So Leute, kurzer Streams, ich guck mal kurz bei Amazon rein und bei ein paar anderen Shops, ob es irgendwas sinnvolles gibt.
Ähm, ich hab ja eigentlich gedacht, dass diese ganze Black Friday Geschichte jetzt rum ist, aber damit hab ich die, Moment, ich muss mir die Sound ein bisschen leiser machen.
Da hab ich die Rechnung ohne Amazon gemacht, ich hab ja gar nicht dran gedacht, dass auf dem Black Friday Monat gefühlt der Cyber Monday noch folgt, ja.
Nicht, dass es da heute was Gescheites gibt, aber wir gucken, wir gucken mal kurz.
Ich hab jetzt eh nix zu tun, ich war zwei Stunden wandern, ich hab gefuddert und eigentlich hab ich mir überlegt, hey, äh, legst du dich mal kurz hin oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Ja, komm, was weiß ich, mach einfach mal Stream an.
Ja, in der Natur tatsächlich, ja.
Oh, morgen krieg ich was von Hermes, MonkaS.
Hermes ist immer, äh, ja, Hermes halt, ne.
Null.
Hermes, naja gut.
Ah, Hermes halt.
Bumba, Dings, Bums, Ba, Ba, Dum, sechs Monat, danke schön für den Sub, excellent.
Oh ne, noch kein Hyper-Subscriber, noch, noch, noch normaler.
Excellent.
Also, guck mal, was es gibt.
Ich hab festgestellt, dass natürlich auch die ganzen China-Shops das, äh, mitmachen, ne, also, die haben alle Banggood.
Wie gesagt, der Shop-Name Banggood ist immer noch der allerbeste Online-Shop.
Äh, der Name aller Zeiten, ne.
Die sind natürlich auch am Start hier, alles Cyber-Monday, Cyber-Monday, Cyber-Monday, was ist mit DH-Gate?
Haben die auch Cyber-Monday, wahrscheinlich haben die auch Cyber-Monday.
Cyber-Monday.
Was?
Diese ganzen China-Shops, ne, diese ganzen China-Shops, die sind alle von, von dem offiziellen China-Web-Design-Ministerium gemacht worden.
Die sehen sich, von der Aufmachung her, die sehen sich alle so ähnlich.
Äh, auch hier, guckt euch diese...
Guckt euch dieses Login-Zeug an.
Das ist alles das gleiche.
So muss das sein, Nico.
Ähm, ja, und alle, und alle sind so dabei, mit allen, bei allen gibt es quasi mehr oder weniger was umsonst.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man hier Dinosaurier kaufen kann.
Was auch immer.
Oh, ach ne, haha, ich hab mich verguckt.
Ich dachte, das wäre wirklich mal was Gutes, aber ist es nicht.
Ist es nicht.
Also, wir gucken uns jetzt mal die üblichen Sachen an.
Also, wir gucken uns mal an, was es in Computer gibt.
Gucken wir uns mal an, was es in Smart Home und in Werkzeuge gibt.
Das ist so eigentlich die Kategorien, die mich hauptsächlich interessieren.
Äh, Gutscheine ist eh da der sinnloseste Grab aller Zeiten.
Also, Gutscheine kaufen ist ja nur wirklich Geld rausgeschmissen.
Das ist so ein excellent Song, ja.
Catch em.
Wir haben doch jetzt, wir haben doch jetzt alle Emotes am Start, Alter.
So, ähm, save on Happy Poo.
Äh, was ist Happy Poo?
Peepo Poo?
Was ist, ist das ein Arsch?
Dusche?
Ach, guck mal da.
Als Wasserflasche.
Das ist quasi wie mein Klo, nur to go.
Hehehe.
Oh, mit Bürst und allem hier.
Ich glaub nicht, dass das so toll ist.
Das ist wie mein Klo.
Warum ist da...
Warum ist da so ein Raspel?
Hä?
Ah, ah, ah.
Okay, normales Klopapier raspelt.
Ah, jetzt hab ich's verstanden.
Jetzt, jetzt hab ich's kapiert, Alter.
Hat ein bisschen gedauert.
Low, low brain, Alter.
Naja, alles braucht keiner.
Ähm, mein Klo ist ja auch nur gut in Kombination.
Ganz ohne Klopapier geht's trotzdem nicht, zumindest bei mir nicht.
Da kommt ja noch der Föhn dabei.
Ähm, und dass man auch variabel Wasser verstellen kann und es warm machen kann.
Ich glaube, das hier ist tatsächlich nicht so gut.
Wenn man unterwegs ist, meinetwegen, mit Feuchttüchern oder so, wenn's sein muss.
Aber seitdem ich mein High-End-Luxus-Klo...
...habe, geh ich, geh ich gar nicht mehr aufs Klo unterwegs.
Ich halt das immer ein, bis ich daheim bin.
Und dann...
...da heim aufs Superklo, ja.
Also, guck, wir fangen mal, wir fangen mal hier.
Was haben wir hier?
Moment, Lightning-Deals?
Ich wollte nicht Lightning-Deals.
Ich wollte Tools.
Ich wollte Smart Home, ich wollte Computer.
Okay, Lightning.
Komoton-Lightning.
Wenn Amazon meint, wir sollen uns Lightning-Deals angucken.
Heimscheißer, genau.
Beste.
Der eigene Klo ist eh der Beste.
Sieht wahrscheinlich eh fast jeder so.
Gab schon irgendwelche Highlights.
Ich hab vor zwei Minuten angemacht.
Aber, so wie ich das aus anderen Sales bei Amazon kenne, gibt's wahrscheinlich wenig Highlights.
So, also, was?
Blitzangebote.
Ah ja, ich brauch tatsächlich was.
Ich brauch ein paar IP68 oder was in der Richtung Boxen.
Aber sowas wird's da wahrscheinlich heute nicht im Angebot geben.
Äh, ja, guck mal mal.
Also, was haben wir denn hier schönes?
Handtücher. Braucht keiner.
Er braucht schon Handtücher.
Das wird ja bedeuten, er wächst.
Er wächst sich auch, ne?
Das ist ja nun mal wirklich...
Also, abwegig.
Ja.
So, ähm...
Powerbanks.
Diese Preise sind immer so heftiger, G-Baid.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was auch G-Baid ist?
Vodafone ist richtiger G-Baid.
Ich hab gestern Abend geschrieben auf Twitter.
Aber, gestern Abend.
Ich wollt ins Bett.
Wollt noch nen Stream gucken.
Ging nicht, weil Vodafone im Arsch ist.
So, ähm...
Da hab ich mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Du machst einfach...
Also...
Du machst einfach 3G und gehst pennen und dann wird's schon wieder gehen.
Da bin ich heute Morgen aufgemacht.
Sieben Stunden später.
Und hab festgestellt, es geht immer noch net.
Und dann, nochmal drei Stunden später, ging's immer noch net.
So, und dann hab ich denen geschrieben.
Also, das ist ja quasi das dritte Mal.
Also, das zweite Mal, wo ich dann an Vodafone direkt geschrieben hab.
Normalerweise kriegen die sowas hier schon immer mit.
Hat immer noch keiner drauf reagiert gehabt.
Aber, ohne Scheiß, ne Viertelstunde später, ging's wieder.
Die...
Ich vermute, die haben noch was gemacht.
Oh, beste.
Excellent Musik.
Ketchup.
Naja, zumindest ne Viertelstunde später ging's wieder.
Und im Nachhinein betrachtet, glaube ich, das war irgendeine Wartungsarbeit von Vodafone, die sie nicht angekündigt haben.
Weil, das ging von...
Guckt euch mal die Zeiten an.
Ich hab das hier gepostet, um...
Also, 11...
12...
Ne, 13...
Hä?
Stimmt nicht.
Ich hab das um 22 Uhr umgef...
23 Uhr?
23 Uhr hab ich das gepostet.
Okay.
Ähm...
Und das hab ich gepostet um...
9.
Ey, Leute.
23 Uhr bis 9.
So glatt ist normalerweise kein Ausfall.
Ich seh hier Illuminati.
Ich seh hier Illuminati, Alter.
Und kurz nach 9 ging's wieder.
Da stimmt doch was nicht.
Alter, was ist mit der Musik los?
Das war nicht übertre...
Ach, das ist Pokémon-Musik.
Aber trotzdem.
Jetzt nicht übertreiben, please.
So.
Ähm...
Das kann doch kein Zufall sein.
23...
Oder...
22 Uhr.
Das ging ja vorher schon nicht.
22 Uhr bis 9 Uhr.
Das kann kein...
Das ist so glatt.
Wie kommen die auf die Ideen der Primetime?
Ich weiß bei Vodafone eh nicht mehr auf was für Ideen, die sonst noch so kommen, ja.
Aber Vodafone ist das eh alles...
Denen ist das eh alles egal mittlerweile.
Ganz schön langes Warnungsfenster, ja.
Das ist verdammt langes Warnungsfenster.
Ein halber Tag Warnungsfenster.
Aber wundert's dich?
Oder würd's dich wundern?
Also mich würd's bei Vodafone nicht mehr wundern.
So.
Also, exzellent.
Zeig ich mal her.
Was haben die hier so?
Komische Hütchen.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
HDMI-Kabel.
Iwanki.
Was ist das denn?
Ist das nicht die Frau von Trump?
Oder ist es Iwanki?
Beides nicht so toll vom Namen her.
So, ähm...
Es sind HDMI-Kabel, die keiner braucht.
Also, wenn ich eins mittlerweile genug hab, sind's HDMI-Kabel.
Zwar keine super high-end China 4K HDMI-Kabel.
Aber HDMI-Kabel hab ich genug.
Ich hab auch kein Gerät mit 4K.
Warte mal, mein Fernseher.
Doch, doch, doch, Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Mein Fernseher ist der mit...
Der muss mit HDMI angeschlossen sein, oder?
Fernseher haben keinen Displayport, ne?
Und das Shield TV hat auch keinen Displayport-Ausgang.
Der Fernseher muss per HDMI angeschlossen sein.
Und mit dem Kabel ging's.
Und das war kein super krasses 4K HDMI-Kabel.
Das ging einfach mit 4K.
Der Friseur hat wieder ein Video gemacht.
Ja, ich weiß.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich hab den Friseur auch noch abonniert.
Oder hat tatsächlich noch ein Video gemacht, ja.
Wieso eigentlich TV mit HDMI?
Naja, weil im TV-Umfeld halt HDMI so das Ding ist.
Das kannst du dir ja nicht aussuchen.
Etwas off-topic, aber hast du schon mitbekommen, wie Corona finanziert werden soll?
Unsere Finanzminister fordern wohl schon Erhöhung des Spitzensteuersatzes.
Die haben alle den Arsch offen.
Ey, gut.
Unser Finanzminister ist ja auch der, der Kanzlerkandidat bei der SPD werden will.
Die haben alle den Arsch offen.
Jetzt mal ganz kurz meine zwei Szenen zu dieser Geschichte.
Wir machen gleich weiter.
Spitzensteuersatz schön und gut.
Ob man den Spitzensteuersatz vielleicht ein bisschen erhöhen sollte, kann man drüber diskutieren.
Aber was ich komplett affig finde in Deutschland ist, ab wann du den Spitzensteuersatz bezahlen musst.
Ich muss Spitzensteuersatz bezahlen.
Ich bin nicht reich oder so.
Du musst in Deutschland ja schon, wenn du, wenn du halbwegs ordentlich verdienst,
musst du Spitzensteuersatz bezahlen.
Spitzensteuersatz sollte meiner Meinung nach was sein, was halt wirklich reiche Leute bezahlen müssen.
Nicht der 0815-Streaming-YouTube-Teilzeitarbeits-Spaß, der hier vorm Rechner sitzt.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Es ist aktuell so, dass quasi das, was man Mittelschicht genannt hat, komplett am Aussterben ist.
Du hast Leute, die rutschen total ab.
Und können kein, können kein, keinerlei Kapital, Vermögen, was auch immer aufbauen.
Du hast welche, ein paar, die rutschen nach oben.
Die kriegen ultra viel Kohle.
Und das, was mal so in der Mitte war, also da, wo ich jetzt gerade bin, ähm, die gehören quasi fast schon zu den,
zu den, rein vom Verhältnis her, was die Leute haben, zu den Reichen.
Ich bin doch nicht reich.
Ich hab keinen goldenen BMW oder irgendwie so einen Scheiß hier stehen.
Ich komm ganz gut über die Runden.
Ich hab auch, ich hab so, ich hab ein Haus.
Ähm, ich verdien ganz gut.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass ich reich wäre in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ja?
Was, was, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Und die, gerade die Leute, die müssen das bezahlen.
Und gerade die Leute müssen das bezahlen.
Natürlich fuckt mich das besonders ab, weil ich davon betroffen bin.
Ne, also.
So, das, das reicht jetzt auch.
Aber das, das finde ich total hängengeblieben.
Die können meinetwegen sogar den Spitzensteuersatz eventuell ein bisschen höher machen.
Aber, meiner Meinung nach wäre es viel, viel sinnvoller, man würde gucken, dass man den Spitzensteuersatz,
eben so macht, dass der, das ist auch, dass du Spitze bezahlst, wenn du halt auch Spitze hast.
Und nicht so einen anderen Kack, wie es jetzt ist.
Ich mein, was sollen denn noch, was sollen die Leute denn noch alles mitbezahlen?
Die Musik ist seltsam, das ist hier Top 100 Nintendo Songs.
Ich finde die Musik äußerst pepejam, ey.
Ja, das, was Tribolon sagt, ist vollkommen richtig.
Ähm, ich hab letztens ein Video drüber geguckt, dass du früher umgerechnet, also wenn man,
wenn man ein bisschen zurückgeht, was weiß ich, 1984 oder so.
Ähm, wenn du da geguckt, wenn du da das hochrechnest, was da der Spitzensteuersatz war,
da musstest du ultra viel verdienen.
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal irgendwie 250.000 Euro oder sowas im Jahr mindestens.
Ich, ich weiß die Zahlen nicht mehr.
Ultra viel im Vergleich zu jetzt.
Ähm, also nicht, nicht für damals, wenn du es hochrechnest auf jetzt, ja.
Das ist dann, das wäre dann auch okay gewesen.
Aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass jeder Typ, der ordentlich verdient, die Chance hat, so ein bisschen Geld aufzubauen,
bisschen Vermögen aufzubauen, dass der gnadenlos voll besteuert wird.
Genau, damals war es das 15-Fache, richtig.
Richtig, also ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, was bei uns los ist.
Das, oh, was ist denn mit der Musik? Die Musik ist zu laut gerade.
Exzellent.
Äh, ja, ja, was auch immer.
Das, das, das ist übrigens meiner Meinung nach eigentlich somit das größte Problem, was wir haben.
Dass der Unterschied zwischen arm und reich immer größer wird.
Und lustigerweise, die Leute mit allem anderen beschäftigt sind, als sich mit dieser elementaren Frage mal auseinanderzusetzen.
Was ist eigentlich los?
Warum, warum bleibt mir so wenig übrig von dem Geld, was ich, was ich eigentlich bekomme?
Warum ist davon eigentlich nichts mehr da?
Warum gibt es so viele Leute in Deutschland, die quasi von Monatsgehalt zu Monatsgehalt leben?
Die, für die ist das, also es ist für ganz viele Leute in Deutschland, ist das unvorstellbar,
dass die spontan einfach mal sich einen 2.000 Euro Fernseher kaufen.
Obwohl die Vollzeit arbeiten gehen und quasi schaffen ohne Ende, ist es bei denen nicht drinnen, dass sie mal sagen,
okay, jetzt gönne ich mir mal irgendwas.
Die, die, die sind quasi am Ende des Monats schon im Minus und schaffen es dann gerade mal so über die Runden mit ihrem nächsten Gehalt.
Ja, vielleicht können sie an Weihnachten, wenn sie mal doppelt was kriegen, ein bisschen was kaufen.
Das kann so nicht sein.
Du solltest nicht arbeiten.
Also dein Leben sollte nicht aus Arbeit bestehen.
Du solltest arbeiten gehen, dass du, dass du ein schönes Leben führen kannst.
Und wenn einer arbeiten geht, sollte er auch ein schönes Leben führen können.
Und nicht von Monatsgehalt zu Monatsgehalt.
Der lebt, wenn du sowas, wenn du, wenn du da drin stehst, du lebst ja nur noch, dass du arbeiten kannst von einem Monat zum anderen.
Das ist mega beschissen.
Warum ich doch auf OBS24 bin?
Weil ich noch nicht abgequält habe.
Ich weiß, da wäre es jetzt nie drauf gekommen.
Hat keine, hat keinen Sinn.
Ja, es gibt 26 OBS 26 hat richtig nice Features.
Nämlich man kann jetzt die Watt Tracks für Twitch mit anderer Musik versorgen.
Also sprich, ich kann jetzt hier im Stream, könnte ich jetzt Metallica spielen und im Watt wäre dann free, free Chilster Playlist oder sowas.
Eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Ja, aber ich belasse, ich belasse es jetzt dabei.
Das ist das ist meine Meinung.
Das ist meine Meinung.
Das ist meine Meinung dazu.
Ich finde das voll für den Arsch.
Ich finde das richtig für den Arsch.
Und auch was mir persönlich, das muss ich jetzt noch dazu sagen.
Wir beschäftigen uns ja mit Diskussionen, mit allem möglichen.
Mit, bloß nicht mit uns.
Die Leute kommen nicht auf die Idee, das mal zu hinterfragen.
Zu sagen, sag mal hier, wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass ich, gehen wir jetzt mal von einem aus, der ein bisschen weniger verdient, 25, 30k im Jahr oder so.
Wie kann es denn sein?
Dass ich von meinen 30k gerade so viel hab, dass ich über die Runden komme und, obwohl ich acht Stunden am Tag arbeiten gehe.
Die Frage stellen sich die Leute nicht.
Und ich finde, das ist eigentlich die wichtigste Frage, die es mal mehr Leute stellen sollten.
Nicht, was weiß ich, wie können wir die ganze Welt retten?
Wie können wir hier machen?
Wie können wir sonst was machen?
Sondern die Leute sollen sich mal ein bisschen auf sich selbst, sie sollen mal wirklich, sie sollen mal ein bisschen Gedanken drüber machen, was das eigentlich soll.
Bist acht Stunden am schaffen und hast von deiner Kohle nichts.
Und dann kommt dann noch dazu, das was mir auf den Sack geht.
Das wenn du siehst, wo dein Geld hinläuft, oder besser gesagt, wo du siehst, wo die Steuern, die du bezahlen musst, die nicht hinlaufen.
Nämlich halt in die Sachen, die mir persönlich wichtig sind, läuft es nicht hin.
Guckt euch mal einen Internetausbau an, eine Infrastrukturausbau generell.
Guckt euch mal an, was für einen Zustand bei uns Krankheits-, Gesundheitssystemen, Kindergärten, Straßen, Tierheime, was auch immer haben.
Also Sachen, die mir wichtig sind, kommt die Kohle irgendwie nicht an.
Ja, und da muss man sich ja fragen, ok.
Ähm.
Ich, ich muss irgendwie, ich krieg noch einen Bruchteil von der Kohle, die ich quasi erarbeite, krieg ich raus.
Und mit dem Geld, was mir abgezogen wird, wird noch nicht mal das gemacht, was ich gerne hätte.
Das ist doch mega, mega, ganz im Ernst.
Das ist eigentlich das, was ich mal wirklich meiner Meinung nach mehr Leute fragen müssen.
Was da eigentlich, was da eigentlich abgeht überhaupt.
Ja, was das eigentlich soll.
Und deswegen.
Ich.
Ihr wisst ja.
Dass ich jahrelang.
Äh.
Mich nicht entscheiden konnte, was, was ich wählen soll.
Terox, 12 Monate.
Dankeschön.
Und ich kann mich immer noch nicht wirklich.
12 Monate ist schon richtig krasse Hyper, Hyper Subs, Subscription.
Ähm.
Was soll ich jetzt sagen?
Äh.
Richtig.
Das seh ich, seh ich ganz genau so.
Seh ich ganz genau so.
Ähm.
Die.
Man kann sich da um die Details.
Man kann sich da um die Details streiten.
Aber.
Mehr.
Übertriebene Regulierung.
Und.
Mehr Regulierung.
Und mehr aufgeblähtes Zeug macht die Sache garantiert nicht besser.
Ja.
Seh ich, seh ich auch so.
Und ich.
Wie gesagt.
Ich wusste jahrelang nicht, was ich wählen sollte.
Ich hab auch.
Ich war immer wählen.
Ich hab aber meistens ungültig gewählt.
Ähm.
Ich hab mich bei der letzten Europawahl.
Dazu hinreißen lassen.
Die Grünen zu wählen.
Was ich im Nachhinein für total bescheuert halte.
Ja.
Ähm.
Aber jetzt.
Ich tendiere.
So doofs klingt.
Ja.
Ich hab mir.
Ich lese mir die Programme manchmal ein bisschen durch.
Und.
Von allen dem.
Leider haben die keine Chance.
Von allen dem muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Wo ich mich noch am ehesten wieder finde.
Ist tatsächlich die FDP.
Hätte ich nie gedacht, dass ich mal irgendwann in Erwägung ziehe die FDP zu wählen.
Tribolon.
Exakt.
So geht's mir auch.
Ich.
Ich mein.
Die werden nix.
Die werden nix reißen.
Die werden auch nix machen können am Ende.
Aber.
Und was die sagen.
Und zwischen dem was sie am Ende machen sind ja immer zwar komplett weilenweite Unterschiede.
Aber.
Ja, die brauchen wir unbedingt, die brauchen wir, die brauchen wir unbedingt, oder ich wähle, wenn ich, ohne Scheiß, wisst ihr, was ich mache, wenn ich immer noch nicht weiß, wen ich wählen soll 2021, dann wähle ich die Tierschutzpartei, bam, so, was, ich habe NPD, gibt es die NPD überhaupt noch, sind die nicht alle bei der AfD jetzt, on stream Wahl-O-Mat, das machen wir, machen wir, ja,
ja, aber ich glaube, die sind nicht mehr alle bei der AfD, ne, es war denen nicht mehr radikal genug, da sind ja viele wieder weg und viele haben dann auch alternative Sachen gegründet, nochmal alternative, zur Alternative und solche Dinger, da sind ja viele wieder weg, die hatten keinen Bock mehr da drauf und gesagt, wie, das ist uns nicht radikal genug, da haben wir keinen Bock mehr drauf, da muss mehr zur Sache gehen, was ist denn die Bierpartei, Alter, ich habe im letzten Wahl-O-Mat, wurde mir vorgeschlagen, ohne Scheiß, wir haben es on stream gemacht, den Wahl-O-Mat,
den hier, aber die für die, ich glaube, für die Europawahl haben wir den, wir haben den Wahl-O-Mat gemacht und, ähm, da ist rausgekommen, ich soll entweder AfD oder die Partei wählen, excellent, ja, letztendlich wäre die Partei wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht gewesen, aber wir machen den Wahl-O-Mat wieder on stream, ja, und ich weiß noch, ich weiß noch, so ein Ding, ähm, da gab es irgendeine, da gab es irgendeine Frage drin,
wollen Sie,
wollen Sie, oder sind Sie dafür, dass quasi Leute, die hier, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es beschrieben wird, also quasi Leute, die hier arbeiten gehen, aber sagen wir aus Schweden, England, sonst wo, irgendwo herkommen, dass die lokal wählen dürfen, so, und da habe ich gesagt, nö, so, und das war halt, das war halt irgendwie die Position, wo halt, das, das nur, nur irgendwie auch zur AfD und die Partei gepasst hat, keine Ahnung, die anderen haben alle gesagt, ja, und ich denke, das immer noch, warum, also ganz ehrlich, wenn, wenn ich irgendwo,
hingehe und da nicht Staatsbürger bin, dann habe ich da auch gefälligst nicht zu wählen, also, ich verstehe, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommt, das geht mich da überhaupt nichts an, ich meine, natürlich wäre es schön, wenn man irgendwie in einer gewissen Art und Weise mitbestimmen könnte, aber ich meine, ich habe nur mal als Staatsbürger gewisse Privilegien, die ich in einem anderen Land nicht habe, deswegen, ich kann ja weiter in meinem Land wählen, ist doch, ist doch okay, ja, ich habe beispielsweise einen Kumpel auf der Arbeit,
kann ich, kann ich so sagen, ist zwar ein Kollege, aber wir verstehen uns ziemlich gut, der kommt aus den USA, oder zumindest der Vater kommt aus den USA, also, da kriegst du ja automatisch einen Pass, wenn du, und der, der macht auch immer Briefwahl, der ist da nie, aber der wählt da auch mit, ist ja okay, der ist ja auch amerikanischer Staatsbürger, aber wenn ich jetzt Engländer bin oder Schwede bin oder so, oder wenn ich in Schweden bin, dann will ich, dann, dann, dann mache ich mir doch gar keine Gedanken, dann komme ich nicht mal auf die Idee,
dass ich in Schweden mitwählen will, vielleicht was wirklich Lokales, aber das hat im Endeffekt eh kaum Auswirkungen, naja, also, ja, Martin, das denke ich auch, die waren wahrscheinlich im Prinzip dagegen und die Partei hat getrollt, das kann, kann schon sein, ja, naja, so, wir gucken uns das bei Amazon an,
oh, Ex-Länder,
also, mal schnell durchscrollen, das war alles Müll bisher,
iiih, was ist das denn,
jetzt sehe ich,
das ist richtig, das ist ein VGA auf HDMI,
was zum,
warum sollte ich denn sowas machen,
für Beamer vielleicht, für, für, für Boomer Beamer,
für so, für, für Schulequipment,
die in der Schule haben die bestimmt noch VGA Beamer,
Leute, als ich in die Schule gegangen bin,
da waren Overhead-Projektoren noch voll angesagt,
da haben die immer, da haben die Lehrer immer auf dem Overhead-Projektor rumgekritzelt,
und zu der Zeit gab es dann auch später noch VGA Beamer,
und die VGA Beamer haben die heute noch,
und wenn die ihre VGA Beamer an irgendwas modernes anschließen wollen,
brauchen sie so einen Kack-Adapter, die gibt es immer noch, ja,
kennt ihr euch, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das bei euch in der Schule war,
aber bei uns war es damals so der neueste Shit,
oder, nein, eigentlich war es nicht der neueste Shit, das war auch schon damals alt,
dass es so Wagen gab mit einem Fernseher drin und einem Videorekorder,
und da haben die Lehrer dann ab und zu mal irgendwelche Physik, Physik-Sendungen und sowas,
äh, so was, und da haben die Lehrer dann ab und zu mal irgendwelche Physik-Sendungen und sowas,
abgespielt auf dem Fernseher, wenn die keinen Bock haben, Unterricht zu machen,
dann hat man dann sich irgendwie so eine Sendung angeguckt,
Moment, mal gucken, ob es sowas in der Richtung gibt, was weiß ich,
Das Atom, alt, alter Film,
äh, das wird ja gar nicht wagen, so Dinge hat man sich da angeguckt in Physik,
hä, viel zu neu alles, viel zu neu,
ja, so Dinge hat man sich da in der Schule angeguckt,
und dann war es so, ähm,
dass unglaublich viele Lehrer, frage ich mich bis heute, wie das geht,
nicht in der Lage waren, diesen Videorekorder-Wagen zu bedienen.
Die haben dann immer diesen Videowagen geholt,
und wussten nicht, wie der Scheiß angeht,
wo ich mir denke, das sind doch nur zwei Knöpp,
wie kann man das nicht schaffen?
Da muss dann immer der Streber vom Dienst vorkommen,
und dem Lehrer den Videorekorder und Fernseher einschalten,
weil der Lehrer zu doof war.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das bei euch vielleicht auch so ist,
aber ich glaube, das ist ein sehr guter Weg,
dass das so gewesen ist, aber,
Vorspulen, ey.
Ja, was ja erschreckend ist,
was ja erschreckend ist,
dass das bei vielen heute noch so ist,
ich mein, ernsthaft, Videowagen,
da wundert mich ja, da wundert mich ja nix mehr.
Ey, sowas haben wir nicht geguckt.
Wir haben, wir haben so Physik-Sendungen geguckt,
also die Musik willst du aber echt wissen,
äh, wir haben so Physik-Sendungen geguckt,
von so einem Typ, da kann ich mich heute noch dran erinnern,
der hat alles so besonders betont ausgesprochen,
der hat nicht gesagt,
das ist, das ist ein Elektron,
oder so, der hat gesagt, es ist ein Elektron,
ein Elektron, vielleicht kennt das hier was.
Das Elektron.
An den Kack kann ich mich heute noch erinnern.
Ja,
schon geil, dass das immer noch so ist, oder?
2015, ah,
wie Overhead-Projektor, ach du Scheiße.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht,
okay, was, aber muss ich mal überlegen,
Telekul, ja,
sowas, sowas haben wir geguckt, genau.
Ja, so ne Kacke,
haben wir damals geguckt.
Sowas haben wir damals geguckt, genau.
Excellent Quali.
So, so, so, so Krempel haben wir damals geguckt, ja.
So in, in der Machart, ja, aber nicht,
aber nicht von diesem Typ.
Ich mein, man muss sich doch nicht wundern, guck mal,
wenn wir hier Leute haben, die 2019, 2015, aber sogar noch 2010,
so was in der Schule sich geben mussten.
Da muss man sich doch nicht wundern, dass das mit Digitalisierung und ein bisschen fortschrittlich im Kopf sein und so,
dass das nicht funktioniert, oder?
Wo soll denn das herkommen?
Ich mein, vom Baum fällt das nicht.
Genau, da hat man richtig Bock, Physik zu studieren, wenn man sowas geguckt hat, ja.
Ne, ne, also das, ja, und dann wundert man sich, jetzt wo Corona am Start ist, oh, warum klappt das mit Rimo?
Ja, und dann wundert man sich, jetzt wo Corona am Start ist, oh, warum klappt das mit Rimo?
Und das ist ja auch der Grund, warum man nur das die Rimo-Unterricht nicht macht.
Ja, klar, weil 90% der Lehrer nie gelernt haben, mit Technik irgendwie umzugehen.
Mittlerweile ist es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen besser,
weil auch viele jüngere Lehrer am Start sind,
Lehrer bei mir in der Berufsschule,
der hat immer World of Warcraft Forum gelesen nebenbei,
der war ja auch ein bisschen jünger,
der war so alt wie ich jetzt bin, ungefähr.
Ähm...
Und, ansonsten
kannst du jetzt doch komplett knicken.
Die schaffen's nicht.
Es gibt
zu wenig Lehrer,
können. Die meisten sind dazu gar nicht in der Lage.
Und ich erzähl's ja immer gerne.
Einen, wo ich gerade erzählt
hab hier, der
amerikanische Staatsbürger ist da von mir auf der Arbeit.
Der hat eine Tochter in Kolumbien,
glaube ich.
Und der hat mir erzählt, in Kolumbien,
die machen seit einem halben Jahr nur Remote-Unterricht.
Und das klappt.
Kolumbien!
Nix gegen
Kolumbien. Aber wenn man so
mal auf ein Papier guckt, wer könnte
besser es technisch,
organisatorisch und
infrastrukturell hinbekommen
mit Remote-Unterricht? Deutschland
oder Kolumbien? Wenn man da mal
international so eine Umfrage machen würde, würden
natürlich alle sagen, ja klar, Deutschland.
Deutschland ist ja recht fortschrittlich. Aber,
wenn man ehrlich ist, nein, es ist Kolumbien.
Kolumbien kriegt's hin.
Wir
kriegen's jetzt so ansatzweise hin.
Also,
der ist Lehrer und
der hat jetzt auch manchmal Remote-Unterricht und so.
Aber,
ja, nicht so
wirklich gut, ja.
Kind geht dort auf eine Privatschule.
Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, also, so viel Geld,
dass die sich da irgendeine Privatschule
leisten können,
hat der, glaube ich, nicht.
Ja, gut, Spinning Frog,
da hast du recht. Guck dir die
Ottos an für die Digitalisierung zuschauen.
Das ist richtig, ja, da hast du recht.
Guck dir die Ottos an, die Dings Artikel,
was Artikel? 13 Artikel, 15, 17,
ich hab's schon wieder vergessen. Oder jetzt,
guck dir die Ottos an, ja,
die, die, die diese Verschlüsselungsgeschichte
gerade durchgewunken haben.
Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Ja, genau. Ja.
Habt ihr denn gerade mitbekommen?
Das ist so,
so realitätsfern,
was da beschlossen wurde.
Das ist, das
funktioniert nicht.
Du kannst nicht sagen, es ist
nur teilweise verschlüsselt,
so nach dem Motto,
ähm, du darfst es
verschlüsseln,
aber es muss für uns
entschlüsselbar bleiben.
Ja, das ist, äh, im Prinzip TLDR.
Ja, die sagen, ja, ja, ist okay,
äh, verschlüsselt, aber sorgt
dafür, dass ihr es für uns entschlüsseln könnt.
So.
Aber der Witz ist ja, das funktioniert ja
nicht. Das ist ja nicht die Art und
Weise, wie Verschlüsselung funktioniert.
Deswegen sage ich ja auch
immer, wenn es irgendeinen Anbieter gibt,
wo ihr Daten hochladen, also,
der, der sagt, ich, wir, sie verschlüsseln eure
Daten. Und ihr habt euer Passwort verschlüsselt,
das habt ihr vergessen. Und der Anbieter kann
das euch wiederherstellen, in irgendeiner Art und
Weise, wenn ihr sowas vergessen habt. Dann ist es nicht
richtig verschlüsselt. Also,
eines der elementarsten
Sachen, wenn es um Verschlüsselung geht, ist,
Passwort weg, Daten weg.
Das ist ganz einfach.
Und was man bei, verwendet
einer von euch vielleicht TrueCrypt oder Veracrypt,
um seine Festplatte zu verschlüsseln.
Die sagen einem ja am Anfang, man soll
eine Backup-CD anlegen. Oder
Backup-USB-Stick oder sowas. Aber,
das ist glaube ich das, was auch viele falsch
verstehen. Das ist kein Backup,
wenn du dein Passwort vergessen hast.
Das Backup
von Veracrypt ist
nicht dafür da, wenn du dein Passwort
vergessen hast. Das Backup von
Veracrypt ist dafür da, wenn
deine Festplatte auf
den Veracrypt-Sektoren beschädigt
ist, sodass Veracrypt
die eigentlichen Keys
nicht mehr mit deinem Passwort
entschlüsseln kann, weil die Keys kaputt
sind. Also, Veracrypt macht es ja so,
du hast auf der Festplatte,
vorne auf der Festplatte,
also das hier, ne. Du hast vorne
auf der Festplatte, ihr seht auch, ich habe mein System
komplett verschlüsselt.
Allein schon aus dem Grund, weil ich die
Festplatte einfach in den Müll schmeißen kann dann.
Veracrypt
macht das so, die schreiben
vorne auf die Festplatte
Keys und die schreiben die gleichen Keys
nochmal hinten auf die Festplatte. Warum?
Falls die Festplatte kaputt geht.
Eventuell ist vorne nicht mehr lesbar, hinten aber noch.
Vorne wird auch mal ganz gerne unter,
überschrieben, falls Windows Scheiße baut
oder wie auch immer. Das sind die,
aber diese Keys,
die sind wiederum mit eurem Passwort verschlüsselt,
was ihr eingeben müsst beim Starten.
Bei Lux ist es genauso.
Bei Lux ist es ganz genauso.
Das Passwort, was ihr eingebt, ist
nicht wirklich das Passwort,
was verwendet wird, um
hier Verschlüsselung zu machen.
Das ist, das funktioniert unter der Haube
nicht richtig, weil die Keys müssen eine gewisse Länge
haben, dass man, das ist
bisschen komplizierter. Aber die
Keys, die VeraClub auf der Platte speichert,
einmal vorne, einmal hinten, die sind mit eurem
Passwort verschlüsselt. Das heißt, wenn ihr
das Passwort vergesst, vergessen
habt, dann bringt euch auch die Recovery
CD nix. Die Recovery CD
oder der Recovery USB Stick
ist nur dafür da, wenn die Festplatte
beschädigt ist. Äh, wie
verhält sich das mit M2 Platten? Ist der Anfang und Ende
physisch gewandt? Ne, logisch.
Also, so wie es der Controller
ausgibt. Quasi
erster Sektor, letzter Sektor.
Wie das unter der Haube
der SSD-Controller
handelt, äh, hat das
keine Ahnung von. Ne, ne, also mit
hinten und vorne ist das gemeint, was der Controller meldet.
Da gibt's ja
logischerweise, gibt's immer einen hinten und vorne. Ob das
jetzt wirklich auf dem,
wenn du die SSD aufschraubst,
ob das der erste Chip ist,
in der linken unteren Ecke und dann
der letzte Sektor im rechten
oberen Eck ist, das ist natürlich sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Ähm, aber wenn du dir
die Sachen anguckst
auf Betriebssystemebene, dann
hast du schon irgendwo was, wo das Medium
anfängt, irgendwas, wo das Medium aufhört.
Also sprich, was dir der Controller so meldet.
Ja, gut.
Ähm, excellent.
So, wir wollten eigentlich, eigentlich wollten wir Amazon gucken, ne.
Kann man eigentlich auch
DVDs oder Blu-rays verschlüsseln?
Klar.
Du kannst alles verschlüsseln.
Du kannst prinzipiell,
du kannst prinzipiell alles verschlüsseln.
Wo davon wieder am Start? Ja.
Zum Glück.
Passwortmanager ist schon mal ein guter Anfang.
Da bist du besser als 99%
der Leute auf der Welt,
wenn du einen ordentlichen Passwortmanager verwendest.
Es ist auch erstmal nicht so wichtig,
welcher. Ich persönlich schwöre
jetzt seit Jahren auf KeyPass,
aber es hängt ein bisschen
von ab, was man machen will, ja.
BitWarn ist ganz gut zum Beispiel, wenn man unterwegs
drauf zugreifen will oder es vielleicht auch aufs Handy
synken will oder irgendwelche Geschichten oder so.
Ich benutze halt, äh, OnePassword kann
ich noch nicht verwenden, kann ich nichts dazu sagen. Ähm,
aber generell Sachen, wo alles
in der Cloud gespeichert wird,
bin ich jetzt kein Freund von. Also,
wenn es um Google Passwortmanager oder sonst was
geht...
Also,
wenn in die Cloud, dann nur, wenn ich sichergestellt
habe, dass es vorm Upload verschlüsselt ist.
Was man ja schlecht kann, weil kaum einer
die Software wirklich verifiziert, die da verwendet wird.
Leute, die Big Brain sind,
die sich alles merken können, die können es natürlich auch im Kopf machen.
Aber ich habe mittlerweile glaube ich 130
oder sowas um den Dreh
Accounts da drin in meinem Passwortmanager.
Also, viel Spaß, das
im Kopf zu merken.
Ja, Bitworn ist okay.
Äh, übrigens, das hier, ne?
Passwortmanager für Boomer.
Notizzettel in Schreibtischschublade.
Das ist gar nicht übel.
Passwörter
auf einem Zettel.
Wisst ihr, was nämlich der riesen Vorteil ist, auch
gegenüber einem Passwortsave?
Also, wenn mich einer fragt,
Max, was ist sicherer?
Einen verschlüsselten Passwortsave wie KeyPass
oder einen Zettel,
dann muss ich ihm ganz ehrlich antworten,
der Zettel ist sicherer.
Also, wenn es rein darum geht, wie sicher das ist, dass es jemand
mitschneiden soll, der Zettel ist sicherer.
Weil der Zettel hat einen
unglaublichen Vorteil
gegenüber so einem Passwortmanager.
Da ist so eine
Mediengrenze dazwischen. Sprich,
das eine ist halt auf dem
Computer gespeichert. Sprich,
wenn jemand bei euch einen Backdoor, Keylogger
oder was auch immer installiert hat,
dann kann man relativ
easy so einen KeyPass abgreifen.
Wir hatten zum Beispiel mal auf der Arbeit,
hatten wir mal
ein Virus oder
was auch immer es war.
Da haben die Leute wieder auf E-Mail-Anhänge geklickt.
Glücklicherweise bin ich dafür
nicht mehr zuständig, ich habe das nur mitgekriegt.
Und die haben sich ein Virus eingefangen,
der KeyPass
Dateien dumpt.
Also sprich, das Ding hat
darauf gewartet, bis einer sein Passwort eingibt
und hat dann, vermute ich mal,
den Speicherinhalt von KeyPass abgegriffen.
Und man hat dann
später die KeyPass-Files
auf einem Windows-Share gefunden.
Da lagen dann
auf einem Windows-Share
Textdateien
mit Amazon-Loggins und sowas drin.
Ja.
Also das ist nicht so
ohne weiteres.
Wie habt ihr das gelöst? Alle Dinge
abgeschaltet. Neu installiert.
Also ich habe es ja zum Glück gar nicht machen müssen.
So und
was wollte ich jetzt da?
Ich wollte da irgendwo drauf raus. Ja.
Das kann dir mit einem Zettel
nicht passieren.
Wer auch immer hier Zettel geschrieben hat,
ja. Das kann dir mit einem Zettel nicht passieren.
Wenn du einen Zettel hast und im Schrank
liegen hast, der
hilft dir zwar nicht,
wenn du illegale Sachen machst
und bei dir wird das Haus durchsucht,
dann hast du aber meistens schon wirklich Scheiße gebaut,
wenn bei dir das Haus durchsucht wird, ja.
Aber gegen die
0815-Hexa-Dudes hilft
ein Zettel fast besser als ein KeyPass.
Ja.
Also Zettel ist gut.
Zettel ist top, top, top Passwortmanager.
Gibt es Passwortmanager, die
die Passwörter eingeben ohne, ja es gibt
für KeyPass gibt es ein paar Browser-Erweiterungen,
die das machen können, aber letztendlich
in irgendeiner Art und Weise muss das ja immer in
Arbeitsspeicher, in irgendeiner Art und Weise muss das immer in Arbeitsspeicher.
Es muss vielleicht nicht in Clipboard-Speicher,
aber es muss in irgendeiner Weise in Arbeitsspeicher.
Also gibt es auch Browser-Erweiterungen
für KeyPass für.
Ähm.
Aber letztendlich
es muss irgendwo unverschlüsselt
im RAM landen, anders geht es gar nicht.
Das ist halt das,
wo du es abgreifen kannst.
So, also gucken wir mal.
So, der Felix hatte mal so eine
komische Maus, so eine super ergonomische.
Ich fand das ja äußerst
gewöhnungsbedürftig, hat mir nicht gefallen.
Hab mich ehrlich, was denn?
Was, was, wie, wo, hä?
Der Schlüssel ist einfach.
Du musst den Salt wissen, du musst wissen,
äh, was du für ein Passwort eingegeben
hast.
Und welcher Algorithmus verwendet wird,
dann kannst du es entschlüsseln.
Drei Sachen brauchst du.
Passwort, Klartext, Salt
und Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus.
Dann kannst du den Kram, äh.
Also wenn es eine Verschlüsselung ist,
nicht wenn es gehashed ist in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ein Hash ist keine Verschlüsselung,
Hash ist eine One-Way-Funktion.
Also wenn ich was hashe,
kann ich aus dem Hash nie wieder
das Original rekonstruieren.
Wenn ich was verschlüssele,
ist ja gerade der Unterschied, wenn ich was verschlüssele,
kann ich mit einem Passwort
quasi aus dem verschlüsselten Text
den Klartext wiederherstellen, bei einem Hash nicht.
Wie lang ist mein Masterpasswort?
Ich glaube 25 Stellen oder so.
Irgendwie so über den Daumen gepeilt.
So, aber wir gucken jetzt mal wirklich ein bisschen Amazon.
Na ja, MD5 kannst du auch nicht
wirklich umkehren.
Du kannst halt MD5
im Voraus berechnen.
Das ist ja das, was viele schon gemacht haben.
Du kannst viel MD5 im Voraus berechnen.
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt ein paar andere,
es gibt noch ein paar Schwachstellen bei MD5.
Und du kannst halt
mittlerweile auch dadurch, dass du mit Grafikkarten
so schnell bist, der Sache
irgendwie noch auf die Spur
kommen. Aber für die
nur nach 15 Sachen daheim, da ist
MD5 eigentlich immer noch okay.
Aber wozu?
Wozu MD5, wenn man auch
SHA-256 oder sowas verwenden kann?
Das ist eine äußerst gute
Frage.
Ja klar, aber wie sollen die IT-Firmen
an das Passwort kommen, wenn es dort auf dem Server
schon verschlüsselt liegt?
Wenn es gut gemacht ist und der einzig
richtige Weg ist, gar nicht.
Gar nicht.
Jeder Service, der es dir erlaubt,
dein Passwort zu recoveren oder
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
verschlüsselte Dateien wiederherzustellen,
der hat sie nicht richtig verschlüsselt.
Verschlüsselung heißt Passwort weg, Daten
weg. Ganz einfach.
Und das Entschlüssel muss kleinseitig passieren.
Das Entschlüssel muss
kleinseitig passieren. Also sprich,
es wird bei dir
lokal, mal angenommen
du hast jetzt irgendeinen Cloud-Dienst,
wo du Dateien hochlädst und die sagen,
hey, wir speichern das nur verschlüsselt.
Dann kriegst du eine Software von denen
oder vielleicht ist es ein Browser-Add-on
oder eine Website oder was auch immer.
Du klickst auf den Upload-Knopf oder du ziehst
eine Datei rein, die du da hochladen willst.
Mega macht es ja so.
Mega macht es ja so ähnlich, zumindest.
Du gehst auf die Seite,
ziehst deine Datei da rein,
sie ist lokal bei dir verschlüsselt,
hochgeladen
und Mega hat keine Ahnung,
was bei ihnen liegt.
Also Mega macht da noch ein paar mehr
Tricks, weil du kannst ja mit Mega,
bei Mega kannst du mit einem Link dann die Sache auch einfach wieder entschlüsseln.
Aber mal angenommen, du hast jetzt sowas wie
Was gibt es denn eigentlich für
Verschlüsselung?
Ich verwende mein eigenes Zeug.
Keine Ahnung, aber wenn du einen Cloud-Dienst hast, der sagt,
sie verschlüsseln alles,
dann muss Boxcryptor zum Beispiel,
dann musst du das lokal verschlüsseln,
hochladen,
runterladen auf dem anderen Rechner
und dort lokal wieder entschlüsseln.
Anders kann das nicht funktionieren.
Ja gut, bei VeraCrypt ist es ja so.
Aber VeraCrypt geht halt nicht unbedingt über die Cloud,
weil VeraCrypt, das ist übrigens auch der Nachteil,
wo wir gerade schon dabei sind,
von VeraCrypt Volumes,
VeraCrypt Volumes
sind ziemlich
kacke für die Cloud.
Weil
VeraCrypt Volumes
sich bei kleinen Änderungen
oftmals
viel ändern.
Das bedeutet, du änderst 5 Bytes
in einem 5 GB großen
VeraCrypt Container
und am Ende sieht der
quasi für jemand, der das ganze nur
verschlüsselt sieht, aus, als wäre die komplette
Datei geändert. Also sprich, du änderst
ein Textfile in deinem VeraCrypt Container
und er lädt 5 GB wieder neu hoch,
weil er denkt, die Datei hat sich komplett geändert.
Äh, das steht ja so nicht drin.
Das ist ja gerade der Witz dabei.
So wie ich das gelernt habe,
das steht da gar nicht so genau drin.
Da steht einfach nur, dass
irgendwie die Möglichkeit geschaffen werden muss
oder sowas. Und die Firmen sagen halt,
das geht nicht, wir können es nicht nur
halb verschlüsseln. Das funktioniert nicht.
Wenn wir es verschlüsseln, dann wissen
wir selber nicht, was drin ist.
Aber so muss es ja eigentlich auch sein.
So muss es eigentlich sein.
Wenn was wirklich sinnvoll verschlüsselt
ist, dann weißt nur du,
was drin ist, beziehungsweise
du musst doch nicht mal wissen, was drin ist.
Du weißt, wie du dran kommst. Das ist das Wichtige.
Du brauchst dein Passwort. Dort, wo du es hochlädst,
die haben keine Ahnung, was da drin ist.
Ähm, die können das auch nicht rauskriegen,
wenn das ordentlich verschlüsselt ist.
Und äh, wenn du dein Passwort
verloren hast, ist es vorbei.
Und die Frage, was mit Passwortresets ist,
ist im Prinzip das Gleiche.
Ein Anbieter, der dir dein Passwort
resetten kann, dass du wieder Zugriff
auf deine verschlüsselten Daten bekommst,
da ist zumindest
irgendwo eine Hintertür,
wie du wieder dran kommen kannst.
Sonst können sie kein Passwortreset schicken.
Wie Passwortreset bei Veracrypt funktioniert
oder bei Lux, die machen das ein bisschen anders.
Ich hab ja gesagt,
Veracrypt verschlüsselt eure
Festplatte nicht wirklich mit dem
Passwort, was ihr eingegeben habt,
sondern mit Random Keys, die sie
am Anfang der Platte und am Ende der Platte speichern.
So. Und
diese Keys, da kann man
verschiedene Passwörter hinterlegen, mit denen man die
entschlüsseln kann. Also sprich, man kann
beispielsweise, bei Lux geht's, wie es bei Veracrypt ist,
weiß ich nicht. Bei Lux kannst du zum Beispiel,
also Lux ist quasi das Veracrypt
von Linux, ja. Bei Lux kannst du
zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, drei
Passwörter hinterlegen oder so.
Kein Problem. Da kannst du mit drei
verschiedenen Passwörtern deine Platte entschlüsseln.
Weil unter der Haube dieses Passwort nur
dazu dient, den eigentlichen
Encryption Key zu verschlüsseln. Das hat nämlich
den großen, ähm,
das hat nämlich den großen Vorteil,
wenn du dein Passwort änderst,
musst du nicht die komplette Festplatte
re-encrypten. Ansonsten,
wenn die nämlich dein Passwort verwenden würden,
um deine komplette Festplatte zu verschlüsseln,
müsstest du jedes Mal,
wenn du dein Passwort änderst, deine
komplette Festplatte entschlüsseln
und neu verschlüsseln. Das dauert ja ewig.
Ja.
Das ist tatsächlich so, ja.
Ja, gut, die
Leute checken das nicht. Das wird ja auch absichtlich
gemacht. Es wird auch absichtlich nicht großartig
breitgetreten. Es wird auch absichtlich so gemacht, dass es kaum
einer checkt. Der Witz ist ja, dass die, die das verabschieden,
wahrscheinlich auch nicht checken.
Also, ansonsten würden da nicht so komische Dinger drinstehen.
Das ist richtig.
Block Device Sync ist doof.
Genau. Ich benutze KeyPass, aber ein Zettel ist auch okay.
Nur Noobs
sagen, Zettel sind nicht gut. Sag ich jetzt einfach mal.
Äh, Zettel sind vollkommen okay für Passwörter.
Es sei denn, du hast, es sei denn,
es sei denn, du bist jemand, der
wirklich komische Dinger treibt
und eventuell mal die Polizei zu dir nach Hause
kommt, dann ist ein Zettel keine gute Idee.
Aber wenn du einfach nur jemand bist,
der nicht will, dass der Keylogger seine Passwörter
abgreift, ähm,
dann ist ein Zettel
eines der besten Sachen, was du machen kannst.
Weil durch diese
Barriere von Computer zu
Offline-Zettel kommt da
kein Hackerman dran.
Vielleicht ein Passwort einzeln nacheinander
mit einem Keylogger.
KeyPass. Ich benutze KeyPass.
Ich benutze aber KeyPass hauptsächlich, weil ich seit Jahren
schon KeyPass verwende.
Gar nicht. Ich weiß nicht genau, von was ich
habe. Gar nicht. Nur du kannst das.
Nur du kannst das.
Wenn du einen verschlüsselten Cloud-Dienst verwendest,
die das richtig machen,
dann werden die Daten bei dir
lokal verschlüsselt,
verschlüsselt hochgeladen. Der Anbieter hat
keine Ahnung. Und wenn du die Daten wieder
haben willst, dann lädst du dir die
verschlüsselten, verschlüsselten
encrypteten Datei
lädst du dir runter und
entschlüsselst sie lokal bei dir wieder.
Der Schlüssel verlässt nie
deinen Kopf quasi oder deinen
Passwort-Safe oder deinen lokalen
Rechner. Und wenn du das Passwort
vergisst, hast du gelitten.
Wenn du dein Passwort vergisst, hast du gelitten.
Du kannst
das alles
nur ändern, wenn du dein Passwort
noch hast.
Also beispielsweise Veracrypt oder
Lux, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich möchte mein Passwort
ändern, wie ich mein System verschlüsselt habe,
dann geht das nur, wenn ich mein Passwort noch weiß.
Wenn ich mein Passwort nicht mehr weiß, dann
geht das nicht.
Das ist der Sinn von Verschlüsselung.
Wenn das
Passwort weg ist, sind die Daten weg.
Fertig. Und nur so kann Bescheid und
Verschlüsselung funktionieren.
So, aber wir gucken jetzt mal echt bei Amazon, ey.
Ich habe mich jetzt ja schon eine Stunde über alle möglichen Sachen
oder so ausgelassen.
Aber ihr wisst ja, ich bin
Meister, Meister im Sidetracked werden.
Excellent.
So, also bis jetzt war nur Müll dabei.
Da gibt es irgendwelche super...
Da sollten sich die Schulen mal ein bisschen
was von anschaffen hier.
HDMI auf VGA.
Das ist für die ollen Beamer, die die haben,
bestimmt wunderbar.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich nicht irgendwelche Subs ver...
Oh, hier.
Andreas X subscribes Prime Gaming.
Was zum Teufel ist Prime Gaming?
Was ist Prime Gaming?
Ist das der kostenlose Prime Sub?
Ah, das ist der Prime Sub.
Ich wusste... Mir fällt zum ersten Mal
auf, dass da Prime Gaming steht.
Weil in meinem anderen Browser
steht nur Prime.
Und hier steht Prime Gaming.
Excellent.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Was habe ich übersehen?
Ich hoffe nix.
Äh...
Tsuga Tsatsango.
Für zwei Monat. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exquisite Subscription.
Äh...
Okay, passt. Ich glaube, ich habe nix vergessen.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir ein bisschen Amazon.
Also, was haben wir hier?
Da sollten sich echt mal jede Schule ein 50er Pack von kaufen,
dass sie ihre ollen Beamer verwenden können.
Äh... Braucht kein Mensch.
Braucht kein Mensch.
Gibt's eigentlich schöne... Gibt's eigentlich schöne
iPhone...
XR Hüllen.
Im Prime
Cyber Monday Deal.
Brauch nämlich eine.
Die sind aber nicht schön.
Ach du große Kacke.
Im Zebralook.
Kappa Brite Hülle. Was ist das denn?
Schon was gefunden?
Nee.
Oh ja, Gänseblümchen. Nice.
Wisst ihr an was mich das erinnert?
Das erinnert mich...
Das erinnert mich übelst
an die Logitech Maus mit den Beulen.
Kennt ihr noch... Kennt noch...
Äh... 518
hieß das Ding? Nee, MX518.
Die mit den Beulen. Kennt ihr noch jemand?
Ja, Leopard und Zebra kommen sich doch fast
gleich aus.
Kennt noch jemand die Beulen Maus?
Das war... Das war früher die Gaming Maus.
Der... Der Shit
ging schlecht hin an Gaming Maus.
Mittlerweile ist die nicht mehr so gut.
Weil Sensor ziemlich sackt.
Außer der Refresh, der mag vielleicht ganz gut sein.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber das war damals der... Die beste Maus überhaupt.
Oh, das war's für mich hier. Excellent.
Wobei... Warum hat das Katzenohren, Alter?
Können die die Katzen...
Ich find die... Ich find die Hülle so find ich echt cool.
Aber ich will da keine Katzenohren
oben dran haben. The fuck?
Oh, das sieht billig aus.
Guckt mal wie schlecht das ausgeschnitten ist.
Da haben die chinesischen Kinderarbeiter
nicht richtig ordentlich ausgeschnitten.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Ja, Logitech
hat eine neue Version rausgebracht. Das ist jetzt aber auch
schon ein bisschen älter.
Oh, ich werde gerade G-Bated.
Ich werde gerade G-Bated.
Ich hab irgendeine Message bekommen, wo einer
sagt, er gehört zu Twitch. Da bin ich ja immer skeptisch.
Musste mal kurz überprüfen, ob das wirklich so ist.
Hmm...
Ok, könnte wirklich echt sein.
Ok, könnte echt sein, ja.
Lul.
Hey, da muss man vorsichtig sein, ja.
Chat-Message-Highlight-Tool.
Spannend, spannend. Muss ich mir mal angucken.
Ich hab mir
selbst sowas gebastelt, was Chats
highlightet. Ich müsste das mal
ausprobieren.
Ich hab's aber bloß
grad nicht an. Ich hab mir sowas ähnliches
selbst gebastelt, was denn die Messages highlight.
Warum auch immer. Fragt mich...
Das ist übelst unoptimiert hier mit dem Chat.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich hab's aber auf dem zweiten Bildschirm auf.
So, ähm...
So, gucken wir mal weiter. Also, was haben wir denn hier Schönes noch?
Also...
Was haben wir denn noch? Zeig mal da.
Ne, ne, ne.
Nicht Band und auch nicht Monkatos.
Zum Glück, man weiß ja nie, ey.
Man weiß ja nie.
Oh, oh, hier. Message.
Huge, huge Message.
Meine Lehrer haben mich gefragt, wie man am besten
Kabel vom Laptop zum Wipe... Ach, okay.
Na gut, warum nicht? Weil man... Die wissen wahrscheinlich,
du kennst dich aus, ja?
Habe ich denen gesagt, dass mein Vater...
What?
Das ist T-Baid, oder?
Das hast du denen nicht ernsthaft erzählt. Das ist T-Baid.
Also, also quasi...
So, wir müssen jetzt mal
gucken, ob da irgendwas dabei ist.
Ich wollte eigentlich, Leute...
Eigentlich wollte ich schon wieder weg sein.
Aber...
Es funktioniert, ey.
Okay, Handyhüllen gibt es nichts gescheites. Sieht alles Kacke aus.
Okay, schauen wir mal an.
Also, alles Mist. Brauchen wir nicht.
Brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht. Was ist das denn?
Ist das für die Corona-Proteste?
Das ist alles
nicht am Start.
Sättke. Guck mal.
Ist das nicht... Ja, ne. S-G-O.
Ich habe irgendwie gerade Sättke gelesen.
Ich frage mich nicht, wie oft...
Okay, das ist eine Ski-Maske. Alles klar.
Jetzt habe ich es auch kapiert.
Wisst ihr, das sind die Masken, die auf den
China-Kamera-Herstellern immer als Einbrecher
auf den Thumbnails sind.
Ähm... Pass mal auf.
Moment.
Oh, die haben gar kein Bild vom Einbrecher drauf.
Ähm... Ach, fuck.
Ich brauche immer... Äh...
Hikvision haben immer so Dinger drauf.
Alter.
Jetzt, wo ich sie suche,
finde ich es nicht.
Die haben auf diesen Bildern immer exakt diese Typen
mit Ski-Masken drauf.
So was da. Warum?
Warum haben die jetzt... Warum haben die keine
Leute mit Ski-Masken drauf?
Jetzt, wenn du sie suchst, findest du sie nicht.
Ja, so was hier.
Guck. Aber das ist eine andere Maske.
Das sieht exakt wie
die Ski-Maske aus, die die China-Typen immer haben.
Hier. So was. So Leute sind
da immer auf den Bildern drauf.
Aber der hat einfach nur Hoodie und Schal um.
Ja.
Das ist richtig Vorführeffekt.
Übrigens, Leute. Das ist das, was ich meine.
Ähm...
Was die Taktik bei Amazon ist.
Oder wo ich zumindest glaube, was die Taktik bei Amazon ist.
Du musst
dich durch so einen Riesenhaufen Müll wühlen,
dass du
am Ende, wenn du was findest,
ich hab's ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass
wenn du am Ende was findest,
was dir halbwegs gefällt, dass du's dann
kaufst, weil du schon so lange dich durch den Müll
gewählt hast. Hast du kein NoScript?
Ne, hab ich nicht. Ich hab
AdBlock, äh, AdBlock,
äh, Origin, ne, uBlock, uBlock Origin
mit ein paar Custom-Regeln.
Das reicht. Ich hatte früher,
im Firefox hatte ich immer NoScript.
Aber leid, leider, leider
kann man es nicht mehr gut verwenden.
Seit, also mittlerweile wieder, aber
immer noch nicht so gut wie vorher.
Seit Firefox 68, wo sie
ihre Plugin-API geupdatet haben.
Seitdem ist NoScript nicht mehr so gut.
Ah, okay. Ah, Twitch
ist ja Big Brain, Alter.
Jetzt seh ich's ja auch. Wie gesagt, ich hab...
Twitch-Mitarbeiter haben ja einen
Mitarbeiter-Tag neben dem Bild.
Ah. Da hätte ich gar nicht nachgucken müssen,
ob das echt ist. Es gibt wohl
irgendwie ein neues Chat-Highlighting-Tool.
Ah, das ist praktisch. Das guck ich mir später mal an.
Excellent.
Äh, zockst du eigentlich noch?
Ab und zu mal ein bisschen Path of Exile, aber die League
hab ich nicht gespielt. Okay, also
es ist ja wirklich nur Müllmüller dabei.
Übrigens, ich glaub,
die hol ich mir nochmal. Welche Größe
sind das? Äh, Größe?
Ob ich da irgendwo wie groß die sind?
Ah, hier. 10 Millimeter, also
ein Zentimeter.
Ungefähr Daumennagel groß.
Ja. Ich glaube, davon hol ich
mir wirklich mal welche.
Ich claim mir das mal schnell.
Ach, fuck. Ich kann mich ja hier nicht
einloggen. Okay, Blitz-Deal ist gelaufen.
Ist vorbei. Egal.
Scheiß drauf. Aber davon.
Davon könnte ich tatsächlich noch ein Pack brauchen.
Wobei, ich mach das einfach auf dem zweiten
Bildschirm. Easy. Oh, ich mach das
einfach auf dem zweiten Bildschirm. Accept. Jawohl.
Zack. Add.
Add to Basket.
Bam. So.
Zack.
Haben wir schon mal was.
Äh, Meinung zu Browsern,
die deine Privatsphäre schützen sollen.
Zum Beispiel Brave.
Ich hab mal Brave ne Weile verwendet.
Benutz ich nicht mehr.
Ich kann dir gar nicht mehr sagen, warum.
Hat mich irgendwie nicht so überzeugt.
Ich benutze auf Android
benutze ich den hier. ProMite.
Das ist quasi
nen Chrome, den
sie ein bisschen entgoogelt haben.
Den verwende ich auf Android. Der hat
einen eingebauten Blocker und
ein paar andere Privacy Sachen.
Den finde ich gut. Brave ist irgendwie
overrated. Brauchen wir nicht.
Taugt alles nichts hier. Brauchen wir nicht.
Fühlt mich ja fast schon bedroht hier
bei Amazon.
Die Blitzdeals machen wir mal weg, weil
Blitzdeals sind wirklich zum größten Teil Crap dabei.
Wofür benutzt du die Magneten?
Zum Beispiel
für ne Tür.
So ne kleine
Klapp, Metall
Klapptür, dass die zu bleibt.
Habe ich jetzt letztens welche verwendet.
Zum Aufhängen
von Sachen sind die ganz gut.
Zum Positionieren
von
beispielsweise Controller und so sind die auch ganz gut.
Oh!
Oh Mist!
Ich sehe gerade die Katz hat
mein Temperatursensor Ding runter
geschmissen und die Ecke vom Display ist abgebrochen.
Ich wollte nämlich gerade gucken was für Temperatur
ist.
Ich habe hier auf dem Schrank so ein selbst gebasteltes
Klimaanlagen
Steuerungsding liegen mit nem Temperatursensor.
Funktioniert noch alles.
Steht auch 21,67 Grad drauf.
Aber die Ecke vom Display ist abgebrochen.
Aber das Display funktioniert noch.
Die hat es runter geschmissen.
Mir ist nämlich eingefallen.
Das hing am Kabel heute morgen unten.
Niemals Arturo WTF.
Allein schon sowas zu
schreiben ist ja schon kurz vor Timeout.
So was haben wir denn sonst noch hier.
Lightning Deals machen wir mal weg.
Okay dann Lightning Deals ist Müll.
Okay ich such mal
nach wirklich ernsthaft was was ich brauche.
Also ich bräuchte
Silikon
Klebe
Ich weiß nicht
wie die Dinger genau heißen.
Sowas hier bräuchte ich.
Gibt es da irgendwas in Deals?
Natürlich nicht.
Die sind tatsächlich ganz nice.
Aber ich brauche was dickeres.
Wisst ihr gibt es nicht.
Wunderbar.
Kein Isolierband.
Das habe ich letztes mal gefunden.
Das benutze ich total gern.
Um irgendwelche Sachen wasserdicht
einzurappen.
Es gibt so ein Silikonband.
Selbst
Nicht selbstklebend.
Sowas ähnliches wie das hier.
Sowas sowas hier.
Das ist richtig nice.
Das ist doppelseitig.
Das machst du zusammen.
Das ist quasi ähnlich wie ein
Schrumpfschlauch nur ohne zu schrumpfen.
Das ist wasserdicht und klebt auf sich selbst.
Also wenn ich die Seite auf
Deutsch hätte würde da da stehen quasi sowas wie
Selbstverschweißen.
Natürlich verschweißt sich das nicht.
Das finde ich extrem praktisch.
Ich weiß nicht ob es genau das ist was ich mir vor einer
Weile mal gekauft habe.
Aber das ist wirklich nice.
Einfach drum gewickelt.
Das Ding ist wasserdicht zu und es ist bombenfest.
Deswegen kein normales Isolierband.
Ich brauche was was beidseitig klebt.
Und das gute daran ist halt
das kannst du ein bisschen stretchen.
Das heißt wenn du das ein bisschen ziehst
und drum herum rappst und dann zusammenpappst
dann ist das richtig
stramm und fest.
So wie das sein muss.
Gab es das jetzt im Deal oder nicht?
Alter was ist das jetzt hier?
Das ist die Smash Musik
in schlechter Quali.
Ne gibt es heute nicht.
Gut. Na dann.
Extreme Ceiling.
Wow.
Übertreibts halt mal.
Ach seht noch 16,5 Meter.
Okay 16,5 Meter
das ist eine ganz schön fette Rolle glaube ich.
Okay gibt nichts was ich brauche.
Also schauen wir mal bei nicht so sinnvollen Sachen weiter.
Alter der Chat wieder.
Der Lowbrain Chat gerade am Start.
Oi Chat.
So ähm.
Also Lightning Deeds.
Wollten wir nicht Lightning Deeds. War Müll.
Schauen wir mal ob es ordentliches Werkzeug gibt.
Hier exzellent.
Gibt es Aguschrauber. Aguschrauber kann man nie genug haben.
Das ist aber ein 18 Volt Aguschrauber.
Ich habe keine 18 Volt Agus.
Hier.
Oh gucke mal.
Ist der
GSB der mit Schlagfunktion?
Ja. Hey das ist gar nicht übel.
Ich glaube der Deal ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Es gibt.
Die haben GSR und GSB.
Willst du dir eigentlich Cyberpunk holen?
Wahrscheinlich.
Aber ich kann gleich sagen.
Ähm.
Das das vom Setting her nicht meins ist.
Ja.
Das ist so ein Hybrid.
Aber der GSR den es normalerweise.
Der GSR der ist ein bisschen kürzer.
Hat aber kein Schlagwerk drin.
Und ich habe mir damals den GSR gekauft.
Und ich habe schon ein paar mal damit geliebäugelt.
Oder ich habe.
Was heißt geliebäugelt.
Zweiten will ich mir nicht kaufen.
Ist bescheuert.
Aber ich habe mir schon ein paar mal überlegt.
Vielleicht wäre es gar nicht so schlecht gewesen.
Hätte ich ihm ein Schlagwerk gekauft.
Weil ich habe damit jetzt auch schon ein paar Löcher gebohrt.
Und es geht. Es geht. Ja. Auch ohne Schlagwerk.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen es geht ein bisschen geschmeidiger.
Das ist kein richtiger Schlagschrauber.
Das ist richtig. Das ist so ein Hybrid Ding.
Aber man glaubt gar nicht.
Was kleine 12 Volt Akkuschrauber.
Mittlerweile für Power haben.
Vernünftiges Werkzeug.
Öffnet Bosch.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ob du damit sagen möchtest.
Das es gut oder schlecht ist.
Das es einen der besten 12 Volt Akkuschrauber den es so gibt.
Find ich.
Das richtig pockt das Ding.
Jetzt kommt einer in Makita.
Nein nein bei mir kommt nur Milwaukee.
Oder sonst was an Start.
Aber ich finde den sehr nice.
Rusty.
So ist es ja auch.
Aber das finde ich gut.
Also das ist glaube ich echt kein schlechter Deal.
Was kostet der normalerweise so?
Guck mal mal Geilzahl.
Zum Vergleich was der normalerweise so kostet.
Okay. Der kostet überall so wenig.
Lohnt sich.
Naja okay man spart 4 Euro.
Man spart 4 Euro.
Ja.
Ach Moment.
Ne das sind alles die mit Zubehör.
Das sind alles die mit Tasche her.
Sparste 4 Euro.
Also ich habe genau den.
Aber die GSR.
Also den ohne Schlagwerk dabei.
Ähm.
Das Set ist auch ganz okay.
Was da dabei ist.
Das Bora Set ist in der Tasche drin.
Zumindest war bei mir drin.
Weiß ich ob hier mehr drin ist.
Ich habe die Tasche ausgepackt glaube.
Also bei mir war das alles in der Tasche drin.
Deswegen ist ja auch da die Tasche dabei.
Wir können mal gucken was hier dabei steht.
Okay. Gucken wir mal beispielsweise was die hier dazu sagen.
Zur Artikelbeschreibung.
Ne da ist anscheinend wirklich nichts dabei.
Ne gut.
Der Bohrer ist es nicht.
Aber man kann damit bohren.
Und für ab und zu mal ein Loch bohren reicht es.
Finde ich.
Ich habe damit schon ein paar Löcher gebohrt.
Das funktioniert ohne Probleme.
Na gut.
Wenn das nur bei Amazon mit Zubehör ist.
Dann ist das Angebot echt gut.
Also wer keinen 12V Akkuschrauber hat.
Dann ist das hier jetzt euer Ding.
Ja.
Ach das ist die Amazon Edition.
Dann ist ja alles klar.
Gibt es zwei Akkus dabei?
Also bei meinem Set gab es zwei Akkus dabei.
Wie viele Akkus sind dabei?
Zwei Akkus ist schon praktisch.
Zweimal hier.
Zweimal zwei Amperestunden Akkus.
Ja.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz.
Ist trotzdem 4 Euro billiger als bei den anderen.
War unabhängig davon ob das dabei ist.
Wohlgemerkt.
Ich habe mein Set für 84 Euro gekauft.
Aber meiner ist auch der ohne Schlagfunktion.
Ich bin wirklich super zufrieden damit.
Das Ding kann man echt empfehlen.
Und man glaubt gar nicht.
Was 12V Akkuschrauber.
Echt für Power mittlerweile haben.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich hatte früher mal einen.
Auch irgendein Bosch Ding.
Und da konntest du mit der Hand anhalten.
Das Ding.
Gut das war auch damals schon ein Kackteil.
Also wenn du den versuchst mit der Hand anzuhalten.
Dann klebt die Hand da dran.
Wie viel das ist eine gute Frage.
Wie viel das hat.
Hier.
Ne Moment.
Ja.
Müsst ihr euch irgendeinen Test angucken.
Gibt es bei Amazon was zu Resellen?
Müsst ihr mal gucken.
Wie viel das hat.
Zumindest kann man sagen.
Ich hab den gleichen.
Bloß ohne Schlagfunktion.
Ist wunderbar.
Echt top.
So was haben wir sonst noch für Werkzeugstells.
Dinger.
Gut da brauche ich nun wirklich nichts.
Da habe ich meine.
Knippex Sammlung für.
Die ja übrigens Knipex heißen.
Aber jeder sagt irgendwie Knipex.
Sowas könnte ich tatsächlich noch gebrauchen.
Gerade wenn ich mal Sachen auspacke.
Ich habe mir schon öfters gedacht.
Ich bräuchte mal ein ordentliches Messer.
Manchmal mühe ich mich dann mit einer Schere echt ab.
Ich glaube die Dinger sind auch gar nicht so übel.
Schraubendreher brauchen wir auch nicht.
Gut hält sich in Grenzen.
Also.
Das können wir mal reinschmeißen.
Kann man bestimmt mal brauchen.
Ok was gibt es sonst noch für Tools.
Nichts was irgendwie.
Was hat das mit Tools zu tun.
Was du hast bei Amazon.
Ein Let's Play Adventskalender gefunden.
What the fuck.
Taglife.
Waren Taglife nicht Chinesen.
Klingt irgendwie extrem Chinesisch Taglife.
Ich erkenne ja auch nicht was es sein soll.
Alter.
Wenn man will das sein Zeug abbricht nach dem ersten mal.
Dann kauft man sich sowas hier.
Ok ist wieder nichts.
Was von Faux Wong.
Alter Faux Wong.
Klingt ja fast so gut wie Cogeek.
Foam Sealing Tape.
Was?
Das ist so ein Ding wo ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Wenn man es hat.
Kann man das öfters mal verwenden.
Nicht im Stream öffnen.
Ok.
Öffne ich nicht im Stream.
Das ist glaube ich nicht.
Das ist glaube ich nicht TOS.
Wobei.
Das ist glaube ich kein TOS.
Es ist nicht TOS.
Ich sehe da nichts nackiges.
Aber es ist auch nichts spannendes.
Was man sich angucken müsste.
Ich habe auch erst Let's Play gelesen.
Das hat mit Let's Play gar nichts zu tun.
Die meinen in dem Fall mit Let's Play.
Das da.
Ich glaube das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt.
Das kann man sich mal geben.
Achso Lightning Deal.
Da muss ich auf der anderen Seite wieder ran.
Alles klar.
Ok.
Ist sonst irgendwas gescheites bei Acrobat?
Ist das nicht so ein PDF Ding?
Ich meine.
Das sieht nicht nach PDF aus.
Aber das erinnert mich an komische nervige PDF Software.
Was?
Was ist das?
Ist das ein Dübel?
Der Special Big Brain Dübel?
Oder was ist das?
Ich werde da nicht so hundertprozentig schlau draus.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Das ist Big Brain Dübel.
Brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe auch kaum was gekauft.
Bisher bei Black Friday.
Der ganze Black Friday Kram ist durch.
Da kam heute Amazon um die Ecke.
Haha.
Cyber Monday ist auch noch am Start.
Oh.
Monka Smoke.
Oioioioi.
Für 15 Euro.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe das nicht gelöscht.
Das wurde entfernt das Emote.
Das wurde gelöscht.
Aber ich kann einfach ein anderes hinzufügen.
Ich kann einfach ein anderes hinzufügen.
Von einem anderen Channel.
Ach ne. Only Available in.
Was ist denn da los?
Warum ist das nicht da?
Sebaro, da müssen wir später mal gucken.
Falls du das Emote irgendwo findest.
Auf Better Twitch TV.
Dann füge ich es wieder hinzu.
Ich habe hier so eine andere Version gefunden.
Dort war das allerdings
auf einem speziellen Channel beschränkt.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist beschränkt auf
Super Chat.
Das kann ich nicht.
Aber das hier ist dann wirklich
Monka Smoke.
Also, wenn das nicht abfackelt.
Was wollen sie uns denn hier
für 15 Euro geben?
Also, ein Lötkolb.
Aber immerhin,
mit Temperatureinstellung
vermute ich mal, dass das eine
Temperaturregelung ist.
Man erkennt das nicht so wirklich gut.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Das könnten 200 Grad sein.
Das könnten
350 Grad oder so sein.
Ich erkenne da nichts.
Wer liest denn auch schon Titelchat?
So, aber der Rest ist wirklich
ganz, ganz billiges Zeug.
Das ist dann einmal
verwenden.
So eine Pumpe ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich.
Also, was man damit macht,
ist folgendes.
Um das mal kurz zu erklären.
Man macht diesen
Wie nennt man das?
Dieses Ding da rein.
Da gibt es einen Unterdruck.
Äh, Schwachsinn.
Nochmal von vorne.
Man macht das da rein.
Dann macht man mit dem
Lötkolben das Lötzinn an einer Stelle
flüssig.
Und dann hält man das dran
und drückt da drauf.
Und wenn man da drauf drückt, da ist eine Feder drin.
Die zieht das dann raus.
Und dann entsteht
ein Unterdruck da drin.
Und da kann man quasi flüssiges Lötzinn wegsaugen damit.
Mit so einer Pumpe.
Und da hält man dann dran.
Dann macht man so.
Macht die Pumpe und dann zieht es das Lötzinn weg.
Kann man eigentlich noch bleihaltiges Lötzinn kaufen?
Klar, privat darf man das.
Was ist denn so die Standardmissung?
70, 30, 60, 40?
Ich habe auch stinknormales Lötzinn
mit Blei.
Das fließt besser.
Kann man sich kaufen.
Und wie bekommt man das dann aus der Pumpe?
Das fällt meistens von alleine
wieder raus.
Sonst kannst du bestimmt noch aufmachen.
Aber bei mir fällt das eigentlich danach wieder
von alleine raus.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du es aufmachen.
Musst du es noch nie aufmachen.
Also eine Pumpe ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich.
Diese Lötkolben hier
würde ich ganz im Ernst
Naja.
Gut, ich meine wir hatten letztens
ein Set, das war
15 Euro mit noch einem Multimeter
dabei.
Müsst ihr nicht arbeiten Flo96?
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ausschaut.
Ich habe Urlaub bis Januar.
Außerdem ist ja eher die Frage Flo96
Müsstest du nicht vielleicht arbeiten?
Übrigens
hier, wo wir
Was auch ganz cool ist, wenn man
einen Lötkolben haben will, den man
mobil verwenden kann.
Was richtig, was ich mir schon seit einer
Weile holen will.
War es TS-80 oder TS-100?
Ich glaube TS-100 war es.
War das der?
Ich glaube sowas hier. Da bin ich mir schon eine Weile
dagegen, ob ich mir sowas holen soll.
Da kann man sogar Custom-Firma drauf
flashen.
Ihr wisst ja, ich flashe eh alles mit
Custom-Firma und das ist jetzt ein Lötkolben.
Da kann man Custom-Firma flashen.
Den kannst du auch mit einer Powerbank
betreiben.
Oder war es der TS-80?
Ich will auf jeden Fall den mit USB.
Dann der, dann der.
Ich war mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, welcher es ist. Der mit USB-C.
Ja.
Da kannst du einen Lötkolben übertakten, wenn du eine Custom-Firma drauf hast.
Da kannst du mit Alexa
den Lötkolben steuern.
Ohje, jetzt habe ich den Namen gesagt.
Jetzt ist wahrscheinlich mal ganz viel wieder angesprungen.
Kennst du noch nicht den
SH-72 Lötkolben?
Ne?
Ist das auch so ein Ding?
Ah, guck mal hier.
Vorgas. Was ist das?
Aber, okay.
Das sieht ein bisschen
billiger aus als der andere.
Also zumindest,
wenn es um Werkzeug geht,
kennt ihr ja meine Philosophie.
Ich kaufe mir
mittlerweile lieber
ein bisschen besseres Zeug
und ein bisschen teureres Zeug.
Und dafür hast du auch quasi mehr Spaß mit.
Und bei
billigem China-Elektronik-Zeug
kennt ihr ja auch meine Philosophie.
Da kaufe ich mir meistens nicht eins oder mindestens drei.
Weil da macht man ganz gerne mal was von kaputt.
Und gerade, wenn man aus China bestellt,
lohnt sich das auch,
weil der Versand aus China ist nicht viel höher.
Wo wir gerade bei China sind, müssen wir gleich mal gucken,
was die Chinesen noch am Start haben.
Und, weil das unter dem letzten
YouTube-Video
auch oft geschrieben wurde,
man kann
nach wie vor ohne Probleme
ab nächstem Jahr auch in China bestellen.
Weil es ist so. Ich gebe jetzt einfach mal irgendwas ein.
Sale, Sale.
Alles Sale. Letztes Mal war das noch billiger.
Letztes Mal hat es nur 5 Euro gekostet.
Da war es auch schon Sale.
Okay, nehmen wir mal irgendwie ESPNode, NodeMCU.
Dann nehmen wir mal beispielsweise eine NodeMCU.
Nehmen wir uns irgendwas hier.
Wo sind die denn?
Nehmen wir mal sowas hier beispielsweise.
So, was kennst du den
Toolpack ES-121 Schraub...
Äh, ja.
Wenn es dieser Schraubendreher ist
mit dem Motor, dann kenne ich den
und den fand ich kacke, wo ich ihn gesehen habe.
So, also.
Ab nächstem Jahr gibt es
keine freie Grenze mehr für Zoll.
Genau, hier.
Ähm, wo steht es denn?
Ja, also hier sinngemäß.
Also, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob das jetzt verabschiedet wurde, aber
genau, bisher war das so.
Es gab die Regelung,
ähm, dass du
irgendwie mit
bis 22 Euro musstest du nichts bezahlen.
Das hat den Zoll auch nicht interessiert.
Dann gab es noch irgendwie von hier
bis 150
und ab 150 war es dann irgendwie anders.
Also, du musstest quasi gar nichts bezahlen.
Dann musstest du nur Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen.
Und dann musstest du Mehrwertsteuer und Zoll bezahlen.
Und jetzt gibt es diese Freigrenze nicht.
Und da denken viele jetzt,
oh Mist, man kann aus China nichts mehr bestellen.
Aber, das stimmt gar nicht.
Zobel16, Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Ich bin heute irgendwie nicht so gut im Gucken.
Sorry Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehe mit Subs.
Ich schau mal kurz in mein Dashboard rein.
Ich bin heute ein bisschen
zu
vertieft in meinem Gelaber.
Ähm, hier.
Dankeschön, Zobel16.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Swarmhost stinkt.
Hat mit Prime abonniert vor 17 Minuten.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exquisite Name, Exquisite Sub.
Den Rest habe ich schon.
Also, Any.
Du musst fragen, ähm.
Roffel, nicht Any Subbers.
Du musst fragen, Any Gifters.
Wenn du was gegiftet haben willst.
Heinrich, 9 Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Ups, diese ganze China Geschichte zurück.
So, und nachdem quasi diese
unter 22 Euro Grenze
wegfällt,
sagen jetzt viele, oh ne man kann gar nichts mehr aus China
erstellen. Aber, das ist falsch.
Erstens,
ich überleg grad mit was ich anfange.
Große Postchamp Einlage.
Ähm.
Also, fangen wir mal so an. Erstens,
haben viele, das stimmt,
viele China, das ist auch der Grund,
warum sie das wahrscheinlich machen,
haben viele China Händler getrickst.
Also du hast dann, keine Ahnung, für 150 Euro
Elektronik Kleinteile in China bestellt.
Und die haben draufgeschrieben 7,50 Euro.
Und das konnte keiner so
wirklich richtig bewerten.
Ja. Hast du jetzt da ein Packen voll
mit China Crap, hat das jetzt
7,50 Euro oder 150 Euro gekostet.
Außerdem, wenn die
Dokumente gefaked sind, äh, ja.
Gut, dir als Besteller
kann eh nichts passieren, der Händler ist im Arsch.
Theoretisch, aber das ist dem Händler in China ja egal.
So, und.
Jetzt fällt das
weg. Ich kann das schon verstehen,
warum man das gemacht hat. Ich find das auch
irgendwie böse
oder so.
Ich bin denen jetzt auch nicht böse, das zu machen, weil
da wurde wirklich verdammt viel getrickst.
Aber, man kann trotzdem
noch aus China bestellen, weil
man geht einfach hier hin und sagt, okay, excellent.
Also, mal gucken, ob der Shop das jetzt hier
anbietet. Und wir gehen auf
EU Priority Line.
Also, keine Ahnung, wir bestellen hier unsere
10 NodeMCUs,
bestellen wir jetzt für 40,
für 50, 50 Dollar ungefähr.
So, und jetzt kommt der Trick.
Äh, übrigens, das kann sein, dass
das jetzt auch schon kommt, ja.
Ähm.
Wenn man
den Euro mehr,
1,50 mehr ausgibt, was man bei dem Preis
von 50 Dollar mal machen kann.
Und EU Priority Line,
übrigens, das ist Banggood Express, das geht auch.
Diese Sachen sind nur
diese, was hiervon betroffen ist,
sind diese ganzen ultra
lahmen, billig Versand-Sachen.
Also, keine Ahnung, ähm, zum Beispiel
das, was früher AliExpress Standard war.
So, wenn man früher
AliExpress Standard bestellt hat.
So, ähm,
sagen wir mal China. Genau, wenn du
sowas hier bestellt hast.
So, das ist, ihr seht's,
das ist ewig unterwegs.
5. Februar.
1. Januar.
Das ist ewig unterwegs.
So, und das kommt über ein Schiff
sonst wie hin.
Und dann ist die Frage, wie der Händler das macht.
Und ob das Ganze greift.
Denn, äh,
wo hab ich's hier? Diese Sache
greift nur für
Sachen, die aus
Nicht-EU-Ländern kommen.
Also, das bedeutet, wenn die
Chinesen das direkt irgendwie hier
reinfahren wollen nach Hamburg
oder keine Ahnung. Aber,
AliExpress ist ja nicht doof.
AliExpress macht so
gut wie jetzt alles schon über die Niederlande.
Und teilweise mit PostNL.
Das heißt,
die gehen dann in die Niederlande
und von dort geht das Paket an euch.
Das bedeutet,
das Paket kommt nicht aus dem Ausland.
So, und je nachdem, wie die das kennzeichnen,
ist halt
die Frage, wie gut das klappt oder wie gut das
nicht klappt. Wo es auf jeden Fall
funktioniert, ist, wenn der EU Priority Line
macht. Das kann zwei
Auswirkungen haben.
Entweder, der China
Händler verschickt
das Paket an
Niederlande, Spanien, Italien
oder sonst wo. Irgendein EU
Land. Und von dort,
ich weiß nicht, ob sie dort ein neues Etikett draufkleben
oder so, keine Ahnung.
Und von dort geht das Ganze
dann weiter zu euch.
So, und nachdem dann die Sendung quasi offiziell
aus Spanien, Italien, Niederlande kommt,
juckt das keine Sau.
Eigentlich eine gute Taktik, ja.
So,
was auch eine Möglichkeit ist,
dass es einfach direkt aus dem EU
Warenlager losgeschickt wird.
Viele China Händler
haben mittlerweile auch EU Warenlager,
so wie man hier sieht. Man kann ja hier aus Polen
bestellen. Guck mal, in Polen
ist es billiger als aus China.
Dafür ist der Versand ein bisschen
teurer.
Russland liefert nicht nach Deutschland.
Spanien, Italien,
Frankreich, so die üblichen Verlechern.
Also sprich, ich kann quasi
in Polen, Frankreich, Italien
günstiger bestellen, schon what the fuck,
als in China.
So, ich sag mal, nehmen wir das polnische
EU Lager
und bestellen da
aha,
da muss man jetzt mal gucken,
ob sich das lohnt.
Ob sich das lohnt.
Weil in China
bleibt es billig.
In China bleibt es billig.
DHL 19 Euro.
Muss man gucken,
ob sich das ganze lohnt.
12 Euro Versand, okay.
Aber auf der anderen Seite
bezahlst du halt weniger,
wenn du nämlich sowas hier bei Amazon kaufst,
so ein Board.
Kostet 7 Euro oder sowas.
8,50.
Hier kostet es 8,50.
Also das kann sich durchaus lohnen.
Wieso ist der Versand aus Polen
teurer als aus China?
Weil der in China auf irgendeinem Containerschiff
über drei Monate oder so.
Voraussichtlich
1. Januar.
Also das ist jetzt erstmal
ein Monat auf dem Schiff,
bis es bei dir ankommt.
Das ist billiger.
Und Polen ist halt
Land.
Wahrscheinlich einfach DHL.
Mal gucken,
ob die noch vor
Guck mal, die kommt sogar noch vor Weihnachten an,
wenn du das aus Frankreich bestellst.
Spanien 18, also
man kann aus den USA bestellen, sehr sinnvoll.
Also, wenn man bestellt aus Spanien
oder Frankreich, bekommt man sogar
bis vor Weihnachten.
Und das, was Dickie5 schreibt, kommt auch noch dabei.
Genau, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
China subventioniert
auch übelst den Export
und die
Versandgeschichten.
Wisst ihr, was ich mich dann frage?
Wir bezahlen ja auch Entwicklungshilfe
nach China. Ich frage mich, ob die quasi
mit unserer Entwicklungshilfe
den Versand zu uns subventionieren.
Das wäre ja mal
excellent big brain, oder?
So nach dem Motto, oh, wir brauchen Geld,
wir haben ganz viele arme Leute noch in ländlichen Regionen,
gib Entwicklungshilfe.
Und dann nehmen sie die Entwicklungshilfe und geben sich den armen Leuten,
sondern subventionieren den Versand nach Deutschland.
Das wäre
der richtige China-Move, Alter.
Ey, ich kann mir das alles vorstellen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir noch viel Entwicklungshilfe nach China
bezahlen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel man da noch bezahlen kann.
Aha.
Wie viel? Kann man mal machen.
Kann man sich mal gönnen.
630, kann man mal machen.
Easy money,
easy life.
Ich meine, die sollten
vielleicht mal
in Deutschland Entwicklungshilfe bezahlen
für den Internetausbau.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Die Türkei bekommt 3,6 Milliarden
Entwicklungshilfen.
Dafür sind die aber sehr unkooperativ
in letzter Zeit.
Na gut, was auch immer.
Na gut, zumindest
das wäre doch mal richtig, richtig
big brain move. Man nimmt einfach
die 630 Milliarden Entwicklungshilfe und subventioniert
den Versand nach Deutschland.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass 3,6 Milliarden?
Alter, aber nicht von uns alleine, oder?
Ich habe mir das noch nie
so genau angeguckt.
Nee, das ist insgesamt, insgesamt.
Alter.
Was ist das für?
Das ist ja brutals viel Kohle, ey.
Was haben die gemacht?
Mit 9 Milliarden?
Man hätte ja mal vielleicht dafür sorgen können,
dass die Leute besseres Leben führen,
aber nee, man hat sich lieber gegenseitig umgebracht.
Big brain move, Alter.
Dafür sind
also gut investierte
9 Milliarden. Top.
Naja, ähm.
Next.
Next level brain, ja.
Na, so wenig sind 9 Milliarden nicht.
So wenig sind 9 Milliarden.
Natürlich, bei unserem
äh, wie heißt's?
Jahres-Dingsbums-Produkt-Kram
ist das nicht viel.
Aber man darf ja nicht vergessen,
ich weiß nicht, was so das Bruttoinlandsprodukt
von Syrien normalerweise ist.
Guck mal.
40 Milliarden.
Die haben 40 Milliarden Bruttoinlandsprodukt
und bekommen
100 Milliarden Entwicklung.
Das ist ein ganz schön großer Anteil.
Gut, ich kenn mich mit der Sache null aus,
ja, ich hab da absolut keinen Plan von.
Ich seh jetzt die Zahlen zum ersten Mal,
äh, ich kann das absolut nicht einordnen,
was da läuft, ja.
Aber das ist anteilmäßig schon ganz schön viel.
Ja, oder was ist das?
2007, ja geil.
Danach haben sie angefangen, sich gegenseitig den Kopf weg zu ballern.
Top.
Beste Investition überhaupt, da.
Ja, gut.
Also, da ist ja nichts dabei hier.
Outstanding Move, ja.
Was machst du denn immer
mit den Links, meinst du das hier?
Ich kopiere eine Eins in die
Zwischenablage.
Das ist richtiger Pro-Gamer-Move.
Das können nur ehemalige Overwatch-Profis machen.
Also, wenn ihr schon immer
mal wissen wollt, was braucht
man, um Pro-Gamer zu werden?
Der erste Schritt ist
Einser kopieren.
Der Richie ist auch am Start.
Nice.
Einser kopieren.
Das ist schon mal das Allerwichtigste.
Wenn ihr das drauf habt, dann ist zumindest mal
Global Elite sicher.
Dann müsst ihr gar nichts
mehr großartig machen.
Was ist das?
Einfach eine schwarze Kiste?
Warum ist das schwarz?
Ah, das ist für die Gartenmöbel.
Okay, braucht kein Mensch.
Wer hat schon Gartenmöbel?
Das würde ja heißen, man sitzt im Garten,
vielleicht sogar noch in der Sonne.
Übrigens, exzellent,
exzellent Bildbearbeitungssachen hier auch.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Also, da hat der Fiverr,
der Fiverr-Photoshop-Mann, Frau,
weiß man ja nicht,
ähm,
die Photoshop-Innen haben
bei Fiverr das wirklich...
Oh, dieser Schnee! Oh, der Schnee
ist ja richtig gut.
Der Schnee, wie in echt.
Ich kann's kaum
erkennen.
Das ist doppelt RTX-on.
Gott, sieht das
scheiße aus, ey.
Das andere sieht auch nicht viel besser aus, ja?
Aber gerade dieser Schnee,
das sieht wirklich kacke aus.
Und hier dieser Lens-Flare-Effekt.
Ich mein,
wo kommt der Lens-Flare überhaupt her?
Hier ist überhaupt keine Sonne zu sehen.
Ach, von da.
Ja, klar, die Sonne ist in Wirklichkeit
im Gemüsebeet gegenüber, beim Nachbar.
Ist die Sonne. Natürlich.
Oh, diese Regentropfen.
Okay, das ist wirklich mies, das Teil, ey.
Der könnte mir Thumbnails machen,
der Kerl.
Oder die Photoshop-Innen.
Die sollen mal rausrücken, wer ihr Designer
ist. Das kostet dann auch nicht so viel,
wenn die mir Thumbnails macht.
Und vielleicht sind schlechte
Thumbnails besser als gute Thumbnails.
Weil gute Thumbnails haben so viele
Leute auf YouTube mittlerweile, wenn man einfach schlechte
macht. Die müssen dann aber so
richtig schlecht sein. So richtig
meme-bar schlecht.
Hey, was? Moment.
Ist eine
MSI RTX 208 super
ihr Geld wert zu sein?
Nee.
Nicht mehr.
Achso, du willst dir eine kaufen.
Du willst dir eine kaufen, oder?
Willst du die verkaufen? Du willst die kaufen.
Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Also vor einer Weile haben alle ihre
RTX 280 aus dem Fenster
geschmissen für ein Appel und ein Ei.
Weil die
rumgeraged haben, weil die
neue
30, 70 oder so
besser ist und die Hälfte kostet.
Also ist fraglich,
ob es ihr Geld wert ist, je nachdem
was es gerade kostet.
Lassen sich die Fire Tablets mit
Stock Android flashen?
Also,
nachdem mir ja vorhin schon
ein offizieller von Twitch war,
weiß ich nicht, ob ich das erzählen darf.
Aber ich kann das ja mal
umschreiben.
Es kommt auf das Alter des Tablets an
und auf den Typ des Tablets.
Und dann würde ich einfach mal googeln danach,
ob das geht.
Bei manchen geht es, bei manchen geht es nicht.
Bei den ganz Neuen stehen die Chancen eher schlecht.
Bei den bisschen älteren Modellen
stehen die Chancen gut.
Und, ähm,
dann ist auch noch die Frage,
was gibt es? Fire HD 7?
Und 10? Gibt es auch ein 8?
Gibt es ein Fire HD 8?
Moment, habe ich sogar ein 8er?
Habe ich vielleicht doch ein 8er?
Kann ein 7er?
Bei mir drüben im Bett liegen?
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Jetzt seht ihr mal.
Früher hätte ich das gewusst.
Früher, zu Zeiten,
wo ich noch
Gamestar abonniert habe und solche Dinger.
Also, das ist schon ganz lange her.
Da konnte ich euch wirklich
Taktraten und Gedöns von allen Geräten sagen.
Von jeder CPU, die aktuell ist.
Und ich wusste auch ganz genau,
was ich für Hardware Specs habe.
Aber jetzt, 20 Jahre später,
habe ich keine Ahnung mehr.
Hatten wir das Smash Bros. Team nicht schon?
Oh, Leute, ich habe euch mitgestellt,
ich habe kein Fire HD 7,
ich habe ein Fire HD 8.
Also, so ein Teil habe ich da.
So, also, ich scroll jetzt nochmal kurz hier.
Ne, ne, ne, 19 Seiten gucke ich mir da nicht an.
Was war denn das eben?
Was war denn das?
Äh, wo ist das hin?
Das? Was war denn das?
Irgendein Set mit
Ach, Schrauben und Unterleben.
Da habe ich genug.
Alter, die Musik!
Die Musik hier, exquisite!
Ah, yes!
Five Head Wine.
Excellent!
Das ist das Smash
Team.
So.
Oh, guck mal, Gosund!
Da sind sie ja wieder.
Was haben die hier am Start?
Ein Stück für 35.
Das erscheint
mir sogar recht
okay.
Weil
Gosund, ich habe jetzt schon ein paar
Sachen von Gosund gekauft,
weil die nehmen es mit
Firmware-Updates nicht so genau.
Ich habe jetzt insgesamt
vier Gosund
doppelte Steckdosen-Leisten
und eine Gosund
Steckdosen, äh, was denn da habe ich denn?
Vier so doppelte Steckdosen
und eine Gosund Steckdosen-Leiste
und alles hat sich
noch vor 1-2 Wochen
ohne Probleme flashen lassen
wireless.
Ohne aufschrauben zu müssen.
So.
Das heißt, die nehmen das nicht so ernst.
Guck mal, die flashen
immer.
Die nehmen es nicht so ernst mit
Firmware-Updaten bei Gosund.
Und das, glaube ich, ist sogar
ganz okay. 35 Euro
für 4 Stück.
Allerdings finde ich die anderen besser.
Diese
Doppelstecker-Dinger.
Die gab es heute
auch im Angebot für 15,19.
Also, da muss ich sagen, ich habe, also
ich kann persönlich sagen,
das lässt sich flashen, das Ding.
Und
das Ding lässt sich flashen.
Habe ich beides noch vor einer Woche gemacht.
Und wir haben sogar
im Stream mal eine aufgemacht, wo es
nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Und konnten es ohne Probleme dann von Hand flashen.
Aber muss man nicht,
weil die sich eigentlich
denke ich mal fast
also der hier auf jeden Fall und
3 von 4, die ich hatte,
haben sich auch flashen lassen übers WLAN.
Und wahrscheinlich, und wahrscheinlich
hätte es, wenn ich es mal richtig
gemacht hätte, die anderen auch
flashen lassen, die ich im Stream
aufgeschraubt habe. Aber, ich meine,
dafür haben wir
einen nicen Stream gehabt.
Wo wir das probieren können.
Wofür geflasht?
Gute Frage. Die Frage kommt nämlich immer.
Und deswegen weiß ich auch
ganz gut, was ich da drauf sagen kann.
Also, der Nachteil dieser
Steckdosen ist,
die gehen nur über die, meistens,
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, aber meistens.
Die gehen meistens nur
über die offizielle App vom Hersteller.
Was schon mal ziemlich doof ist,
wenn man quasi ein Heimautomatisierungssystem
hat und das da einbauen will.
Und man kann es nur über eine offizielle App vom Smartphone
machen. Das ist schon mal doof. Das zweite ist,
was für mich absolutes K.O.-Kriterium ist,
warum ich sie nicht mit der
Originalfirmware verwende.
Die Dinger brauchen zwingend
Cloud-Verbindungen nach China.
Das sind ja zwei Sachen in einem,
die mir auf den Keks gehen. Erstens
Cloud-Verbindungen, zweitens auch noch
Cloud-Verbindungen nach China.
Ich habe prinzipiell alles offline,
was bei mir im Smart Home ist.
Also alles funktioniert ohne
irgendwie Internet-Anbindungen in irgendeine
China-Cloud. Wenn was
Online-Services benutzt und mein Internet
ausfällt, dann funktioniert es zwar nicht,
aber für so einfache Sachen wie eine Steckdose
will ich nicht, dass wenn mein Internet ausfällt,
dass die Steckdose nicht mehr funktioniert.
Das ist ja total hängengeblieben.
Und dass diese Sache gar nicht
so weit hergeholt ist, hat man erst vor ein paar Tagen
gesehen. Da hatte Amazon bei AWS
einen Ausfall. AWS ist dieser
Amazon-Cloud-Service.
Und da hatten einige Leute Probleme,
ihren Staubsauger
zu verwenden. Muss ich dir jetzt mal vorstellen.
Amazon hat einen Ausfall.
Du kannst deine Wohnung nicht mehr staubsaugen.
Und ihr Thermostat.
Also sprich, manche Leute
haben dann dadurch,
dass Amazon einen Ausfall hatte,
hatten dann quasi
eine dreckige Wohnung. Um es mal übertrieben zu
sagen. Eine dreckige Wohnung.
Eine kalte,
dreckige Wohnung.
Ging aber schnell vorbei.
Gibt es ein neues Gesetz oder hast du mit den China-Bestellungen?
Ja, ab 1.
1. 2021
gibt es keine Freigrenzen mehr beim Zoll.
Aber das ist kein Problem. Du musst einfach EU
Priority Line bestellen.
Dann hast du keine Probleme.
Dann wird es über ein EU-Land verschickt.
Dann schicken es die Chinesen zum Beispiel nach Italien, Spanien,
Niederlande. Von dort weiter.
Und dann kostet es auch keinen Zoll.
Also deswegen, wenn man die flasht.
Wenn man die flasht. Und da kam eben auch
die Frage, was
was bedeutet
geflasht? Flashen bedeutet,
du tauschst die Software
aus, mit denen die Dinger
ausgeliefert werden. Also die
Steckdose selbst, die
hat ja keine Ahnung von WLAN und
wenn du eine App auf ein- und ausschalten
kriegst oder so. Da ist eine Steckdose
drin mit ein paar Relays und einem
Controller. Dieser Controller hat
eine Firmware drauf. Also quasi das Betriebssystem von
diesem Controller oder halt die Software, mit der dieser Controller
läuft. Und diese Software kannst du
austauschen. Und das nennt man halt
Flashen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil das meistens auch Flash-Speicher
ist. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
woher das Wort Flashen kommt.
Da könnte man ein Command draus machen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Mod-Check.
Leute, Mod-Check.
Haben wir irgendeinen Mod da, der das
gerade machen kann?
War der Sibaro nicht eben noch da?
Hab ich doch irgendwo gesehen gerade.
Ach, da ist er doch, der Sibaro. Wann kommt dein Headster-Placement?
Ich habe mit Headster nichts abgesprochen oder so.
Command,
für das, was ich gerade erklärt habe, was Flashen
bedeutet, vor 30 Sekunden oder so.
Das wäre
äußerst, wenn du das machen
könntest.
Und deswegen flasht man die Dinger.
Ich flashe die Sachen immer hier mit.
Finde ich am besten, wenn man nicht
großartig programmieren will. Top.
Und danach
sieht das so aus.
Ich zeige euch mal ein Beispiel.
Dann habt ihr so ein Menü. Das ist übrigens noch eine ganz alte Version.
Ich glaube, ich sollte mal was
Neueres zeigen.
Habe ich noch irgendwas Neueres hier drin?
Nee.
So, dann habt ihr quasi
ein Web-Interface
für die Steckdose, wo ihr dann
die Steckdosen mitschalten könnt.
Ohne China Cloud, ohne alles.
Und natürlich ist es auch genauso doof, wenn man
jedes Mal auf das Web-Interface muss.
Deswegen kann man diese Sachen wunderbar in seine
Heimautomatisierung anbinden.
Die können so ziemlich alle gängigen
Heimautomatisierung-Sachen.
Also MQTT ist eigentlich mit das
Gängigste. Du kannst HTTP-Requests
hinschicken, du kannst MQTT-Messages hinschicken.
Und für alle, die Home Assistant
verwenden, gibt es jetzt was Neues.
Das ist das, was ich
für Heimautomatisierung verwende. Gibt es
was Neues? Es gibt eine neue
Tasmota-Integration,
die alles komplett automatisch
macht, wenn man Tasmota geflasht hat.
Das ging vorher schon, aber
mittlerweile gibt es sogar eine offizielle Extension
für Home Assistant. Da kannst du deine
Tasmota-Geräte quasi mit einem Klick einbinden.
Und die synken sich
dann in deinen Home Assistant und du kannst alles
dort drüber auslesen. Also sprich,
Stromverbrauch von Geräten, du kannst Steckdosen
ein- und ausschalten, du kannst gucken, wenn ein Temperatursensor
ist, was für eine Temperatur. Also alles, was das Gerät kann.
Eigentlich ziemlich nice.
So, und
deswegen werden die Dinger immer geflasht.
Und die Sache ist
halt die, wenn man versucht, die Sachen
zu flashen, die
Hersteller sind
da meistens nicht so scharf drauf, dass man
das flashen muss.
Dass man das flashen kann, weil
die Hersteller wollen ja, dass du ihren eigenen Krams
verwendest. Wobei man da halt auch wieder sagen
muss, dass sie unterschiedliche
Interessen haben. Also,
es sind ja meistens
zwei verschiedene
Sachen, also Parteien da
involviert. Es gibt einmal
den, der diese Steckdose wirklich
herstellt in China.
Dann gibt es den,
der dort
sein Logo draufdruckt,
nachdem er sich die Steckdose gekauft hat.
Und dann gibt es vielleicht noch irgendeinen, der es hier
vertreibt oder so. Das ist wieder was anderes. Aber
bei China-Produkten ist es ganz oft
so, dass das, was draufsteht,
nicht der Hersteller ist.
Also sprich,
deswegen sieht man auch so viele China-Geräte,
die exakt gleich aussehen.
Also diese Steckdose hier,
oder noch ein
viel besseres Beispiel.
Ich zeige euch mal eine andere Steckdose.
Wartet mal.
Fuck, wie hieß das Ding?
Ich muss mal kurz in meine Amazon-Bestellhistorie gucken.
Amazon-Bestellhistorie.
Die da.
Diese Dinger.
Die hier laufen unter
was weiß ich,
Dings.
Diese Teile gibt es von mindestens
10 verschiedenen Herstellern. Sehen exakt
so aus, haben nur ein anderes Logo drauf.
Also das heißt, daran sieht man, es gibt einmal den
China-Hersteller, der diese Steckdosen
baut. Und es gibt
einmal die Typen, die ihre Logos
draufdrucken. So. Der Hersteller,
der diese Dinger baut,
der hat kein
Interesse dran, das zu verbieten,
dass man Custom-Firma draufmachen kann.
Super, Sebao. Pogos.
Cute. Huge.
Huge Modding.
Der Hersteller, der diese Steckdosen
herstellt, der hat kein Interesse
dran, das zu verbieten, dass die Leute Custom-Firma
flashen. Weil unterm Strich verkauft er mehr,
wenn die Leute Custom-Firma flashen können.
Wer keinen Bock da drauf hat, dass
Custom-Firma geflasht werden kann, sind
diese Hersteller, die da ihr
Logo draufdrucken. Weil die wollen,
dass man ihre Kack-Apps verwendet und
im Zweifelsfall auch Daten abgreifen und gucken,
was die User sich, wie die User sich verhalten
und sonst was. Also die wollen das nicht.
Das heißt, es ist ein kleiner Interessen
Konflikt, der da besteht.
Deswegen
sind die Chancen relativ gut,
dass diese ganzen China-Geräte
ähm
oftmals auch
1-2 Jahre
nachdem es Firmware-Updates gibt,
die die eigentlichen Lücken
gefixt haben, dass man sie so ohne weiteres
flashen kann, dass die immer noch die alte
Firmware draufhaben.
Weil die Hersteller, die
juckt das nicht.
Die Hersteller, die das juckt, sind die,
die da ihr Logo draufmachen.
Und Gursun scheint es nicht zu jucken,
weil bei Gursun konnte ich bisher alles flashen.
Weil der Unterschied ist nämlich der,
wenn die eine neue gepatchte Firmware-Version
haben, dann kann ich es nicht mehr
hiermit konvertieren.
Hiermit ist das total einfach, so eine China-Steckdose
zu flashen.
Man braucht ein Raspberry Pi, die Software drauf
und kann das übers WLAN flashen
und alles ist gut. Wenn die das neueste
Firmware-Update haben, muss man aufschrauben.
Ich sag dazu nur
kurz raussuchen
Wenn es um das Thema
Aufschrauben von Steckdosen geht,
dann
sage ich dazu
nur
Habt ihr gesehen, wie ich es verbogen habe?
Dann sage ich nur das hier dazu, wenn es ums Aufmachen
von Steckdosen geht.
Aufmachen von China-Steckdosen.
Es funktioniert nicht.
Also die ging wirklich kacke auf.
Pass mal auf, jetzt kommt es gleich.
Die anderen Clips
sind aber noch drin.
Guck mal, der Clip ist schon raus.
Ich will jetzt eigentlich...
Ach Mist.
Ich verbiege zumindest das Ding jetzt.
Ich verbiege das Ding jetzt.
Und daran sieht man, es ist viel einfacher,
wenn man diese Steckdosen übers WLAN flashen kann,
als wenn man die lokal
aufschrauben muss.
Die Steckdose war wirklich eklig aufzubekommen.
Jetzt weiß ich, wie es funktioniert.
Jetzt muss ich die 20 Minuten aufmachen.
Flaschen und zumachen wieder.
Guck mal, wie ich das verbogen habe.
Naja.
Wahrscheinlich kann man die flashen.
Das ist eigentlich das, worauf ich
wollte.
Scheinbar nicht mehr flashbar.
Das ist aber scheiße.
Wenn das nicht mehr geht zu flashen.
Kann man die hier noch flashen?
Was sind denn das für welche?
Das sind...
Steht da irgendeine...
Nummer?
Was das für welche sind?
EP2?
Das sind die, die sich nicht mehr flashen lassen.
Ja.
Zumindest alles, was ich bisher
von Gosund hatte, hatte ich flashen lassen.
Außer das eine, was ich aufgeschraubt hatte.
Das hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch flashen lassen.
Was verbraucht die
smarte Steckdose denn ungefähr, ohne
dass ein Gerät angeschlossen ist?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Weil ich glaube, viele Leute
verbinden damit, dass diese
Dinger quasi
so rum eidelmäßig viel
viel Strom verbrauchen.
Verbrauchen sie nicht.
Also der ESP2866, was da drin ist,
das ist der Microcontroller,
der wird wahrscheinlich...
Also der Controller selber läuft mit
3,3 Volt
und braucht
100 Milliampere.
Also kannst du ja mal ausrechnen.
3,3
mal 0,1.
Also 0,3...
Also der braucht 0,33 Watt.
So. Natürlich ist es in Wirklichkeit
wahrscheinlich einen Ticken mehr.
Das muss noch...
Von 230 Volt runter
auf 3,3 und so. Aber
sagen wir mal so, du bist locker
unter, aber absolut locker
unter einem Watt, was das braucht.
Also sowas weit, weit weg von.
Das ist nix
im Endeffekt, was das braucht.
Stellst du ein Weihnachtsbaum auf?
Ich werde mir
dieses Jahr
zum ersten Mal seit glaube 2013
wieder einen richtigen Weihnachtsbaum kaufen.
Machts gut, ihr Bauer.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen,
dass Weihnachtsbäume mittlerweile
saumäßig teuer geworden sind.
Wo hab ich geguckt? Vom Bauhaus oder so?
Ich hab irgendwo in irgendeinem Online-Dings
mal geguckt.
Das ist
übelst teuer, der Kram.
Ne Moment, künstlicher Weihnachtsbaum?
Ich mein,
67 Euro
für einen Weihnachtsbaum.
Schon ordentlich.
Gut, der ist auch ziemlich
groß.
Fahr doch in den Wald und schlag dir einen selbst.
Also erstens darf man wahrscheinlich nicht einfach in den Wald
fahren und sich da irgendwelche Bäume
abhauen.
Zumal es auch schwierig, du brauchst ja irgendeinen kleinen, der
irgendwo am Start ist.
Und außerdem hab ich keinen Bock
selbst zu machen.
Zumindest ist der Kram ziemlich teuer.
So, ich
scroll jetzt mal hier kurz weiter durch.
Was ist hier?
Das Dübelset.
Exzellent.
Da wird heftig gedübelt.
Aber alles nett.
Bienen haben viele an und ist billiger.
Vielleicht mach ich das.
Vielleicht mach ich das auch.
Okay, hier haben wir wieder Billig-China-Zeug.
Mal gucken.
Okay, ich glaube,
das ist eine der
hässlichsten und gleichzeitig
wahrscheinlich billigsten Krimpzangen, die ich
je gesehen hab.
Und auch, okay, das ist dieser 0850
Billig-Netzwerk-Tester, den jeder schon mal hatte.
Okay, nee, braucht wirklich keiner.
So, was gibt's denn sonst noch?
Langweilig.
Gibt wieder, wirklich ernsthaft
nur Müll.
Blödsinn hab ich noch genug.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Big Brain, 10 Euro, Multimeter, was wahrscheinlich
sonst was misst.
Aber diese China-Multimeter-Dinger,
jetzt, ich hab da schon ein paar Tests gesehen,
die scheinen mir doch
zum größten Teil ein bisschen besser als ihr Ruf
zu sein. Wie läuft's denn mit den
LED-Strips? Richtig gut. Ist alles
fertig jetzt. Guck hier. Post-Image.
Äh...
Wo hab ich denn den letzten?
Tja, Chat, ich hab letztens... History,
History.
Ich hab doch den aktuellen LED-Strip-Stand
letztens gepostet. Post-Image.
Der da vielleicht?
Ah, da. Excellent. Guck mal.
Ich hab extra ein paar
Punkte unterschiedlich hell gemacht, dass man sieht.
Ich hab jetzt, ähm...
Ich hab jetzt Alu-Leisten
gekauft, mit so...
ähm... so einem Milchklar...
milchigen Plastik-
Diffusor davor. Und dann
hab ich das abgeschnitten.
Also hab ich abgemessen, abgeschnitten.
Und jetzt hab ich genau, passgenau
fürs Fenster...
Ich kann meine Browser-History zeigen, überhaupt kein Problem.
Und warum kann ich meine Browser-History
zeigen? Weil ich einen extra Browser hab.
Nur fürs Streamsauen,
wo überhaupt nichts drinnen passieren kann.
Ich zeig euch nicht...
Das ist meine normale Browser-History
würde ich euch im Leben da zeigen, Chat.
Da kann der Chat noch so...
Das...
Vergesst's.
So, ähm...
So sieht's aus mit den LEDs.
Und ihr müsst ja mal zugeben,
das sieht um ein Vielfaches besser aus,
als die erste Installation, die ich hatte,
wo ich einfach mal testweise die LED-Streifen
an das Fenster gepappt hab.
Ah, hier unten muss noch die Kiste zugemacht
werden. Hier liegt ne Kiste, wo das dann alles reinkommt.
Ja.
Viel besser.
So, die Seite
machen wir jetzt noch durch. Irgendwie ist da wieder nichts dabei.
Noch irgendwie...
Hey, ist das nicht dieses... das Billig-China-
Multimeter, was ich mir auch gekauft hab?
Ey, ich glaube schon.
Exzellent.
Reicht, reicht
für das, was ich machen will, aber
ich hab jetzt ein paar Mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt, ob ich mir nicht
schon mal ein wirklich
besseres, ordentlich gutes Multimeter
kaufen sollte.
Was ist das? Schleifsteine?
Oder was? Ne. Hä?
Doch, oder? Ah, ja.
Das ist es.
Amonkatos.
Kann man die Geflächten stecklos
eigentlich per App steuern, oder wie läuft das? Ja, ja.
Du kannst die entweder über den Browser steuern,
hab ich dir ja gerade gezeigt.
Du kannst die entweder über den Browser steuern, hier.
Und dementsprechend kannst du die auch über
das Smartphone steuern, weil du kannst mit deinem Smartphone
einfach auf die Adresse gehen.
Oder du bindest die in deine
Heimautomatisierung ein und die hat ja dann
eine App. Also ich benutze Home Assistant.
Ich zeige euch mal die offizielle Home Assistant Demo,
weil ich mein Home Assistant nicht zeigen will.
Dann leake ich wieder so viel.
Das sieht dann ungefähr so aus.
Das ist jetzt so eine Beispielseite
von denen. Ja, und dann hast du dann hier
einen Knopf für
Steckdose an und aus.
Und das gibt es auch als Smartphone App.
Benutzt du privat auch Chromium?
Ich hab so ziemlich alles an
Browser-Mascher installiert gehabt, ja.
Aber Chromium verwende ich auch so.
Also ich hab aktuell Chromium installiert.
Chrome,
Firefox,
Vivaldi,
Edge,
gezwungenermaßen.
Ich glaub ich soll so irgendwas.
Ich glaub das war's.
Also die 0.15 Browser.
Was hältst du von Fritz deckt?
Kann ich dir noch nicht sagen.
Flo96, ich hab mir jetzt zum ausprobieren
aber ich hab ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht vor das zu benutzen.
Ich hab mir so zum ausprobieren
so einen Fritz Thermostat
mal bestellt.
So eins hier.
Wie gesagt, ich hab nicht vor den Krams zu benutzen,
weil ich brauch nicht noch ein Wireless-Ding,
was ich integriere.
Ich hab WiFi-Sachen in der Heimautomatisierung.
Ich hab Zigbee-Sachen in der Heimautomatisierung.
Ich hab C-Wave-Sachen
in der Heimautomatisierung.
Das unbedingt noch.
Und ich hab noch RF433,
also normal olle Funksachen
für die Rollos drin.
Also ob ich da jetzt noch
eine fünfte Funktechnologie drin brauche,
weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich hab mir mal eins bestellt,
weil ich mir genau die gleiche Frage gestellt hab,
ob diese
AVM
Geschichte was taugt.
Deswegen hab ich mir auch eins bestellt.
Das liegt hier hinter mir.
Das liegt hinter mir
im Karton.
Was genau hast du für Rollos?
Oh, fuck.
Irgendwelche...
Also die, die ich steuere,
das sind so Plastik-Jalousien, so dünne.
Oh, wie heißt der Hersteller?
Irgendwas mit S am Anfang, glaub ich.
Som...
Somfy oder so?
Gibt's sowas?
Sowas hier?
Ja, sowas.
Sowas.
Genau.
Ja, ich hab dann auch so einen
hässlichen Knopf hier dafür.
Ich hab da so einen hässlichen Knopf.
So, und das ist
ganz normales RF, glaub
433 Megahertz.
Und
ich hab mir
einen
RF 433 USB
Adapter gekauft.
Und da kann ich jetzt die Dinger ohne die Knöpfe steuern.
Also ich hab mir
für meine Heimautomatisierung
einen Sender-Empfänger gekauft
für diese Frequenz von denen.
Und
da brauchte man dann so spezielle
Codes, die man sich irgendwie
runterladen musste. Ich krieg das gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen.
Und
dann konnte man
das denen beibringen.
Nee, Kelmore, das geht nicht.
Klingt erstmal easy.
Ja, wenn man eine Fernbedienung hat, kann man
die Signale
quasi
abfangen und kopieren. Kann man nicht.
Weil das sind Rolling Codes.
Und Rolling Codes
ist, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob es so eine Art Verschlüsselung ist für
Infrarot oder
RF.
Rolling Codes
zumindest ändern sich die Sachen,
wenn man den Knopf drückt. Also wenn man den Knopf
drückt, sendet er nicht immer das gleiche.
So, und
den Sender-Empfänger, den ich mir gekauft
hab, der kann diese
Somfy Rolling Codes.
Also allein schon, dass sowas wieder verschlüsselt ist.
Wobei auf der anderen Seite,
das ist sogar ganz gut, dass das verschlüsselt ist,
sonst könnten Leute von der Straße aus Rollen hoch und runter machen.
So, und zumindest, die konnte ich
dann einbinden da drin.
Ja, und dann habe ich mir noch was anderes gekauft.
Ein...
Das habe ich aber schon, habe ich schon
eine Weile und noch nie verwendet.
Ich habe mir so einen Stick gekauft.
Für Duo Fernrollern
Motoren.
Für irgendwie so ein Teil
da, so ein billiger,
den kleinsten, den es gab.
Weil ich den mal ausprobieren wollte.
Irgendwie sowas hier.
Und da gibt es auf Github
eine Python-AP, wo man quasi diesen offiziellen
Hersteller-Stick
auch mit nicht offizieller Hersteller-Software
verwenden kann.
Ich habe mir, wie gesagt, ich habe mir schon viel unnützentechnischen
Kram gekauft, unter anderem auch bei irgendwelchen Black Friday Sales,
Cyber Monday Sales,
die ich habe, einfach weil es mich
interessiert hat, wie es funktioniert.
Nicht so sehr, weil ich es wirklich verwenden will.
Weil da sich das lohnt,
müsste ich quasi jeden Rollladen
mit so einem Teil ausstatten.
Und ich meine, ich habe hier mindestens mal eins, zwei,
drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben,
irgendwie acht, neun Rollläden
oder sowas. Da müsste ich nochmal 1000 Euro
ausgeben. Nur für
Rollläden-Dinger.
Nee, nee, nee, das muss nicht sein.
So oft mache ich die Rollläden nicht hoch und runter.
Wobei,
easy sub money, ne?
Wobei, da fällt mir wieder ein, ich kriege ja nur die Hälfte
von ab, also ist es doch gar nicht so viel.
Nee, ähm,
lohnt sich nicht, das lohnt sich nicht.
So, also wie gesagt, die Seite, die Seite,
nee, Subgoals und sowas.
Ich, ich hab echt,
ich bin jemand, der überhaupt nicht gut
Subs geiern kann.
Es gibt andere, die haben das richtig gut drauf, die können
richtig smoothen Sellout machen.
Die sellouten quasi den ganzen Stream
über und die Leute gehen ab wie sonst was.
Ich kann das nicht gescheit, ich bin kein guter
Sellout-Mann.
Warum machst du die letzte Ziffer im Link immer weg?
Gib mal Ausrufezeichen 1 ein im Chat,
da gibt es eine Erklärung dazu.
Zugeschrieben 1.
Also die Erklärung ist unterm Strich, weil ich sie nicht mehr alle hab.
So, ähm.
Oh, hier ist nichts dabei.
Oh, die sind gut, die Dinger.
Äh, so, so, äh.
Weiß gar nicht, wie die auf Deutsch heißen,
die Dinger. Äh, wie nennt man das?
Wie heißt denn sowas auf Deutsch?
Tufenbohrer.
Ist wirklich Tufenbohrer.
Okay, ähm.
Die sind wirklich praktisch.
Da hab ich mir auch mal so ein Set gekauft.
Nicht, glaub nicht das hier, aber
die sind wirklich praktisch.
Wenn man zum Beispiel
in, äh, Gehäuse
Löcher machen will,
die quasi schön weich sind, also
schön, schön, schön eben und
gut ausschauen. Oder auch in 3D
Drucke und sowas.
Da sind diese Sachen wirklich, äh,
Gold wert, ja. Da kriegt man schöne,
schöne, äh,
gleichmäßige, nicht
ausgefranste, abgerundete
Löcher. Das ist gut.
Danach braucht man irgend so nen Kabel
Durchführungsding, dass man's
verschraubt auf beiden Seiten und dann ist das Ding
wasserdicht so.
Gibt's dafür
Custom Firmware?
Das Super Rollo?
Custom Firmware für den Super Rollo?
Also, irgendwie, mal wieder
kaum was dabei.
Sonst hat mich nix großartig
angesprochen. Ich scroll mal kurz
durch, was die noch bei
Smart Home haben und dann gucken wir mal kurz bei
den Chinesen, ob sich da irgendwas lohnt.
Hast du Urlaub oder Home Office?
Ich hab jetzt Urlaub. Ich hab schon Urlaub
seit dem, äh,
18.
Bis Januar.
Und davor hatte ich seit März Home Office.
Ist Home Assistant Apple
exclusive oder komplett? Hat mit Apple nichts
zu tun. Gar nichts.
Ist nicht HomeKit. HomeKit ist Apple.
Home Assistant ist komplett Open Source auf
GitHub, ähm,
und
du kannst es entweder im Browser verwenden,
du kannst dir die
PWA installieren oder du kannst dir jeweils
die Companion App installieren auf iOS
oder Android.
Äh, am besten,
also Home Assistant selbst
installierst du allerdings am besten
auf irgendeiner Linux Kiste.
Auf Windows würde ich es nicht verwenden. Ich glaube
Windows ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr
in allen Konfigurationen supported.
Warum so lange Urlaub? Ja, weil ich so viel Urlaub hab.
Unicorn, Salami,
ja, ich finde da auch kaum was. Wie gesagt,
meine Theorie ist ja eh, dass die einfach
ganz viel Müll den Leuten entgegenschmeißen,
dass man dann das Gefühl hat, äh,
dass man ein gutes Gefühl hat, wenn man doch noch irgendwas
findet, ja.
Okay, also was gibt's denn heut bei Smart Home?
Gibt's da irgendwas Sinnvolles?
Okay, Staubsaugerroboter hab ich.
Brauch ich net, hab ich schon zwei.
Ich hab nen ollen, einen ollen, äh,
wenig smarten
Eufy 11.
Den kann man nur mit Infrarot,
Fake-Infrarot-Fernbedienung
losschicken. Dafür ist er klein und kommt
unter das Sofa, unter den Schrank und dann sonst.
Und dann hab ich nen Roborock S50.
Den Roborock, äh, Roborock S50
hab ich natürlich, ihr kennt mich, Leute,
hab ich natürlich auch mit Custom-Firmware
geflasht. Und jetzt
kann ich per Browser auf meinen
Staubsaugerroboter
und den rumkommandieren, ja.
Wettrennen fahren.
Einen Roborock S50 hab ich.
Den da. Und
für mich war der ausschlaggebende Grund,
dass man Custom-Firmware drauf machen kann.
Und dass ich keine China-Cloud brauche.
So.
Ähm.
Übrigens, was auch cool ist.
Wo wir grad,
wo wir grad bei Staubsauger sind.
Ich würd's mal in Linux VM anmachen.
Ähm.
Hast du den Roborock S50 im Angebot
geholt? Ja. Ich hab den,
mal gucken, was der aktuell kostet. Ich glaub, ich hab
290 Euro für bezahlt.
Was, ähm, damals
nen wirklich, S5 und
S50 ist übrigens das gleiche.
Ähm. Ein super Angebot
war... Okay, gibt's
grad gar nicht. Die gibt's
grad gar nicht. Verstehst nicht,
warum man sich nen Staubsaugerroboter holt?
Ja, weil er staubsaugern kann, ohne dass du selbst
staubsaugern musst. Ich dachte
auch nicht, dass es sinnvoll ist. Muss ich dir ehrlich sagen.
Ich hab auch
am Anfang gedacht, total sinnlose Spielerei.
Ähm. Und als ich den dann in meinem Angebot
für 290 gefunden hab.
Und mich mal schlau gemacht hab,
dass man Custom-Firmware drauf machen kann, alles möglich.
Hab ich mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Kauf's dir einfach mal und guck's dir
an. Und ich muss sagen, ich find das
unglaublich praktisch mittlerweile.
Grade im Wohnzimmer für die ganzen
Katzenhaare. Das Ding
fährt einfach los, wenn ich nicht da bin.
Dockt sich wieder an. Und ich leere das Ding mal
aus und gut ist. Übrigens,
was auch cool ist, und was
kaum jemand mit seinem Staubsaugerroboter
kann, hast du ein Snipe
mit Sailforce. Ja, mittlerweile schon.
Wie kommst du denn da drauf, Chillfreak?
Seit einer Woche, seitdem wir uns das mal hier im Stream
angeguckt haben, hab ich mir jetzt eins angelegt
und hab angefangen meine, ähm,
Sensoren und Controller
drin zu erfassen, dass ich die besser finde.
So, Leute. Bam.
SSH-Login auf dem Staubsauger.
Ich weiß, dass jetzt
ein Leak kommt. Es kommt immer ein Leak am Anfang,
aber damit könnt ihr nichts anfangen, es sei denn,
ihr seid bei mir im internen WLAN drinnen.
Guck mal. SSH-Login
auf dem Staubsaugerroboter.
Also, welcher Staubsauger
hat denn schon einen Root-SSH-Login?
Und man sieht da drauf,
auf dem Staubsauger
läuft ein Ubuntu 14.04.
Erstmal
Docker drauf installieren. Also, man kann,
man kann theoretisch,
man kann da
theoretisch Sachen nachinstallieren, ja.
Das ist ein ganz normales Ubuntu
14.04, aber
ich sag euch mal ganz ehrlich,
ich trau
der Sache nicht, das Betriebssystem vom Roboter
so viel zu ändern.
So viel Platz ist da nicht drauf, das stimmt,
aber es geht, es geht eigentlich.
Also, man hat doch, man hat doch
noch ein bisschen Platz.
Guck mal, mein 1,3G, da kann man schon
bisschen was installieren, ja.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Wir haben noch, wir haben noch auf dem
Roboter mal mein Paket, oh,
Mist, äh, ich hab grad mein Headset
runtergeschmissen.
Also, mein Verlängerungsteil vom Headset
So.
Ich muss das mal wieder entwirren.
Das Kabel ist total verknotet.
Das Kabel ist eigentlich 3m lang und jetzt ist es irgendwie
20cm. So,
ähm, was wollt ich jetzt
sagen? Wir haben ja mal
ein Paket-Tracker-Software mal probiert,
auf dem Staubsauger-Roboter auszuführen.
Hat funktioniert.
Es war ein .NET Core-Programm, drauf kopiert, gestartet
und ich konnte meine eigene Software auf
meinem Staubsauger-Roboter laufen lassen.
Hat funktioniert.
Ja, aber wer hat schon einen Staubsauger
mit SSH-Login?
So, ich wollte aber Smart Home mal kurz durchscrollen.
Also, nix, nix,
nix, nix,
nix, nix, jede Menge
Plink. Also, wer sich sowas
kauft, äh, nee, geh mal fort.
Die versuchen ja mittlerweile alle,
irgendwelche Abos unterzujubeln,
ne, so nach dem Motto, ja, kannst Security-
Kamera von uns kaufen, aber, haha,
lokal speichern,
oder irgendwelche Features lokal fänden, nee,
das kannst du natürlich nicht. Das geht nur
über unsere Cloud und das geht dann auch nur mit einem Monats-Abo.
Für nur, für,
für nutzt du Sniper daheim, also hier,
das waren die Testinstallationen, was man hier noch,
was man hier noch gesehen hat, äh,
wo ich mal ausprobiert hab, äh, ich hab das jetzt
installiert
für meine, äh, ganzen
kleinen Technik-Geschichten. Also, ich hab,
ich kanns dir ja mal zeigen, wenn du willst.
Muss mal kurz gucken, dass ich da
nix, äh, drinstehen hab, was
ich nicht will, dass man das sieht.
Ich hab da noch nicht so viel drin.
Hier, ja, nee, kann man, kann man zeigen,
sieht man, sieht nix.
Sowas hab ich da zum Beispiel drinstecken
guck. Excellent Passport.
Äh, sowas steht da
zum Beispiel drinne hier, ja.
Also wie gesagt, ich hab erst angefangen da mit Zeug, Zeug,
Zeug zu erfassen.
So, da steht zum Beispiel drinne,
dass ich, äh,
hier, die, LED-Strip,
äh, ne Rolle
SK6312 RGB
W Black
hab ich in Fach 1 liegen.
So. Und zwar
genau eins Stück.
So, Shelly 1L hab ich jetzt neu bekommen,
hab ich fünf Stück,
hab ich noch fünf, äh, hab ich noch
vier TT Core OT Displayboards, sowas
da. Ich versuch da jetzt nach und nach
meine ganzen kleinen Technik-Sachen reinzukriegen,
weil ich hab mittlerweile das Problem, ich hab
so viel Technik-Krams am Start.
Da sind ja allein, ich hab jetzt hier,
ich hab, ich hab die letzten Tage hier übelst
aufgeräumt, ich hab, ähm,
gefühlt tonnenweise, äh, Amazon-Verpackungen
weggeschmissen und sowas. Ich hab jetzt hier
immer noch fünf, sechs Kartons
voll mit Technik-Krams, mit so
kleinen Scheiß, den ich mir im Laufe der Zeit bestellt hab.
Und, ähm, das muss da alles
rein, weil ansonsten find ich nix.
Ich find nix mehr.
Ja, das mach ich da.
Das Tool an sich ist maßlos
oversized für meine Verhältnisse
und 90% der Features werd ich gar nicht verwenden.
Äh, Trollomat sagt,
mein Vater hat sich so ein Teil gekauft, als es im Angebot war.
Äh, ich weiß
gar nicht, worauf ich das jetzt beziehe.
Du meinst so ein Roborock?
Die Dinger sind richtig nice.
Dann flash das mal deinem Vater.
Ach, ne Blinkkamera?
Oh, ne, die Dinger sind richtig, richtig mies.
Also,
es will dir eh jeder nen Abo aufschwätzen
aktuell.
Alle, alle wollen sie, dass du irgendwie,
also, für Dinger,
die normalerweise selbstverständlich sein sollten,
auch dass sie lokal funktionieren,
wollen sie heute Abos haben, ja?
Hast ne Kamera? Lokal speichern?
Ne, gibt's nicht. Du hast ne Tür-Gegensprechanlage?
Lokal verwenden? Ne, ne,
geht nur mit unserer Cloud und nur mit Abo.
Wie, du willst lokales Backup machen? Ne, gibt's nicht.
Du musst Cloud Backup mit Abo.
Also, richtig, richtig
hängen geblieben.
Deswegen ist bei mir Spartan-mäßig
alles nur
lokal.
Außer halt die Sachen, die online sein
müssen, wie zum Beispiel mein
location tracking
vom Handy,
wo ich, wo ich dann quasi gucken kann,
äh, also,
meine Heimautomatisierung feststellen kann, wo ich gerade
bin, ob ich vielleicht im Heimwicht bin oder so.
Das muss natürlich übers Internet gehen, weil ich meine,
mein Handy ist ja nicht daheim, wenn ich
unterwegs bin und das Handy mit hab, ist ja logisch.
Wenn ich hier gerade in der Bahn sitz,
dann muss das natürlich übers Internet die Position
schicken. Aber
ansonsten ist alles nur lokal. Deswegen lege
ich auch so viel Wert drauf,
dass wenn ich was kaufe, gerade diesen China-
Kram hier, dass ich das flashen kann
mit Custom-Software, wo ich
weiß, dass das lokal funktioniert.
Dazu hab ich noch ein extra IoT-WLAN,
wo quasi
Geräte nirgends wohin dürfen, nicht
ins Internet dürfen. Das einzige, was Geräte in meinem
IoT-WLAN machen dürfen, ist, äh,
NTP, sich Zeit
abrufen, das war's. Nichts.
Sonst nichts. Da darf nichts
rein, nichts raus aus dem WLAN.
Das einzige, was ist, ist der Zugriff auf
diese Geräte von meiner Heimautomatisierung
ist erlaubt, aber...
Weil ansonsten,
ich, ich trau da keinem Hersteller.
Ganz ehrlich, ich
trau da weder
den Chinesen noch
irgendwelchen, äh,
Teams oder sonst was. Das ist alles,
ist alles Hardware,
wo ich keine Ahnung hab, was sie eigentlich im Hintergrund
macht. Und noch schlimmer,
sie kann von heute auf morgen nicht mehr
funktionieren, weil der Hersteller keinen Bock hat.
Äh, Philips Hue,
ne, nicht Philips Hue, äh doch Philips Hue,
Philips Hue auch,
die haben auch mal alte Hubs
unbrauchbar gepatcht, aber
das beste Beispiel dafür ist TP-Link.
TP-Link hat
letztens ein Firmware-Update verteilt,
wo die lokale, der lokale Zugriff
einfach abgeschaltet wurde. Sie haben sich
rausgeredet mit, ja,
äh, Security.
Und dann haben die Leute da gesessen,
Scheiße, geht nicht mehr. Und dann hat, dann hat
TP-Link gesagt, ah, aber ihr könnt ja unsere
Cloud verwenden.
Also was die Aktion sollte,
weiß man jetzt ja. Mittlerweile, nachdem
der Shitstorm so groß war, haben sie
gesagt, ja, okay, vielleicht
entwickeln wir doch wieder eine Firmware, mit der man lokal
drauf zugreifen kann und wer uns anschreibt,
der kriegt auch das Downgrade und bla und so.
Aber, aber nur weil die Leute sich wahnsinnig
direkt haben.
So, und du bist halt auf Gedeih und Verderben
deinem jeweiligen Cloud-Anbieter
ausgeliefert. Und wenn du jetzt, sagen wir mal,
du Geräte von 20 verschiedenen
Herstellern hast, was echt nicht viel
ist, es gibt ja schon verschiedene, es gibt ja schon 20 verschiedene
recht verbreitete Geräte, Gerätekategorien
für Heimautomatisierungs-
Geschichten, ähm,
und dann der ein oder andere
Hersteller sich überlegt, ah, nee, ich geh jetzt pleite,
oder, ah, nee, ich verkauf das, oh, nee, das wird eingestellt.
Zum Beispiel Nest.
Ist ja mittlerweile Google.
Und, äh, Nest
hat von heute auf morgen auch gesagt, ach, nee,
Zugriff
auf das
Nest-System, nee, das gibt's nicht mehr.
Also das heißt, du konntest dann,
je nachdem, was du dir zuhause für
eine Automatisierung gebaut hast, du
konntest dann einfach deinen Thermostat nicht mehr verwenden.
Weil die sich gedacht haben, ne, haben wir keine Lust mehr,
wollen wir nicht.
Und natürlich haben die auch gesagt, ja, Moment,
wenn du jetzt natürlich unsere Google-Apps dafür verwendest,
dann funktioniert das noch.
Aber will ich mich wirklich
davon abhängig machen auf
ähm, gut Wetter
mit irgendwelchen China-Herstellern?
Deswegen, bei mir ist das alles lokal.
Und eine Möglichkeit auch direkt mit
Customfirma, wo ich weiß,
dass das nicht
entweder nach China funkt,
in die USA funkt, an, äh,
bauen sie irgendwo hin
funkt, oder geschweige denn
irgendwelche Updates die Funktion ausschalten bekommt.
Am besten gleich Customfirma drauf
und Ruhe ist.
Und dann kann ich eigentlich Linux in einer Form laufen,
beziehungsweise kein Dual-Booten,
in jedem Fall Linux als Main OS.
Weil ich Sachen mache, die unter Linux nicht gehen,
nicht gescheit gehen,
also mein ganzes Video-Bearbeitungs,
Audio-Bearbeitungs und ähm,
Audio? Wie das?
Äh, Foto, Thumbnail
funktioniert nicht gescheit unter Linux.
Zumindest nicht mit der Software,
mit der ich mich einigermaßen auskenne.
Und mit GIMP fang ich gar nicht an.
Ähm, so, also ich mach halt
viele Sachen unter Windows, die Windows-Only
oder hauptsächlich Windows-Only
oder nur gut, richtig gut so unter Windows funktionieren.
Und, ähm,
Dual-Boot ist mir zu anstrengend.
Deswegen, also ja,
die ganze Gaming-Geschichte außen vor, ja.
Ähm, es geht zwar mittlerweile
viel unter Linux, was Gaming angeht,
aber spätestens, wenn man, äh,
aktuelle Multiplayer-Sachen spielen will, die Anti-Cheat
haben, dann ist die Chance
doch, ja, höher,
dass es nicht geht, als dass es geht.
Und, äh,
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, nachdem ich
zu faul bin für Dual-Boot und Dual-Boot
nervig ist, zumal ich die Sachen ja auch
mehr oder weniger parallel mache,
ich mach einfach
Host Windows
und VM Linux.
Weil alles, was ich auf Linux mache,
lässt sich wunderbar nahezu in Native
Geschwindigkeit unter Linux machen in der VM.
Und ich kann alles, was ich
unter Windows machen will, Native
Geschwindigkeit unter Windows machen.
Also für mich ist es das optimale Setup.
Äh, eine Frage an alle,
auf Thema, was
könnt ihr bestätigen,
dass DVI
äh,
ehrlich gesagt, ich hab davon
absolut keinen Plan, aber
nachdem beide
Techniken das
digital an den Monitor übertragen,
wüsste ich nicht,
warum es
einen Unterschied zwischen DVI und HDMI geben
sollte. Es sei denn,
dein Kabel ist kaputt. Und dann hast du
halt diese typischen, äh,
Digitalübertragungsgeschichten. Du hast halt
dann nicht etwa Gerausche, wie
mit einem halb kaputten Kabel, als es analog war.
Sondern, äh,
du hast dann halt gar kein Bild
oder halt komplett Bildaussetzer.
Also, ich wüsste
nicht, warum die Qualität
irgendwie anders sein sollte. Weil das, was da übertragen
wird, die Bildinformation, werden bei beiden digital
übertragen und die Bildinformation selbst
sind bei beiden die gleichen.
Äh, ja, ich hab erst bei mir angefangen
hier mit...
Ja, klar, wenn du noch
das analoge in DVI verwendest,
dann schon. Aber das macht ja keiner.
Ähm...
Ich hab jetzt bei mir
angefangen mit RGB
Beleuchtung.
Ach, ne, du meinst die...
Ne, da kann ich dir nichts zu sagen.
Elgato Keylight ist diese Streaming
Kamera, ne? Ne, da kann ich dir nichts zu
sagen. Das ist die Streaming Kamera,
oder? Ja. Ne, keine Ahnung.
Da weiß ich nichts zu.
So, generell Heimautomatisierung und
RGB Beleuchtung bin ich grad dabei, aber zu dieser
Streaming Kamera, keine Ahnung.
So, ich wollte doch hier noch schnell die Heimautomatisierungsdienst
durchscrollen.
Leute, by the way, ich wollt glaub ich schon vor
zwei Stunden weg sein, ne?
Ja. Nein, nicht ganz vor
eineinhalb Stunden, aber scheiß drauf.
Jetzt ist eh zu spät, jetzt kann ich auch da
bleiben.
Klappt dein RGB-Streifen jetzt auch mit dem kleineren
Controller? Äh, ja, würde
eher. Ich hätte mal den Flash
komplett löschen müssen, dann
funktioniert's. Ich hab jetzt aber
auch einen anderen Controller. Ich hab jetzt
einen ollen ESP2866
genommen, einfach weil ich davon noch so viele
hab und das dafür dann locker reicht.
Was? Kannst du eine
WiFi-Karte oder Access... ähm, ne.
Ne. Also,
die Mikrotik-Singer sind alle
Linux-based, kannst aber keinen Zugriff auf
Linux drunter.
Ich hab nur noch
UniFi-Access-Point mittlerweile, ja.
Die sind zwar
nicht Linux, oder sind glaub ich schon
Linux-mäßig unten drunter, aber du hast da keinen Zugriff
drauf. Aber die UniFi-Dinger sind echt
okay. Sind halt leider auch bissl teuer.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Äh, hast du ein Mikrofon-Arm?
Ne. Hab ich nicht.
So.
Also, zeigt mal her. Das ist alles Crap.
Das braucht kein Mensch, was die haben. Oder
braucht vielleicht jemand, weil er
denkt, dass er's braucht, aber da sollte ich lieber was anderes
kaufen als diesen Kram hier.
Also, Plink, Ring und so.
Kommt mir nicht in die Tüte.
Die sind hartnäckig, ne?
Die sind hartnäckig, die
Gosun-Typen.
Die wollen, dass ich nochmal zwei Stück kaufe,
glaub ich.
Wolltest du nicht ne wetterfeste Box suchen? Doch, wollt ich.
Tatsächlich, hast du recht.
Wollt irgendwie so ne IP
86, äh,
sowas suchen in der Richtung.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Case.
Sowas hier. So.
Aber viel zu... What?
Alter, sind die noch ganz... Okay, der wird jetzt viel zu groß.
Ne.
Trocken und wasserdicht ist nicht so.
Ist nicht so das.
Sowas hier in der Richtung reicht mir.
Ja, aber das muss ich nicht im Stream gucken.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich ziemlich langweilig.
So, ähm, alles Müll braucht
man nicht. Alles Müll.
Die Gosun-Typen sind wirklich
hartnäckig wo wir es gerade von hatten china geräte und unterschiedliche
hersteller ist nicht mehr drin wir hatten nämlich wir hatten nämlich
vorhin sachen guck mal die dinger sehen sich auch extrem ähnlich
ich würde nicht wundern wenn das der gleiche hersteller ist und einfach nur
das logo anders wie alles misst brauchen wir nicht welchen 3d drucker hast du ich
habe den i3 mega es habe ich ja vor einem jahr oder so ungefähr gekauft ich
weiß gar nicht mal wann genau ein jahr eineinhalb jahre oder so für meine
sachen reicht ich war kurz kurz davor mir damals so
einen 1000 euro plus 3 fragt mich nicht zu kaufen aber ich habe es noch sein
gelassen hätten die paypal akzeptieren hätte ich
heute davon ein ich war ich habe bei dem shop bestellt
ich weiß das noch ich habe ich habe ich habe das bestellt bei denen wollte
bezahlen
und es ging kein paypal die wollten irgendwas anderes haben und habe ich
gedacht was da los habe ich die angeschrieben gesagt hier jungs ist so
was ihr euch da vorstellen funktioniert nicht
lasst mich mal paypal bezahlen und dann haben wir den link generiert zum paypal
bezahlen und dann habe ich nie bezahlt und habe mir dafür einen billigeren 3d
drucker gekauft also ich habe immer noch die bestellung offen von dem du von dem
teuren 3d drucker
was druckst du denn alles ja nicht so viel deswegen war es eine gute sache dass
ich das nicht gemacht habe
und war schon auf der zweiten seite von einem automatisierung ich druck
hauptsächlich gehäuse für mein technikraums ich hab schon mal ich habe
auch schon mal ein paar sachen gedruckt wo man dann zum beispiel led led ring
vorne an 3d drucker machen kann so was ich habe auch ein paar tools für 3d drucker
selbst gedruckt aber ich druck hauptsächlich irgendwelche cases für
mein technik gebastelt deswegen hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt dass ich einen
teuren 3d drucker gekauft ich trug so wenig und dann so so
unanspruchsvolle sachen dass ich das gar nicht lohnt aber was sich gelohnt hat ist
muss ich sagen ich habe ja vor einer weile mal haben wir das könnten sogar im
stream gemacht habe ich mir nicht mehr sicher mal wirklich ganz genau mein
mein drucker bett gelevelt das hat wirklich was gebracht die drucker sind
jetzt viel besser ist ein drucker noch stock mit sicherheit der nachfolger auf
jeden fall guck mal da warum kostet 100 euro mehr
bei mir hat er 219 moment warum kostet mehr der jetzt zu beliebt geworden dass
die dass die der china hersteller sich gelassen teurer machen die drei mega
müssten anycubic mega
e
es wie order details ich habe nichts gesagt ich habe für den gleichen preis
gekauft ich habe jetzt irgendwie gedacht er war 100 euro günstiger na gut ich
habe sogar noch fünf euro mehr bezahlt so in dem dreh habe ich hier okay ich
habe nichts gesagt guck mal gearbest das stimmt da die d also generell sind 3d
drucker bei in china deutlich deutlich billiger
also dass das lohnt sich mal gucken wie sieht es mal gut aus
bengen gut das das lohnt sich doch dann haben wir germany eu priority mail top
60 cent versand
die chinesen aber wenn es kommt aus auch aus aus cc ist das tschechien oder so
dass nicht china aus china ist er sogar
otto
fack ist das juliabend deswegen habe ich doch ich meine video gesagt das ist
natürlich richtig die welt wenn man denn mal letztes video gesehen hat ich habe
ein paar video für youtube gemacht habe ich gesagt ich verstehe gar nicht warum
so viele leute sagen ich kaufe mir das jetzt nicht ich warte auf black friday
deals haben an der deal oder sonstwas wenn sie doch in china bestellen können
wo preislich das ganze jahr über
Cyber Monday Preise sind für
manche Sachen.
Und wisst ihr, was ich auch überhaupt nicht
verstehe? Es gibt Leute,
also es gibt zwei Sorten
von, die kaufen den gleichen
China-Kram dann bei Amazon
fürs Doppelte und
sagen, oh, ich kaufe ja nicht in China,
weil scheiß Menschenrechte,
aber ich kaufe dann China-Kram bei Amazon.
Ist auch absolut Big Brain.
Und dann
hast du welche, die zu dumm für
alles sind und auf
Wish.com gehen
und sich China-Kacke bei
Wish.com kaufen und irgendwie denken, es ist kein
China-Kram.
Das sind die richtigen Kack-Noobs, Alter.
Wer bei Wish bestellt, der
hat wirklich die Kontrolle über sein Leben verloren.
Also Wish, die Existenzberechtigung
von Wish
erschließt sich mir überhaupt gar nicht.
Wish ist wirklich für Noobs,
der einzige Grund, warum es Wish
gibt, ist, weil es so viele Noobs
gibt, die entweder nicht wissen, dass man in China
bestellen kann, die sich nicht trauen, in China
zu bestellen, oder die zu doof
sind, in China zu bestellen.
Für die ist Wish.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst,
einfach direkt in China kaufen.
Was soll denn da passieren?
Also wenn man bei Wish schon keine
Angst hat, gescampt zu werden,
dann muss man, wenn man direkt aus China
bestellt, auch keine Angst haben, gescampt zu werden.
Weil wahrscheinlich scammen
dich die Chinesen auf AliExpress,
weniger als die Zwischenhändler
auf Wish. Weil AliExpress
als Marketplace ziemlich genau
guckt, was die Hersteller machen. Ich muss
euch sagen, ich hab
bisher mit
PayPal und
diesem Käuferschutzprogramm mehr
Probleme gehabt, als mit dem AliExpress
Käuferschutzprogramm. Ich hab bei
AliExpress schon ein paar Sachen bestellt.
Eine kann ich mich gut erinnern.
Da haben die mir geschickt, das war auch
eine Bestellung für, frag mich nicht, für 120 Euro.
Das war nicht ohne.
Und da haben die mir eine Versandbestätigung geschickt
und da hat sich nix getan. Das hat sich nix getan.
Das hat sich nix getan. Das Ding stand immer noch
auf, irgendwie auf dem Weg zum Flugzeug
oder so. Ähm, da hat sich nix getan.
Und irgendwann hab ich dann bei AliExpress
eine Bestätigung bekommen. Aha!
Ihre Bestellung ist eingegangen. Ist nie bei mir
angekommen.
Jungs, was ist denn da los?
Da hab ich bei AliExpress so einen Case
aufgemacht. Also das gleiche, was man bei PayPal
Käuferschutz, ähm,
ähm, ja, Basti,
jetzt warte mal ab, was ich gerade erzähle.
Es ist eigentlich, ist es gar nicht so schlecht
in China. Es gibt zwar keine Rechte
drauf, aber AliExpress guckt recht genau,
was diese Shops da machen.
Ähm, so, und
da hab ich einen, einen, einen
AliExpress Case aufgemacht
und hab gesagt, Jungs,
äh, was ist denn da los?
Angeblich ist es angekommen, ich hab's
nicht bekommen. Eure Versandbestätigung
sagt auch, es ist nie losgeflogen.
Und dann hat dann der AliExpress-Typ
drauf geantwortet, ja, okay, der Hersteller
wurde kontaktiert. Hersteller hat drauf
geantwortet. Und hat gesagt,
oh ja, bitte, bitte, gib uns noch ein bisschen Zeit
und hier hast du einen neuen Tracking-Link
und der Tracking-Link war original,
das war, das war Massive,
Massive Cheatbait, der Typ.
Der Tracking-Link war exakt der Tracking-Link
vom letzten Mal, der schon drei oder vier
Wochen lang nicht funktioniert hat.
So, der hat gemeint,
ja, er hat es jetzt neu, er hat es jetzt losgeschickt
und das hier wäre jetzt der richtige Tracking-Link.
Aber es war exakt der gleiche Tracking-Link.
Hab ich drauf geantwortet, das ist
da immer noch der gleiche Tracking-Link. So,
und dann hat er gesagt, ja,
und jetzt kommt der Unterschied zu Paypal,
die Erfahrung, die ich mit Paypal gemacht hab,
bei AliExpress war es jetzt so,
die haben zu mir gesagt,
ähm,
wenn, wenn ich
nicht sage,
der Fall ist zu meiner
Zufriedenheit geklärt,
dann, ähm,
also, dann krieg ich oder beschricht
das Geld zurück. Also, dann wird
der Case nicht geschlossen, sondern
es passiert, also ich hab da, ich hab da
im Endeffekt meine Kohle wieder
gekriegt,
dadurch, dass ich nicht reagiert habe.
Also, bei AliExpress war es bisher so,
ich musste sagen, es wurde zu meiner
Zufriedenheit erledigt und dann wurde der
Case, wird der Case geschlossen.
Bei Paypal hatte ich es umgedreht.
Paypal hat dann zu mir gesagt,
ähm, wenn du nicht reagierst bis
da und dahin, dann schließen wir den Case
und der Händler kann seine Kohle behalten, so.
Ähm, also, da war ich echt
überrascht bei AliExpress, dass das quasi,
gut, ich meine,
die Chinesen haben die Beweislastumkehr quasi
eh schon perfektioniert, was das angeht.
Dass das da aber auch so ist.
Also, ich hatte bisher mit AliExpress
äh,
Käuferschutz weniger
Probleme, als mit Paypal-Käuferschutz.
Bei Paypal hatte ich, ich hab mir mal
einen Rack bestellt, bei irgend so einer komischen
ich glaub,
ich weiß nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Ich hatte mir hier mal
einen Rack bestellt, scheiße, den gibt's ja immer
noch, ey, für Online,
für Online-Shopper.
Da hatte ich mir mal 19 Zoll, so ein kleines
19 Zoll Rack bestellt.
Weil's dort eben besonders
günstig war.
Ey, das ist ein kleines Rack.
Sowas hier in der Richtung, hab ich mir da bestellt.
Ja.
Das ist angekommen.
Musstest du auch schon mal
zum Zoll fahren? Ja, ja, musste ich leider.
Musste ich schon öfters. Aber nicht,
aber noch nicht von China, nur als ich
das aus den USA bestellt hab.
Äh, weil die Händler aus den USA
sind zu Kokona im Kopf,
zu verstehen, wie man Zoll-Dokumente
richtig macht. Oder umgekehrt,
die Chinesen wissen, wie man Zoll-Dokumente
faket, keine Ahnung, was da richtig ist.
So, ähm, da hab ich mir so einen Schrank bestellt,
hier bei dieser komischen Kack-Plattform.
Der kam an, zerbrochene Glasscheibe.
Hab ich hingeschrieben, hab ich gesagt, Jungs, eure Lieferung
ist kaputt angekommen. Foto gemacht, hier
Foto hingeschickt. Und, ähm,
keine Reaktion. Ey, doch, doch, stimmt nicht.
Sie haben reagiert, sie haben reagiert,
haben irgendwie gesagt, die Mail ist eingegangen, oder sowas.
Ähm, hab ich gesagt, ja, Jungs, wie läuft
es jetzt mit dem Zurückschicken? Ist kaputt?
Keine Antwort. Nochmal hingeschrieben,
keine Antwort.
Dann bin ich hingegangen, hab PayPal
Käuferschutz aufgemacht, hab gesagt, hier, kaputt
eingekommen. Händler reagiert nicht.
Und, ähm,
dann wollte PayPal, dass man irgendwie
noch belegt, den Fall
ein bisschen, hab ich alles gemacht. Keine Reaktion.
Keine Reaktion. So.
Da hab ich natürlich auch nicht drauf reagiert.
Und dann kam irgendwann eine Meldung so nach dem Motto, ah,
ich müsste jetzt reagieren, sonst wird PayPal
das Ganze zumachen. Sag, nee, nee,
der Hersteller reagiert nicht.
Und dann hat sich PayPal irgendwie eingeschaltet und am
letzten Tag von diesem PayPal Case,
oh Scheiß, am letzten Tag
hat irgendein Typ aus der Stonks-Abteilung
hier daheim angerufen von, von CrowdFox
und hat zu mir gesagt, ey, wissen
Sie was? Behalten
Sie das Ding.
Es ist Ihnen zu teuer, zurückzuschicken.
Äh, ich mein, Sie haben mich zwar
mehr oder weniger gefragt, so, wollen Sie es behalten
oder zurückschicken? Äh, Sie können es ruhig behalten.
Sag, naja, gut, wenn
ihr mich so fragt, behalte ich's.
Da hab ich halt die Glastür rausgemacht
und dann war auch okay. Hab ich's dann umsonst gekriegt
quasi, das war dann in Ordnung. Aber am letzten Tag
und hätte ich nicht reagiert, hätte PayPal
gesagt, ah, nee, gibt keine Kohle und
bei AliExpress war's genau umgedreht.
Also man mag zwar keine Rechte auf
dem Papier haben bei AliExpress,
wo man rechtlich dagegen vor
äh, gehen kann.
Was machst du mit dem Ding ohne Glastür?
Äh, ehrlich gesagt hab ich's mittlerweile
weggeschmissen.
Äh, Grimx, Grimx,
Grimx, your mom.
Ah, exzellent, Big Brain Username.
Seh ich schon. Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, also man mag bei
AliExpress auf dem Papier keine Rechte haben,
aber die sind da recht genau,
was ihre Händler auf ihrer
Plattform machen, weil man muss ja sagen, AliExpress
ist ja nur
ein Marketplace. Also sprich,
wenn ihr hier irgendwas aufmacht bei AliExpress,
das kommt nie selbst von AliExpress,
das kommt immer von
ja,
von Shop,
also vertrauenswürdigerer Name
kann ein Shop ja gar nicht haben.
Shop 5594046.
Würde ich immer wieder kaufen, ja.
Oder hier ist es, buy, go, go,
store, store. Also
ich hab bisher nur gute, was ich sagen will, ich hab bisher
nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht, was ähm,
China-Bestellungen angeht. Und dort wo's,
wo ich keine guten Erfahrungen gemacht habe, halt
mit, weil's nicht ankam oder
sowas, aber auch wirklich wenig war, so
ein ganz kleiner Teil, ähm,
hat mir die jeweilige
Händlerplattform geholfen. Also ich kann
da nix Negatives sagen, ja.
Warum ist das deiner Meinung nach
ein Big-Brain-User-Name? Ja, ist es nicht.
Ist es, ist es, ist es ein Low-Brain-User-Name?
Weiß ich nicht, musst du mir erklären.
Es ist ja dein User-Name!
Vielleicht ist es, vielleicht ist es auch nicht Big-Brain,
vielleicht ist es auch Low-Brain, kann ja auch sein.
Mach auch nen User-Name, go, buy,
fast, so, so Dinger gibt's da, ey,
die, die Store-Names sind teilweise echt
total bescheuert bei AliExpress,
ja. Ja, das hatte ich
auch schon bei Webcams, drei Webcams ohne Mikro-Stores
rumliegen. Ja, die sind ja auch teilweise nicht
blöd bei den Shops, ne. Also,
die sagen dann schon oftmals
so, ey, scheiß drauf, behalt's.
Genau, Wish ist nix anderes
als Dropships. Drop, Dropshipping,
die geben im Endeffekt den Chinesen deine,
deine Adresse und die Chinesen
schicken's zu dir, der Wish-Händler hat damit überhaupt nix
zu tun. Äh,
oh, äh, ja,
also, Sir Kenner,
das kenn ich,
ähm, ich hab
immer nen Adapter, um mit
Keyboard und Maus auf der PS4 zu spielen, glaub ich,
das ist ja eh schon verpönt,
also, das ist ja,
ja, das ist ja quasi fast schon Cheaten,
aber ich, ich muss euch mal was, ich muss euch mal
was gestehen, Leute, ich hab auch so'n Teil,
aber ich
hab nen anderen, ich hab nen anderen, ich hab irgendeinen,
ich glaub, so'n Ding
hab ich mir mal gekauft.
Excellent.
So'n Ding hab ich.
Das ist noch mehr, das ist noch mehr Cheat als das andere,
ja, so.
Aber, ehrlich gesagt,
hat auch nicht dazu gefühlt, dass
ich lieber auf Konsole spiele.
Ja, und ich
hab mir mal in den USA, also
das, wo ich am meisten Zoll dafür bezahlt hab, war
mein Dreamscreen.
Das ist so'n Ambilight-Ding,
das macht man hinter den Fernseher
und dann macht es
so einen auf Ambilight.
Gibt's übrigens nicht mehr,
die sind pleite mittlerweile.
Äh, so'n Teil hatte ich mir bestellt, das muss man sich halt
in den USA bestellen.
So, und am Ende,
hab ich quasi fast das Doppelte
bezahlt, ey, als bei denen im Shop
gekostet hat, also.
Da kam dann am Ende, kam irgendwie die Ami-Fat
noch irgendwie drauf, dann kam
äh,
Mehrwertsteuer drauf,
Zoll drauf
und ich weiß noch, ey,
der Typ beim Zoll, oh Gott,
das war,
das war wirklich mega, mega Low-Brain-Aktion,
ja.
Die Fragen, die dürfen das ja nicht aufmachen beim Zoll.
Beim Zoll,
die, die dürfen das behalten und die können das dann quasi
mit dir zusammen aufmachen.
Also, haben wir aufgemacht, reingeguckt
und
da hab ich, da hat er gefragt, was ist das?
Hab ich gesagt, ja, das ist, sind im Endeffekt
Lichter, die macht man hinten so an Fernseh dran
und da hat er gemeint, ah, das wär ein Fernsehgerät.
Nein! Das ist kein, das ist
kein Fernsehgerät.
Das sind Lichter, die macht man an Fernseh dran.
Das hat er nicht verstanden.
Und da hat er versucht, den so rauszubekommen, was ist
das denn jetzt? Also, wozu gehört das jetzt? Gehört das jetzt
zu Fernsehgerät oder gehört das zu Beleuchtung
oder ob es...
Ich glaub, der hat bis zum Ende nicht kapiert,
dass das kein Fernseh ist, sondern ein
LED-Strip, den man hinten an Fernseh dran pappt.
Wie bezahlst du
bei AliExpress? Kommt immer drauf an, was der
jeweilige
Shop anbietet. Deswegen mag ich
Banggood eigentlich, weil man bei Banggood
relativ oft mit PayPal bezahlen
kann. Gucken wir mal, ob wir hier auch
mit PayPal bezahlen können.
Ja. Kann man.
Was ist denn klar, ne?
Das ist bestimmt irgendwas Russisches, ja?
Ja, bei AliExpress hängt es halt auch extrem
vom Shop ab, was man damit bezahlen kann.
Also, das Schlimmste bei AliExpress, da muss
ich mal bei Alipay bezahlen.
Alipay
zu einer Zeit,
ähm, wo Alipay
noch komplett auf Chinesisch war.
Da habe ich mir einen Account gemacht mit
Google Translator bei Alipay.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie man da
was aufladen konnte mit Alipay.
Konnte man an Alipay PayPal überweisen?
Also, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich kriege das gar nicht mal zusammen.
Zumindest muss ich
einen Account bei Alipay machen,
um das bezahlen zu können.
Das war echt abenteuerlich.
Alipay Account mit Google Translator
und dort einen Account angelegt.
Also, ich bezahle
am liebsten über PayPal,
wenn es bei dem jeweiligen Shop möglich ist.
Ich bin damit gar nicht sicher,
aber bei Banggood weiß ich, da habe ich das letzte Mal
mit PayPal bestellt, dass das geht.
Wie gesagt, ich bezahle immer
am liebsten per PayPal, wenn es möglich ist.
Übrigens, es gibt jetzt,
ich habe heute Werbung bekommen von PayPal,
dass es jetzt eine
PayPal-Karte gibt.
Karte oder so?
Wie hieß das?
Ich habe es doch hier liegen.
PayPal-Debit-Card.
Nicht digital.
Also eine Kreditkarte im Endeffekt.
Und ich bin ernsthaft darüber überlegen,
normalerweise, wenn ich Werbung bekomme,
mache ich das nie.
Das ist aber so ein Ding,
ich muss sagen,
ich bin wirklich geneigt,
das zu machen,
weil ich habe schon oft überlegt,
wie wäre das nicht gut,
wenn man mit Aliexpress,
nicht Aliexpress, vergesst,
wenn man nicht mit PayPal einfach bezahlen könnte
oder wenn man sein PayPal-Guthaben
einfach ganz normal verwenden könnte
und das ging nie,
das ging die ganze Zeit nicht.
Du musstest das immer auf dein normales Bankkonto überweisen
und damit geht das
nicht.
Ich habe immer so viel
Kohle bei PayPal rumgammeln,
dass ich mich schon oft gewünscht habe,
Alter, könnte ich den Scheiß
jetzt mal bei PayPal bezahlen?
Gibt es monatliche Kosten
für, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Fies.
There is no cost to apply
Das ist nicht
kostet sich dafür anzumelden, ist ja wohl mal selbstverständlich,
oder?
Ja.
Kostet nichts.
Irgendwelche Service Fies,
Überziehungsgebühren
oder sowas,
Ausland überweisen.
Ich muss mir das mal genauer angucken,
aber das war seit langem mal eine Werbung,
die ich gesehen habe, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
okay, gar nicht mal so schlecht,
könnte man vielleicht machen.
Ja, ich habe aktuell auch von der Sparkasse
noch einen Kredit, noch eine Mastercard,
da bezahle ich auch irgendwie
ein paar Euro im Jahr für, ja.
Brauche ich die mittlerweile gar nicht mehr,
weil PayPal sich jetzt schon auch bei China Shops
und allem durchgesetzt hat.
Eigentlich brauche ich gar keine,
wenn ich so richtig überlege,
es gibt eigentlich so gut wie nichts,
was ich mit
Kreditkarte bezahle.
Okay, okay.
Okay, doch.
Aber sage ich euch nicht was.
Und es ist nicht Belle Delphine
Onlyfans.
Aber die haben bloß
Kreditkarten an, nur Kreditkarte.
Aber ansonsten brauche ich für nichts
eine Kreditkarte.
Und nein, es ist auch nicht Pornhub Premium.
Aber ansonsten
brauchst du echt für nichts mal eine Kreditkarte.
Was ist denn überhaupt stehen geblieben hier?
Was, was, Chat,
was wollte ich denn jetzt machen?
Genau, wie man bezahlt.
Ja, wie gesagt, wenn es geht, immer PayPal.
Guck mal, ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe im Chat.
Also,
Max, nur mal eine kurze Frage.
Ich bin gerade an meiner Bewerbung zum Systemintegrator.
Nenn mal bitte
zwei bis drei Sachen,
die da essentiell sind und mit rein sollen
an Interessen ETC.
Bevor ich dazu was sage,
Geh doch mal in dich,
was sind denn die Gründe,
warum du das machen willst?
Sag mir das mal.
Wieso bist du da drauf gekommen,
weil du das machen willst?
Weil, bevor ich dir irgendwelche generic Sachen erzähle,
wäre es doch sinnvoller,
es wäre irgendwas,
was auch auf dich zutrifft, oder?
Es sei denn, du willst das gar nicht machen.
Also, ich meine, es muss ja irgendwas gegeben haben,
dass du jetzt gesagt hast,
ja, das ist was, was ich machen will.
Geld kriegst du ja auch woanders, ja.
Also sprich,
es muss ja irgendwo mal,
irgendwas muss dich auf die Idee gebracht haben
und sei es nur mal ein Video, was ich dazu gemacht habe,
vielleicht irgendwann mal,
warum du das machen willst.
Moin Lukas, 320
Bitcoins.
Nutzt du Google Apple Pay?
Ne.
So, also was man hier wieder schön sieht,
auch der 3D-Drucker kostet quasi 100 Euro weniger
in China.
So, aber,
ich wollte jetzt gerade nochmal schauen,
ob die irgendwelche guten,
kann man hier filtern?
Halle Express ist ja auch schon ein bisschen eine Rotzeit, oder?
Also, du findest ja da echt nix.
Schiff aus...
Schiff aus Germany, exzellent, ja.
Alquara Cube schon getestet?
Nein, aber ich habe einen bestellt.
Schiff aus Germany
kostet gleich... Moment, das...
Moment...
Okay, aber nicht viel billiger als...
Okay, also,
Interesse an Software, Hardware,
Lösung von Problemen,
mein Bildschirm ist noch schwarz, wenn ich die Rechnung anschalte oder hilfe,
ich habe das Internet gelöscht, ansonsten Basic...
Ja! Genau das!
Genau das kannst du da reinschreiben!
Gerade das hier!
Gerade das hier,
dass du dich für Netzwerke interessierst,
dass du dich für logische Sachen
und Programmieren interessierst,
dass du dich fürs
Lösen von Problemen interessierst,
auch allgemein, dass du...
dass du...
Interesse an Software, Hardware,
ist sehr generic, ja.
Aber gerade das hier, Lösen von Problemen,
ist eine super Geschichte, dass du dich für
Programmieren interessierst, dass du dich für Netzwerke interessierst,
diese Sachen zusammen ist eigentlich optimal
für einen Fachinformatiker.
Ach so!
Für Hobbies!
Gut, woher soll ich wissen, was du da für
Hobbies reinschreiben kannst?
Tja, das ist halt die Frage, was das
für ein Laden ist, ne? Also,
ich würde ja
es nicht negativ auslegen,
wenn einer sagt, er spielt
Competitive Counter Strike oder sowas, in einem Team.
Dann würde ich sogar sagen, hey, das ist cool,
den würde ich vielleicht sogar
dann, keine Ahnung, beim Bewerbungsgespräch
fragen, sag mal, was bist du für ein Rank?
Aber es mag bestimmt den ein oder anderen
Boomer Human Resources
Typ geben,
der damit nichts anfangen kann.
Sich interessieren und können
sind leider noch zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe,
aber ist doch egal.
Deswegen machst du ja eine Ausbildung.
Du machst ja keine Ausbildung, weil
du schon alles kannst. Also,
es gibt meiner Meinung nach viel zu viele Azubis,
die der Meinung sind, sie können das
alles schon und sie machen die Ausbildung
nur, weil
sie brauchen dann einen Zettel, wo das draufsteht.
Das stimmt bei den meisten nicht,
die damit anfangen.
So, und wenn er, genau,
das ist eine Bewerbung für eine Ausbildung. Wenn er sich halt zu viel bewirbt,
dann
muss er ja nichts können. Okay, wenn du Gaming
rauslassen willst, ehrlich gesagt, ja,
was weiß ich, was man da reinschreiben kann.
Ich habe schon ewig keine Bewerbung mehr geschrieben und
ich würde mittlerweile bei Hobbys tatsächlich
reinschreiben, dass ich Sachen, aber okay,
ja,
was könnte bei irgendeiner Stonks Firma gut
ankommen als Hobbys?
Schreib Wandern und Radfahren rein,
das ist so schön unverfänglich, da
kann keiner was dagegen sagen.
Golfspiel.
Aber wenn du da nichts, willst du da,
also ich meine,
wenn du da was reinschreiben willst als Hobby,
was, was Technisches ist,
also was, was irgendwie zu dem,
zu dem Beruf
passt, boah, was könnte
man da schreiben?
Die Idee finde ich gut, doch der Chat, der Chat
ist heute mal wieder enorm hilfreich,
also ernst gemeint, das finde ich gut.
Ähm,
Technologien ausprobieren,
finde ich,
ist, ist, ist
ein super Hobby, wenn man sich,
wenn man sich als Fachinformatiker, also das
fände ich cool, wenn das drinnen steht.
Schach, Alter, spielst du wirklich Schach
oder hast du einfach nur Schach reingeschrieben,
weil es sich Big Brain anhören soll?
Das ist
Fail.
Das ist ein Kackladen.
Also, von einem Azubi sollte man
nicht erwarten, dass er das kann.
Wenn jemand natürlich sagt, hey,
äh, ich interessiere mich für
Programmieren, ich habe schon ein paar kleine Sachen gemacht,
ist es das eine, aber da kann man ja nicht jetzt hier
von, von großartigen
Kenntnissen und, und großartig Können
sprechen, das ist eher so, ich interessiere mich ein bisschen für,
ja, aber ich finde, man sollte
Azubis nicht so sehr danach auswählen,
ähm, ob sie, ob sie
irgendwie Sachen quasi jetzt gleich
schon voll einsatzfähig machen können.
Dafür ist eine Ausbildung nicht da.
Also das, aus, aus meiner Sicht
ist das Wichtigste, was ein Azubi hat,
der haben muss, der muss sich eben
für die Inhalte interessieren, weil sobald
er sich für die Inhalte interessiert, kommt der Rest
mehr oder weniger von allein.
Bildest du aus, äh, ich, nein, ich habe keinen,
also, ich habe weder eine eigene Firma mit Azubis
noch habe ich irgendwie die offizielle
Lizenz zum Ausbilden
oder sowas, aber ich habe bei uns halt ab und zu
schon ein paar Azubis betreut.
Und bin da auch öfters mal bei irgendwelchen, äh,
Abschlusspräsentationen und, äh,
Monatsdingern und Ausbildungsberichte,
Gedöns und Krams dabei, ähm,
ja, das heißt, ich
bin da nicht ganz komplett
planlos. Äh, das ist eine
Ausrede für, äh,
wir verstehen uns nicht, würde ich sagen.
Das ist bla bla bla.
Äh, in der Regel
nicht, aber ich war schon bei, ich war schon
bei welchen dabei und, äh,
also was
mich immer nervt, sind Personalleute.
Am besten ist bei uns unsere
Personalleute, in letzter, ich war aber schon eine ganze
Weile nicht mehr dabei. Am besten sind
unsere Personalleute, die dann
Stellenanzeigen schreiben,
es geht jetzt nicht so sehr um Azubis, auch um andere,
die Stellenanzeigen schreiben auf Grundlage
dessen, was ihnen irgendein Typ mal erzählt
hat, was man technisch braucht.
Und da kommen dann Stellenanzeigen raus, wo ich mir so denke,
Alter, da hat sich wirklich jemand
drauf beworben?
Das sind dann so Stellenanzeigen wie,
wir suchen Leute mit Erfahrung in
Cisco, VMware,
Windows, Linux,
Sun, Firewalls,
Kernelentwicklung,
äh, Java-Entwicklung,
äh, DevOps,
Cloud, Azure, AWS, Google
Cloud-Plattform, da denkst du so, was ist
passiert, wer hat das denn geschrieben?
Und da
sich da auch wirklich Leute drauf bewerben.
Also ja, das ist, ja,
so alles, es ist teilweise ganz wirr.
Wir hatten mal
für unseren, jetzt kein Witz,
für unseren Support,
hatten wir mal eine
Stellenanzeige, da stand
drin, ITIL
das geht schon gut los,
ITIL-Zertifizierung,
äh, Erfahrungen,
Zabbix,
RedHat,
VMware, also
Windows AD,
hochverfügbare Systeme,
Cloud,
äh, was war noch drin?
Kann es fast gewesen sein?
Ne, ich glaub es war noch ein bisschen, ich glaub es war noch mehr drin.
Äh,
ja, es ging irgendwie so in die
Richtung weiter. Für den Support,
also für,
ich geh ans Telefon und nehm,
und nehm, ähm,
ne Störung auf und leite eine Entstörung
in die Wege bei den eigentlichen Leuten,
die sich damit auskennen. Für den Support,
also, da waren sie echt,
also das war wirklich komplett jenseits,
voll des Realistischen,
ja.
Ach ja, da haben sich Leute drauf bewor- ach ja, ach ja,
ich hatte, das Wichtige,
Bereitschaft zur Schichtarbeit, das Wichtigste
hab ich ja vergessen, Bereitschaft zur Schichtarbeit,
zur Schichtwochenend- und Nachtarbeit,
war noch dabei.
Also nur vom Feinsten,
nur vom Allerfeinsten.
Ja.
Und ihr werdet's nicht glauben, da haben sich Leute drauf
beworben, aber das Witzige war,
die haben's richtig gemacht,
die haben nämlich schon predicted,
dass die Stellenanzeige
kacke ist.
Und die haben sich da drauf beworben,
und hatten vielleicht,
zwei, drei Sachen davon,
und wurden dann trotzdem genommen.
Weil die, die haben richtig
predicted, die haben predicted, die Stellenanzeige
ist von Deppen, oder naja, was heißt von Deppen, von
nicht so sehr in der Materie
Leute, nicht so sehr in der Materie
drin ist, geschrieben worden.
Und
das haben die richtig predicted,
heute sind sie am Start, ja.
Und am geilsten war,
wenn die sagten, ich würd sie euch ja zeigen,
aber dann, dann sieht man,
wo ich arbeite, das will ich auch nicht.
Ich sag ja immer, ich sag nur,
bei ner Bank in Frankfurt, da gibt's
jetzt ja doch schon genug, ja.
Also da sieht man das
nicht so, Banken in Frankfurt gibt's ja, wo du hinspuckst.
Ähm, fuck.
Hab vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Ähm, genau.
Da stand in der Stellenanzeige,
stand dann auch drin, was die Vorteile
sind von
dieser, diesem
Arbeitgeber.
Stand da drin. Und,
das war, wie wir uns hier manchmal
Stellenanzeige angucken, ja.
Ähm,
das war,
das
Unkreativste überhaupt.
Da stand dann drinnen,
ähm,
irgendwie überdurchschnittliche
Vergütung, das schreiben ja eh alle rein,
äh, gute Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten,
ein moderner und,
und, äh,
zukunftsfähiger
Arbeitsplatz oder irgendwie sowas stand da drinnen.
Also, da stand nichts
drin, wirklich gar nichts, wo ich
sagen würde, oh ja, da will ich hin.
Und ich hab dann irgendwann mal mir die Mühe gemacht
und hab dem Chef
von dieser Abteilung,
der, wo dieser Support arbeitet,
hab ich ihm mal ein paar Sachen dazu geschrieben, was mich
persönlich jetzt von den
Vorteilen, die wir haben in der Firma,
dazu bringen würde, ähm,
das in Erwägung zu ziehen,
ja. Zum Beispiel, dass wir flexibler
flexible Arbeitszeiten in Form von, ähm,
ähm,
dass wir, äh,
höhenverstellbare Schreibtische haben,
dass wir eine eigene Kantine haben,
dass wir, äh, ach, ich weiß gar nicht,
so Dinger. Und ich hab gedacht, ey,
das sind wirklich Pluspunkte,
wo man sagen könnte, ja,
das gefällt mir.
Ich mein, gerade eine Kantine im Haus ist super.
Oder, naja, im Haus nicht, aber
eine subventionierte
Kantine in der Nähe, ja.
Ähm,
auch, auch gerade
für Leute, die
da ganz, die, die da wirklich 24
7 Support machen, für die ist ein höhenverstellbarer
Schreibtisch und sonstige technischen Sachen
sicherlich auch ganz interessant, ja. Dann,
dass man ein kostenloses iPad, iPhone bekommt,
zum Beispiel. Und auch
privat verwenden kann. Das sind so Sachen,
wo ich mir denke, ey, das sind
Vorteile, schreib die doch rein. Und nicht so dieses
0815 Generic Zeug,
ein toller, zukunftsfähiger Arbeitsplatz
bei einem der Besten
der Branche oder so Gedöns. Wer,
wer lässt sich von so einem,
äh, iPad nicht jeder,
aber iPhone jeder.
iPad kriegt nicht jeder, aber
es gibt ein paar, die haben ein iPad,
aber ein iPhone kriegt jeder. Aber es gibt auch,
also, gerade wenn du im Support
arbeitest, sind die Chancen, dass du relativ
hoch, dass du ein iPad kriegst,
weil der Support muss
unsere Mobile Apps testen.
Täglich.
Und deswegen hat man da
ein iPad für. Normales.
Kein Pro. Ganz normal.
So, jetzt habe ich bestimmt ein paar Sachen
übersehen. Wurde bei uns auch
letztens genutzt? Ja.
Das ist überhaupt nicht erlaubt, ne?
Das probieren die bei uns auch.
Bei uns wird auch immer gesagt, ja Moment,
über das Gehalt kannst du doch nicht reden, das geht doch gar nicht.
Der Witz ist halt,
du hast eigentlich keine Vorteile
dadurch, nicht über das Gehalt zu sprechen.
Ähm,
der einzige
Vorteil ist dein Arbeitgeber, weil
wenn
die Leute untereinander nicht wissen, was der andere
verdient, dann kann er natürlich sagen, ah, ja,
nee, nee, also da ist jetzt leider gar nichts mehr drin,
wenn ich mir das so ankomme. Wenn du natürlich
weißt, dass irgendwelche anderen Leute
irgendwie ein Drittel mehr bekommen,
die ähnliche Sachen machen wie du,
tja, das ist halt schwierig, ne?
Wie sie dann erklären sollen, warum das
bei denen okay ist. Ähm,
Supportic, ich
bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das
bei mir nicht auch drin steht.
Ich könnte mir,
ich glaube sogar, da steht
drinne oder stand drinne
in der alten Variante,
aber da ist
eh fraglich, wie
wie haltbar so Dinger
sind.
Aber ich rede ja auch gar nicht über das Gehalt.
Mach ich nie. Äh, ich rede
über, wenn schon, über
Stufen im Tarifvertrag und
äh,
Beschäftigtenjahre und sonst was und da kommt man
auch schon ziemlich gut hin, was am Ende rauskommt.
Klar, jeder hat noch ein bisschen Bonus oben
drauf, also es ist bei uns nicht der nackte
Tarifvertrag mit, äh,
Jahren und Stufe.
Es hat hier noch ein bisschen Bonus oben drauf,
ein bisschen, so wenig ist es jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht. Ähm, aber man kommt schon
recht gut im Gefühl für,
was man so verdient.
Ohne, dass man wirklich über das Gehalt reden muss.
Und außerdem bei uns,
ähm,
außerdem ist es bei uns so,
dass die
auch öfters mal,
dass die Abrechnung nicht so ganz stimmt.
Und allein schon aus dem Grund tauschen, tauschen
sich die Leute aus. Das heißt,
dieses Fass will da gar keiner aufmachen,
dass jemand wirklich da drauf besteht und sagt,
ihr dürft da nicht drüber reden.
Ja, gibt es.
Ähm,
weil die Leute müssen miteinander reden, allein schon um zu überprüfen,
ob ihre Abrechnung stimmt. Man darf so nicht
vergessen, ähm,
dass es eigentlich ein Unding ist, dass sie das seit
drei Jahren oder so nicht hinbekommen,
dass die Abrechnung, also seit über drei Jahren ist
bei manchen Leuten kontinuierlich die Abrechnung, also
ne, kontinuierlich, immer wieder bei den gleichen Leuten,
ist die Abrechnung falsch. Hallo?
Wir sind einer der größten,
ja, Finanzdinger in Deutschland.
Kann doch nicht sein. The fuck?
Naja.
Ja, ey,
das, das kann ich,
das kann ich zum Teil verstehen, ja.
Ähm, die Frage ist halt
nur, wenn die was ähnliches
machen wie du,
warum sie nur so einen Hungerlohn bezahlen?
Was würde bei einem Vorstellungsgewinn, ob ich
bereit wäre, vor Ausbildung statt an drei Jahren ein Praktikum
zu machen, um nötige
Erfahrungen zu machen?
Das finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Das finde ich sinnvoll, sowas zu machen, ja.
Ja, Whitebird, das ist ja dann richtig bescheuert.
Ähm, das finde ich gut, sowas.
Übrigens, das zeugt meiner Meinung nach auch
davon, dass das ne ganz gute Firma ist,
wenn die sagen, hey, an sich
würden wir gut zusammenpassen,
aber wir schlagen vor,
zur Vorbereitung das zu machen. Das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Das sind eh die Besten.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch schon mal erzählt hab,
wie damals mein
Bewerbungsgespräch gelaufen ist, wo ich mich
für die Ausbildung beworben hab. Also ich hab ja
mal vor etwas längerer
Zeit, 2007
war das dann,
äh,
ich hab mal
ne Ausbildung gemacht,
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
So, und
das war übrigens nicht meine erste
Ausbildung.
Ich hab davor Stonks Zeug gemacht.
Aber da hatt ich keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Und ich habe schon immer
Stonks Zeug gehasst.
Ich hab, ich, ich, Wirtschafts-BWL-Kram
kannst du mich echt jagen mit. Ich weiß gar nicht, was
mich da gerissen hat, ja.
Ähm,
naja, so.
Ähm, zumindest hab ich dann noch ne Fachinformatiker
Ausbildung gemacht, was ja im Endeffekt
auch das war, was ich machen wollte.
Und ich hab mich damals bei nem
Provider beworben, und
ich hab mir ja
sonst was ausgemalt,
wie das, wie das funktioniert.
Also mit, mit Bewerbung und
Vorstellungsgespräch und sonst was.
Und ich hab gedacht, da kommen jetzt die ultrakomplizierten
fiesen Fragen und so.
Ich glaube, ich hab im Nachhinein
eine Sache richtig gemacht. Die ist mir aber erst
im Nachhinein eingeleuchtet,
ja. Also ich bin da hingefahren
zu nem Provider.
Und wurde alle eingeladen. Hab ich beworben, wurde eingeladen.
Bin hingefahren.
Und, ähm,
dann gab's erstmal so nen, so nen
Basic Test.
Und die haben damals auch gesagt,
das ist eigentlich nicht der Test für Azubis,
sondern das ist der Test, den auch normale
Leute bei ihnen kriegen. Sie wollen einfach nur
mal gucken, wie man sich schlägt.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, das war ein bisschen G-Bait
im Nachhinein. Das war, ich glaub,
die wollten mal gucken, wie die Leute drauf reagieren, wenn man
irgendwas hinschmeißt, wovon sie gar keinen Plan haben.
Eigentlich gar keine so blöde Idee.
Da waren Fragen drinne, ey,
da wusste ich damals echt nicht genau. Aber,
ich kannte mich damals ein bisschen
Linux-mäßig schon aus, und ich hatte auch
ein bisschen schon mit Cisco-Switchen rumgespielt.
Das heißt, ich konnte den zumindest
ein paar Cisco-Befehle sagen, in diesem Test.
Und ich konnte denen auch ein paar
IP-Tables-Sachen sagen.
Und, das weiß ich heute noch,
und ich konnte ihnen sagen, wie man aus Wim
rauskommt. Die wollten, die wollten
wirklich wissen, wie man aus Wim rauskommt.
Und dann gab's noch ein paar andere doofe
Tests, so was weiß ich, das Zahlen, die man
sich merken soll, und ach, bla,
okay. Zumindest,
zumindest war der Test vorbei.
Zumindest, zumindest war der Test vorbei,
und danach musste man halt
nochmal, äh, zum Chef.
Oh, zu den zwei, zu den zwei Chefs.
Und,
die haben einen halt nochmal interviewt, so.
Und, das war dann, das war dann eigentlich so das
eigentliche Vorstellungsgespräch. So, und da
hab ich unbewusst,
unbewusst, glaub ich, was richtig gemacht.
Also, es war ja
keine Taktik oder so. Das hab ich aus der Not
heraus gemacht, weil ich nicht wusste, was ich sagen soll.
Und zwar, ich bin ins Büro
rein, und das erste, da hab ich mich
hingesetzt, und das erste, was ich
gesagt hab, war, oh, der Test war
schon ganz schön gemein.
Und,
wir hatten instant ein Gesprächsthema,
was in die Richtung ging, wie ich wollte.
Weil das, das nächste,
was die mich gefragt haben, ist, ja, warum?
Und dann konnt ich übelst
Technikkrams labern, dass die, dass
die gemerkt haben, dass ich, äh,
von manchen Sachen mich schon
ganz gut auskennen, ja.
Und da hab ich gesagt, ja, ich wusste genau, bei
IP-Tables haben wir die und die Tabellen,
aber, ähm, ich wusste
nicht mal genau, ob man, ob
der Engel jetzt dabei muss oder nicht.
Also sprich, ich, im Prinzip hab ich mich da drüber
ausgelassen, warum ich manche Sachen
in dem Test verkackt hab.
Und da wollten sie dann auch irgendwelche
Dinger wissen, so nach dem Motto, ähm,
was war denn das, ob ich wüsste,
ob ich wüsste, was die Firma macht, und solche
Geschichten, äh, nee, nee, nee, nicht,
ob ich wüsste, was die Firma macht, sondern sie haben
mir ein paar Sachen gesagt, die die Firma macht,
und ob ich mir darunter was vorstellen kann,
ähm,
zum Beispiel Monitoring, das weiß
ich noch, die haben mich gefragt, die, die
haben, die haben mich gefragt, ähm, ob ich mir unter
Monitoring was vorstellen könnte.
Da hab ich gesagt, ja, sowas wie Herzrate.
Sowas wie Herzrate, Alter.
Was steht da?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nein, nein,
nicht im Krankenhaus hat er gesagt.
Nicht im Krankenhaus.
So,
und, ähm,
ganz ehrlich, wir haben da eigentlich zehn Minuten ganz normal
gelabert, oder 15 Minuten, ich weiß gar nicht
mehr genau, und ganz ehrlich,
ich bin da rausgegangen und hab mir gedacht, okay,
war doch eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm,
und einen Tag später,
einen Tag später morgens,
um, frag mich, halb acht,
das waren Zeiten, da hab ich bis elf gepennt, oder so,
ähm,
haben die mich angerufen, und haben
gemeint, ja, ähm, ob ich
vorbeikommen will, Vertrag unterschreiben.
Sagt, hä, ich war doch gestern erst da,
ja, ja, sie haben sich schon entschieden.
Okay, ich komm vorbei.
Auf geht's.
Also das war wirklich easy im Nachhinein.
Und ich glaube, das war wirklich,
das lief auch nur so gut,
weil ich irgendwas Blödes
am Anfang gesagt hab, wie, oh, der Tester war
aber fies, weil dann ging's gleich in die
richtige Richtung, wo ich dann halt auch
was sagen konnte zu.
Ach ja, und, ähm, ähm,
ich weiß auch noch, ähm,
da war noch so ein anderer,
so ein anderer Typ dabei,
ähm, ich überleg grad,
es waren drei Leute dabei, und ich glaub,
einer hat danach auch noch mit mir angefangen.
Zumindest, da war so ein Typ dabei,
der, der, ultra korrekt.
Also, übelst rausgeputzt,
mit Anzug, Lederschuhen,
ähm,
gescheitelt, geharn,
gegelt, ey, Alter,
wie aus dem Ei gepellt, als bewirbt er sich jetzt irgendwie
für den Vorsitzenden von der Europäischen Zentralbank
oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, ist übelst, übelst
rausgeputzt. Und der Kerl,
der war, wahrscheinlich wollte er den Anzug gar nicht anziehen,
wahrscheinlich haben seine Eltern gesagt, oder so, Alter, zieh den
Anzug an, kommt gut an.
Der saß da,
der hat gezittert, der war fertig mit den Nerven.
Ich muss sagen, ich war auch übelst aufgeregt,
ja, ähm,
aber mir ist das merkwürdig.
Bei mir ist das merkwürdig.
Es ist ganz komisch.
Wenn ich, also,
ich hab so zwei, ich hab so zwei,
jaja, ich hab so
zwei Stufen.
Ich hab so zwei Stufen.
Wenn ich, also ich hab so ne,
ich hab so ne Stufe, ich bin aufgeregt,
und ich hab die Stufe,
ich hab Panik bei irgendwas, ja, also was weiß ich.
Wenn mich jetzt ein Hund halb anspringt,
dann hab ich Panik und hab natürlich Schiss.
Und krieg irgendein Adrenalinschub übelst,
krieg übelst Panik und sonst was, ja, okay.
Das kennt, glaub ich, jeder. Aber,
ähm,
wenn ich einfach nur aufgeregt bin,
dann ist es
bei mir meistens so, dass ich
gar nicht unbedingt, ich werd ein bisschen
hüppeliger, na, was im Prinzip jeder hat.
Du bist, du bist ein bisschen aufgeregter. Aber,
was ich hab ist, wenn ich aufgeregt
bin,
ich hab das, ich fang übelst,
ähm, an
über alles nachzudenken, so irgendwie. Also,
bei mir ist es so, bei mir geht das
aufgeregt sein weniger in,
in schwitzen und hüppelig werden über,
sondern zu, ähm,
irgendwie übelst
aufmerksam sich alles angucken, über alles
nachdenken und sonst wie. Also,
ich kann das, kann das, kann das, kann das
schlecht betreiben, beschreiben, ja.
Ich werd dann, ich werd dann, äh, für einen kurzen Moment
pfeifert. Das geht, das hält nicht lang.
Das hält nicht, das hält nicht lang, ja.
Ähm, so.
Zumindest, also ich,
was ich damit sagen will, ich war da natürlich auch
aufgeregt, aber halt so auf meine Art und Weise
aufgeregt, so.
Aber der andere Typ, der war halt
aufgeregt in Form von
halb angefangen zu schwitzen und zu zittern
und so, ja, ähm,
der, der war übelst fertig.
Der, der war übelst fertig.
Ähm, übrigens bei mir führt das dann auch dazu,
ich bin, wenn ich irgendwas, was präsentieren
muss oder so, da bin ich auch
aufgeregt vorher, aber irgendwie
ist das dann auch so ein Aufgeregtsein, dass
ich mich sogar drauf freue.
Weil, man hat sich dann drauf vorbereitet,
das Beste, was man übrigens machen kann, das ist mal so
ein Lifehack, ja.
Wenn ihr irgendwas machen müsst,
wie, wie was präsentieren, ich hab das früher
absolut ungern gemacht. Ich hab's gehasst.
Ich habe, ich habe präsentieren, vorstellen müssen,
müssen wir sagen, absolut gehasst.
Und, ähm,
bis ich dann irgendwann mal gemerkt habe,
dass dadurch,
dass man es
absolut ungern macht,
man sich auch noch
ungerner damit
beschäftigt. Und dadurch,
dass man es nicht gern macht,
sich damit auch nicht beschäftigt,
sind die Ergebnisse auch immer total beschissen.
Weil ich meine, was soll dabei rauskommen?
Stellt euch vor, man ist jemand, der nicht gerne
sich vorne alleine hinstellt und was präsentiert.
Und
man ist dann auch nicht drauf vorbereitet.
Was soll da am Ende rauskommen?
Es wird einfach kacke.
Das Ergebnis wird einfach peinlich und scheiße.
Ist ja logisch irgendwo, ja. Man hat eh schon
nicht so wirklich gutes Talent für und keinen Bock drauf.
Und man hat sich nicht vorbereitet und
es ist scheiße am Ende, was rauskommt.
So, aber was ich gemerkt habe ist,
wenn man sich
zumindest bei solchen Sachen
mit dem Thema beschäftigt,
das ist,
das ist die halbe Miete.
Man muss das Thema nicht mögen,
man muss es auch nicht geil finden,
sich vorne hinzustellen, aber wenn man sich
mit dem Thema, was man
vorstellen muss, beschäftigt hat,
dann hat man schon gefühlt mehr gemacht, als die meisten
anderen, die irgendwas präsentieren.
Und wenn man dann aufgeregt ist,
dann führt das zumindest
bei mir dazu, dass ich nicht
etwa anfange, die Sachen
zu vergessen oder so, sondern, dass
mir alles, was ich mir in der
Vorbereitung angeguckt habe und was ich
im Vorfeld auch schon mal geübt habe,
dass mir das dann
quasi alles auf einmal wieder einfällt.
Klingt letztendlich bescheuert.
Wenn ihr eine Präsentation schon ein paar Mal geübt habt,
ihr müsst euch nicht von Spiegel stellen,
ich bin jetzt auch niemand, der Ultra-Präsentation-
Guidelines, irgendwie How-To-Rhetorik
geben kann oder so, bin ich wirklich
der Letzte, der das wirklich gut
kann, aber ich kann es mittlerweile
ganz okay, würde ich sagen.
Und, wo auch ein bisschen Videos machen
auf YouTube geholfen haben, würde ich sagen.
Wenn ihr euch da vorbereitet
habt und das ein paar Mal
vor euch hin gesprochen habt oder am besten
auch mit ein paar Leuten, die ihr gern habt,
die ihr mögt, das mal gezeigt
habt und wenn ihr das
dann anfangt, eure Präsentation,
dann seid ihr natürlich ein bisschen nervös.
Aber dadurch,
dass ihr euch vorbereitet habt,
hilft es euch quasi
besser zu denken während der Präsentation.
Ihr seid dann nicht nervös, im Panikmodus
nervös, weil ihr wisst,
ihr habt euch eigentlich ganz gut vorbereitet,
sondern ihr seid dann einfach nur ein bisschen angespannt
und euch fällt dann
quasi mehr oder weniger spontan
immer, zumindest bei mir so,
zu dieser Situation das
Richtige ein, was ihr in der Vorbereitung
geübt habt.
Klappt wunderbar.
Und zumindest,
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn,
ich war ja beim
Vorstellungsgespräch und der eine Typ, der war halt
mega,
war halt total aufgeregt.
Der hat halt wie gesagt gezittert und so, scheiße, ich muss da jetzt rein.
Und es ist eine
Sache, das ist mir heute noch unangenehm,
wenn ich da drüber nachdenke.
Ich glaube, ich hab den übelst geschockt,
den Typ.
Ich wollte das überhaupt nicht.
Muss ich dazu sagen. Ich glaube, ich hab den übelst
geschockt. Und zwar,
wir haben da gehockt zu dritt, der eine Typ
schon übelst am zittern,
so fuck, fuck, fuck, gleich Vorstellungsgespräch,
Vorstellungsgespräch. Da kommen
die zwei halt raus und man so, okay,
wer möchte
anfangen? Wer möchte anfangen?
Und da haben wir uns alle so angeguckt und der Typ
so hat irgendwie kein Wort rausgekriegt.
Da hab ich halt gemeint, okay,
fang ich an und
dementsprechend, ne, erstes Gespräch,
zehn Minuten, zehn, fünfzehn Minuten, war ich auch als erstes fertig.
Logischerweise, es gibt ja nur zwei Chefs und wenn die dich
interviewen, können sie die anderen nicht interviewen.
Und da bin ich rausgegangen,
bin ich nochmal zu den anderen
zwei hin, hab gesagt, ja, tschüss, macht's gut.
Und da hat der eine quasi, und, und, wie war's?
Und da hab ich dann zu ihm gemeint so,
alter, was die alles wissen wollten
hier, boah,
ey, der ist fast, der ist fast
kollabiert, ey.
Das war überhaupt nicht meine Absicht,
ey. Das ist überhaupt
nicht meine Absicht gewesen. Der Typ, der war vorher
schon mega im Arsch.
Und ich, ey,
ich, ich, ich
glaub, der ist, der ist auseinander geschmolzen,
ey.
Und das wollte ich überhaupt nicht.
Das war so eher so ne spontane Sache, so,
so, das war ehrlich gesagt zu helfen, eher so,
boah, bin ich froh, dass ich's hinter mir hab, so nach
dem Motto. Das war wirklich keine Absicht.
Deswegen ist mir das heute auch noch unangenehm, wenn
ich da dran denke.
Ich, ich wollte den nicht
sabotieren in irgendeiner Art und Weise,
ja.
Tja.
Den hab ich danach auch nicht mehr gesehen.
Also,
der oder die andere,
die da noch, ich kann mich an den dritten oder
die dritte, die dabei war, gar nicht mehr erinnern,
wer das war. Aber der hat glaub ich danach
auch die Ausbildung noch angefangen.
Oder die? Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Der hat, wahrscheinlich hat der gedacht,
ich hab's absichtlich gemacht, ja.
Aber hab ich nicht. Hab ich echt nicht.
Wirklich nicht.
Das hab ich da überhaupt nicht dran gedacht in dem Moment.
Ich kann sowas gar nicht
predicted machen, da bin ich viel zu low brain für.
Der Friseur kann
sowas. Wenn der, wenn der
drauf anlegt, kann der die Leute auch unter den Tisch
labern, ey. Der Frasier.
Ähm, by the way,
wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Ich hab ehrlich keine Ahnung,
weil wir da drauf gekommen sind. Bewerbung.
Sonst wie. Ja.
Matt 9908.
Ich mach, ich mach's ein bisschen anders.
Also im Prinzip ähnlich,
aber ich mach's, ich mach's so.
Äh, hup.
Wo ist es? Alter.
Er schreibt hier, ich mach meine Präsentation immer ohne Notiz,
gehe vorher nur ein paar Mal die Logik schreiben.
Ich mach's ähnlich.
Wenn ich die, äh,
ich schreib mir am Anfang immer total viel auf.
Also,
so Unterschiede, so Sachen wie zum Beispiel,
ey, bei diesem Punkt kannst du dann das
sagen oder, vielleicht kannst du bei diesem Punkt
irgendwie so einen kleinen Gag machen oder sowas.
Sowas schreib ich mir immer auf, wenn ich gute Ideen zu den einzelnen
Punkten hab. Und dann probier ich,
wenn ich die Sache zwei, dreimal
testweise
halte, versuch ich diese Sachen einzubauen
und am Ende
hab ich auch keine Zettel dabei.
Ich hab, ich hab nie Notizen dabei.
Ich bin viel zu
konzentriert auf das jeweilige Thema.
Ich lese die Notizen eh nicht.
Absolut, no chance.
Also, und ich hab am Ende
trotzdem alles erzählt, was ich erzählen wollte.
Naja.
So, ich hoffe ich hab jetzt nichts übersehen.
Äh, wir sind nicht, wir sind nicht wirklich
weit gekommen mit Einkaufen heute, oder?
Kann das sein? Der Titel, der Titel
ist, der Titel des Streams, ich muss das
nochmal kurz betonen.
Der Titel des Streams ist, kurz Amazon
checken, Cyber Monday.
Ich habe kurz gecheckt.
Entr...
Ich hab auch nichts, das stimmt.
Also, ich hab jetzt 3 Stunden 40 gebraucht
und hab
nicht so viel gemacht, ehrlich gesagt.
Mir kommt eine Stimme
unfassbar bekannt vor, aber ich kann es nicht einhören.
Woher kennt man nicht? Guck dir mal mein Avatar
auf Twitch an, vielleicht fällst du dir dann ein.
Wenn nicht, dann
kennst du mich wahrscheinlich nicht von woanders.
Oder du hast den Avatar
nicht gemerkt, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Was, W...
Kelekon schafft WLAN to go im Heimrouter ab.
Was ist denn überhaupt WLAN to go?
Kenn ich nicht.
Sagt mir nichts.
Ich muss noch kurz...
Äh...
Ah, excellent Yoshi's Island Musik.
So, also
was wollten wir? Wir wollten auch noch irgendwas gucken.
Genau, ich wollte gucken, ob
es
gescheite Deals gibt.
Da ist mir aufgefallen, dass AliExpress total
Crap ist und man noch nicht mal sortieren kann
nach, ob
es jetzt ein Cyber Monday Deal ist oder nicht.
Kann man, kann man denn
bei Banggood wenigstens
sortieren, ob es ein Cyber Monday Deal ist
oder nicht? Nö.
Schwachsinn, Alter.
Oder sind das hier am Anfang alle Cyber Monday
Deals? Guck grad mal, ob ich
irgendwas übersehen hab im Chat, kurz.
Ich glaub nicht. Übrigens,
äh, ich muss grad nochmal reinschauen, ich hab bestimmt
irgendwelche Subs übersehen und bin ich irgendwie
sehr vertieft ins Geschwätze.
Ähm...
Übrigens auch für die ganzen Follows, die es noch
äh, gegeben hat.
Mach hier mal schnell Durchlauf. Ich les da normalerweise
nie die Follows vor, aber
warum nicht? Können wir mal machen.
Dann haben wir hier am Start Perimoth,
Sandgrab, Lensge...
Was?
LensGD, bitte?
Hab ich beim Komplettfalt ausgesprochen.
Tedem,
Warnus, äh,
PS485, Nikrotin,
Lukas360, äh 320,
nicht 360, fast.
Äh, DerKaiserSchnitt,
DerMultiKiller,
Skydive,
HiAlleMiteinander
und
Seekios
HerbsenXniton
Xniton
und DrKerem
Bayrakta.
Alles klar. Äh,
das war jetzt die letzte Stunde nur. Schön, dass ihr alle am Start seid.
Und der MasterHawk eben auch noch.
Excellent.
Haken by Sail. Wo ist Sail? Wo ist der Sail?
Wo ist hier Sail?
Bei AliExpress, meinste?
Wo ist hier ein Haken bei Sail?
Doch, von Youtube, genau.
Richtig.
Ja, excellent.
Hast du ja erkannt, ja.
Bei Banggood da steht Sail. Wo?
Ja, äh, wir haben gerade geguckt,
wie viel günstiger der gleiche 3D-Drucker ist,
wenn man ihn in China kauft.
Mitte oben.
Ach, da. Moment, warum
findet er Sail nicht, wenn ich Sail eingebe?
Oh, sag bloß, das ist ein Bild.
Das ist ein Bild.
Warum ist das ein Bild?
Die Chinesen wieder, ey.
Da werden Wörter auch als Bilder gemacht. Okay, Sail.
Also,
was haben wir denn da?
Warum soll ich 7 Euro für ein Modul bezahlen,
was auch nicht mehr hat als ein anderes Modul?
Viel zu...
Warum ist das so teuer?
The fuck, das sind ja fast...
Ach, Moment, ich hab Chips, hab ich noch Chips von Germany?
Ne, all regions.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Was ist mit euch los?
Hä?
Das kostet normalerweise 3,50?
Warum kostet es jetzt das Doppelte,
weil es Cyber Monday ist, oder wie?
Die Boards sind gut, die kann ich echt empfehlen.
Ah, hier. Hier haben wir noch 4,99.
Sag mal, Banggood ist Cheap Bait, oder?
Das ist überhaupt nicht im Sail.
Das kostet normalerweise auch nicht mehr.
Banggood ist komplett
das Cheap Bait.
Das ist einfach Cyber Monday dran,
und ist es überhaupt nicht.
Es kostet normalerweise immer so viel.
Ich hab noch nie
für den ESP32
und noch nie
12 Euro bezahlt.
Der kostet ja sogar 1 Euro Amazon.de nur 8 Euro.
Macht fast jeder so.
Ja, ist so, aber...
Das kostet jetzt ja genau das gleiche.
Es kostet genau das gleiche wie sonst.
Ja, Spatzgranate, ich wollte eigentlich auch
eine Stunde weg sein.
Und was ist das?
Ich dachte, das ist ein ESP266.
Es gibt doch gar keinen offiziellen
D1 Mini ESP32.
Oder doch?
Okay, gibt es da irgendwas, was sich lohnt an Boards?
Wo man sagt, hey, das bräuchte ich mal.
TTGO Camera Module.
Diese ESP-Cams finde ich total uninteressant.
Uninteressant.
Nichts interessantes dabei.
An Zäpfchen oder was?
Ach ne, das ist so ein
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor oder sowas.
Für ein Zäpfchen wäre es vielleicht auch
ein bisschen unangenehm.
Aber trotzdem, sieht schon ein bisschen so aus.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor.
Aber das sind die schlechten
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren, die
anfangen zu rosten mit der Zeit.
Oh, der ist gut.
Der ist tatsächlich nice.
Allerde...
Ach guck mal, den gibt es
auf dem kleinen Modul.
Okay, das ist
tatsächlich was, was mich interessiert.
Und zwar, das ist ein...
Was ist denn?
Das ist ein ESP32
mit einem SIM-Slot.
Da kann man zum Beispiel
GPS-Daten oder so verschicken, wenn man
einen GPS-Empfänger noch hat.
Gar nicht so übel.
Aber,
nichts, was ich jetzt unbedingt bräuchte.
Ne, ist glaube ich nichts spannendes bei
diesmal hier.
Ist es nicht wenig sinnvoll, dass Feuchtigkeitssensoren
rosten können? Nein, das ist nicht sinnvoll.
Deswegen ist der Sensor ja auch ziemlicher Müll.
Es gibt...
Es gibt ein paar verschiedene
Typen von so
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren.
Und es gibt welche, die machen das halt so,
die haben links und rechts ein bisschen Metall
und leiten da quasi
Strom dazwischen durch
und messen dann den Widerstand.
Anhand dessen sagen sie, wie
feucht oder trocken der Boden ist.
Das Problem ist dabei nur,
dass es anfängt zu rosten.
Also nicht nur anfängt zu rosten, sondern
es fängt auch an, die
Teile sich
vom Plastik zu lösen und so richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich meine, dann hast du einen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor,
der dann im Jahr kaputt ist.
Ich habe jetzt übrigens was Neues,
was Neues,
was Altes wiederentdeckt.
Und zwar, ich habe mir vor einer
ganzen Weile so einen
Fibaro Door,
also nicht Sebaro,
Fibaro Door Sensor gekauft.
Die ist jetzt nicht
mehr gibt.
Und zumindest
die Version, die ich davon habe,
an die kann man noch,
das ist eigentlich ein Sensor, wo man checken kann,
ob die
eine Tür oder
ein Gartentor
oder ein Fenster auf und zu ist.
Den macht man auf die einen Seite,
das kleine auf die andere Seite,
wenn du ein Fenster auf und zu machst, meldet das,
Fenster ist offen, Fenster ist zu.
Dieser Sensor, den gibt es auch in der Variante,
dass man noch einen Temperatursensor anschließen kann.
Und ich habe mir vor einer Weile die Variante gekauft,
Und
den stecke ich jetzt
in den Gartenteich,
den Temperatursensor, das ist so ein hier.
Die Dinger sind von Haus aus wasserdicht.
So sehen die Dinger aus,
Temperatursensoren.
Der sieht wirklich jetzt ein bisschen aus wie ein Zäpfchen.
Nein, ich habe mir die Simkarten
nicht gekauft, Clips 2.
Ich will mir die aber noch kaufen.
10 Euro für 10 Jahre.
Auch nicht viel Volumen, aber reicht dafür.
Und den will ich in den Fischteich hängen.
So, einen Zentimeter
oder so, ein bisschen in den Fischteich,
unter die Oberfläche.
Und da will ich, dass der mir
alle 6 Stunden ein Report schickt,
was die Temperatur im Fischteich ist.
Denn,
damit kann ich mir ableiten, ob ich den Fischteich
zudecken muss oder nicht.
Wenn es nämlich Richtung 0 geht,
von der
Oberflächentemperatur im Fischteich,
dann weiß ich, oh, jetzt wird es höchste Zeit,
den Fischteich abzudecken, weil,
wenn das unter 0 geht und anfängt
der Fischteich zu gefrieren, dann
platzt die Wand
im schlimmsten Fall umherum.
Und das Ding wird undicht.
Oder, was davor wahrscheinlich
passieren wird, dass die Farbe abplatzt
und sowas. Das Zudecken musst du auch
noch automatisieren, auch das stelle ich mir schwierig vor.
Aber gehen
tut alles irgendwie.
Aber,
die Idee hat was, finde ich.
Wie tief ist der Teich?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Also, vorne kann ich noch stehen.
Hinten kann ich nicht
mehr stehen. Also, ich denke
mal, vorne ist der irgendwie
was um 1,60
oder so.
Und hinten dürfte der vielleicht 2,20
oder sowas sein.
Zu geraten einfach mal.
Sauerstoffsensor habe ich keinen, das ist eine wirklich
sehr gute Idee.
Gibt es denn sowas?
Oh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Oh, das ist ganz schön teuer.
Ist eine gute Idee, weil ich habe da so eine
Pumpe drin, die halt Luft reinpumpt
in den Teich.
Ist doch wichtig, sonst gibt es so viele
Algen und Gedöns drin.
Was, GPS?
Nee, wozu? Achso, nee, Moment.
Was meinst du? Hä?
Was ist denn eine Netzklubkarte, kenne ich nicht.
Netzklub klingt nach irgendeiner
Erotik-18-Plus-Seite.
Und wo warst du heute im Netzklub?
Da ist ein Sim-Anbieter.
Ich habe schon nie was gehört.
Okay, zeig mal. Netzklub.
Netzklub-IoT-Sim.
Nö.
Kostenlose Sim-Karte?
Ja, wie verdienen die denn Geld, wenn das kostenlos ist?
Sponsored Surf Basic.
Moment, was soll das sein?
SMS-Werbung.
Moment
mal.
Ach, nur für vier Wochen danach kostet.
Ja, das ist doch bescheuert, das brauche ich das nicht.
Oder?
Ja, nee.
Das ist doch gar nicht kostenlos.
Was?
Ohne Grundgebühr für vier Wochen.
Heiß, johi, 12 Monate.
Das ist doch schon Hyper-Subscription.
Zeig mal her.
Und was haben die mit...
Ja, aber...
Was wollen die mir denn sagen
mit ohne Grundgebühr?
Die gibt es doch auch so
keine Grundgebühr.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Wir...
Nee, warum soll ich mir Brave holen?
Also, so wie ich das sehe, man bekommt
man bekommt
200 MB Daten
Volumen für 0 Euro
und man kriegt irgendwelche
SMS-Werbung. So, und jetzt
kommt der Trick.
Ob der geht, weiß ich nicht. Aber
was ich mit diesen
Sim-Karten ja vorhabe
ist,
ich möchte die in einen
Microcontroller stecken,
der dann irgendwo seinen Dienst verrichtet.
Der kann überhaupt keine SMS empfangen.
Was machen die denn
dann?
Oder meinetwegen, der kann...
Vielleicht kann der SMS
empfangen, aber ich werde sie nie lesen.
Und E-Mail ist ja auch
kein Ding. Ich kann so viele
E-Mail-Adressen machen, wie ich lustig bin.
Das mache ich. Das ist
eine echt Big-Brain-Idee.
Was muss man da alles angeben, wenn man das bestellt?
Bestellt man...
Nein, nein, nein.
Los geht's. Excellent.
Äh.
Ach stimmt, man muss sich ja... Man muss ja
mittlerweile... Muss man ja für Handysachen
sich auch gleich mit Ausweis und Geschiss
registrieren.
Wie hieß der andere...
Wie hieß dieser andere Job
noch... Andere Anbieter
noch mal, die wir letztens hatten für
10 Euro Sim
Lifetime...
Waren das die?
One Nice?
E-Mail...
Macht das jetzt über Amazon?
Ich habe keinen Bock mich da mit
Ausweis zu registrieren.
Ich will einfach ein ESP32 mit Sim
irgendwo hinstellen. Ich will nicht meinen Lebenslauf abgeben.
Also ich brauche... Ich brauche wirklich
nicht viel Übertragungsrate.
Also für ein bisschen GPS-Daten
übertragen, das sind Bytes.
Das sind Bytes. Also das
ist nicht viel.
Ja, ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
dass Ausweis-Registrierungsgesetz nicht vorgeschrieben ist,
aber ich meine, wenn das ein Anbieter in England ist oder so...
Ich will da meinen Lebenslauf nicht abgeben. Ganz ehrlich.
Und dann
klaut mir noch einer den Controller und macht mit der
Sim-Karte irgendeinen Scheiß und...
Nee...
Wo kommt man sich den Kram jetzt noch mal kaufen hier? Shop?
Ja...
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü...
Okay, die wollen
wenigstens keinen Ausweis. Die wollen wenigstens schon mal
keinen Ausweis hier.
IoT-Pilot...
Auch nicht schlecht. Gucke ich mir alles nachher an.
Muss ich mir erst mal überlegen. Brauche ich...
Ich brauche es eigentlich gar nicht. Ich wollte es noch mal ausprobieren.
Und ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich meinen Lora...
Lora, ähm...
Friedhofs...
Überwachungsprojekt...
nicht doch mit einer Sim-Karte mache.
Oh... Leute...
Wisst ihr was?
Ich weiß, wir haben...
nicht komplett uns durchgekämpft durch Amazon.
Aber...
Ich... Mir tut...
Ich habe ganz trocken an den Hals. Ich muss jetzt was...
äh... was trinken gehen.
Friedhofsüberwachung. Ja.
Und zwar, was ich probiert habe,
ist...
einen
Auf-Fried-Kontroll-Sensor
auf den Friedhof zu packen.
Mit einem Micro-Controller.
So dass ich immer mitbekomme,
wann ich das Grab von Opa und Oma gießen muss.
Big Brain.
Ich bin da auch so öfters mal. Aber gerade im Sommer weiß man nie,
ob man da jeden zweiten Tag,
jeden dritten Tag hin muss, oder ob es mal geregnet hat.
Und da wollte ich den Boden von einem kleinen...
also wirklich nur einen ganz kleinen Controller.
Ähm...
Ich habe es jetzt schon ausprobiert.
Also das funktioniert prinzipiell mit LoRa schon.
Ähm...
1,4 Kilometer ist das Ganze weg.
Also Übertragung über 1,4 Kilometer funktioniert.
Mit LoRa geht es.
Mit LoRa habe ich schon ausprobiert.
Mit LoRa funktioniert es.
Allerdings, ich stelle es mir mit der Sim-Karte
ein bisschen einfacher vor auf Dauer.
Weil LoRa hat ein bisschen rumgespackt.
Schlechtes Wetter hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Auch so war das nicht so hundertprozentig zuverlässig.
Das muss ich mal sagen.
Das sind 1,4 Kilometer.
Das geht durch Häuser durch.
Das ist, ähm...
Ja, nicht die besten Voraussetzungen.
Ähm...
Deswegen wollte ich es mal probieren, ob es mit einer Sim besser funktioniert.
Zeig mal den besten Deal.
Lull.
Habe ich überhaupt einen Deal gefunden, der was getaugt hat?
Hey, ich habe mir einen...
Ich bestelle mir einen Bosch Professional Knife Set.
Excellent.
Ich glaube, das war das einzige...
Ach nee, ich habe da noch...
Äh...
Irgendwelches Klebeband geordert.
Total sinnlos.
Wirklich nichts dabei.
Großartig für mich.
Was ich brauchen würde.
Welchen Spreading Factor hast du genutzt?
Ich habe das allerlangsamste eingestellt.
Also ich habe eingestellt,
dass...
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, welche Settings da was waren.
Dass der quasi richtig lang
so ein...
Sende-Window macht.
Und dass der dann auch noch richtig wenig
da drin schickt.
Also ich habe das langsamste aller Zeiten eingestellt.
Und das ging.
Also das...
Hat schon funktioniert.
So Leute, ich muss...
Ich muss was trinken.
Und ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Macht's gut, wir sehen uns nächstes Mal.
Bis denn. See you.